Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Was hast du vergangenen Sonntag gemacht?
Ich war in einem Elektronikmarkt.
Du profaner Banause. Ich glaube, du offenbarst dich wieder als perfekt passend in den Zeitgeist. Wir beerdigen einen Papst und ernen Wolfram Weimer zum Kulturchef. Und du gehst in den Elektronenglas.
An einem Sonntag. Ja, wie kann das sein? Ich habe mich erinnert, dass ich als Kind hin und wieder mal verkaufsoffene Sonntage besucht habe, aber sonst nie. Diesmal aber bestand eine gewisse Not. Und diese Not ist auch zugleich die Einleitung in eine neue Ära. Ja, ich will sagen, ich habe eine Schlacht verloren. Pass auf, mein Auto ist ja schon sehr in die Jahre gekommen. Und jetzt ist es tatsächlich an dem Punkt, an dem man sagen muss, noch mal Geld reinstecken, noch mal in die Werkstatt und so. Das lohnt sich nicht mehr. Ich brauche ein neues Auto. Ich habe auch ein neues Auto gefunden und unterschrieb dann den Kaufvertrag. Und der Verkäufer sagt zu mir, ja Herr Schmitt, wenn Sie es dann abholen, denken Sie nur dran, das Smartphone mitzunehmen, dann bekommen Sie ja Ihre ID und dann wird das konfiguriert und und und und und. Und ich sagte, Moment, stopp. Ich zückte mein Nokia und sagte, das ist mein Handy. Und dann sagte er, na ja, also das wird natürlich dann schwierig. Also Sie können es natürlich trotzdem fahren, aber Sie können dann ja dies und das nicht. Und dann führte er das immer alles weiter aus. Woraufhin ich dann dachte, gut, es ist wahrscheinlich der Punkt gekommen, an dem ich mich nicht mehr wehren kann, es sei denn, ich sage, ab sofort fahre ich nur noch Oldtimer. Was habe ich also getan? Ich musste dann relativ schnell ein Smartphone haben, damit das auch mir jemand einrichtet, da ich das ja gar nicht selbst machen kann. Und am Sonntag war dann dafür Zeit. Und so bin ich in diesen Elektronikmarkt und habe ein iPhone gekauft. Dass ich jetzt morgen fertig konfiguriert bekomme. Also heute ist mein letzter Tag in Freiheit. Ich war aber schon bei der Konfiguration in Teilen dabei, weil man ja hin und wieder sein Gesicht in die Kamera halten muss. Und für mich ist es so...
Wer hat es denn für dich konfiguriert? Hast du es im Laden gemacht?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ein Freund hat mir das konfiguriert, oder er ist jetzt gerade dabei. Also im Abend dann nicht.
Aber er ist jetzt gerade dabei, also so lange dauert das auch nicht.
Naja, ich muss ja erstmal einen Vertrag dafür bekommen. Ich hab ja, das ist ja alles jetzt völlig neu für mich, ja. Ich muss mein Gesicht in die Kamera halten und Worte sagen wie Motorrad, Holunder, damit sie irgendwelche Gesichtserkennungen durchführen können.
Ja, Siri ist jetzt deine Freundin.
Und ich muss sagen, dass es sich für mich anfühlt, als würde ich ein Stück Autonomie aufgeben. Ich komme mir wirklich vor, bislang konnte ich mich immer raushalten und jetzt ist es nicht mehr möglich. Also wir sind an einem Punkt angekommen, an dem ich sagen kann, mein Leben wird so viel komplizierter, wenn ich jetzt kein Smartphone habe. So muss ich also jetzt eins haben, um überhaupt die normalen Dinge, zum Beispiel ein Auto fahren, noch machen zu können.
Ich würde sagen, das Smartphone musst du ja gar nicht als Smartphone verstehen. Es werden ja sehr viele Leute abgeholt, bei denen du denkst, ich nicht. Du kannst also auch das Smartphone, das du gekauft hast, wie ein fester Konsolenteil einfach im Auto verbauen. Und den Moment, wo du es einschaltest, geht es an und ist halt das Interface zum Auto.
Ganz richtig. Was ich jetzt schon sagen will, ist, ich werde nicht diese ganzen Apps mir runterladen, mit denen ich sieben Messenger in Familiengruppen und sonst irgendwas habe. Das will ich alles gar nicht machen. Ich will diese Dinge, Navi und ID und was man da so alles braucht. Das ist ja hilfreich, aber ich möchte nicht diesen ganzen Klumpasch jetzt da haben. Denn ich merke wirklich, dass die Freiheit geringer wird. Also ich kann natürlich sagen, es ist alles so wahnsinnig praktisch und ich kann da und dort klicken und machen und tun. Aber ich habe gerade schon bei dieser Konfiguration erlebt, wie sehr man doch eigentlich plötzlich sich dem unterwerfen muss. Und das ist für mich sehr unangenehm.
Bei dir ist einfach alles falsch rum. Typischerweise erzählen die Leuten Geschichten von früher, wie sie auch im Auto telefonieren konnten.
Ja.
Und du erzählst Geschichten von heute, wie du nur im Auto telefonieren konntest. Ist eigentlich nicht schlecht. Aber vielleicht kommst du ja dazu, dass du denkst, krass, ich muss hier parken, aber ich bin ja eigentlich noch gar nicht da. Ich mache die Navi weiter bis zur Haustür. Und dann nimmst du das Handy einfach in die Hand und gehst die letzten Meter, lässt dich leiten. Und das ist ja, finde ich, immer noch die beste Metapher auch. Google Maps lotst uns durch den Verkehr, wie uns Google durchs ganze Leben führt. Und der eigentliche Sinn von Navigation ist ja gar nicht Navigation im Raum, sondern Navigation in der Zeit. Also Leute wissen eigentlich ganz genau, weil es ist ja sozusagen das Schicksal des modernen Menschen, dass er eigentlich die immer selben Wege hin und her pendelt. Nur er möchte wissen, wie ist der Verkehr. Und vor allem, wann komme ich an? Und dann sagt das Navi einfach, wenn du jetzt losgehst, bist du in 37 Minuten da. Und das ist nicht die beste Funktion, über die niemand so richtig nachdenkt, obwohl sie jeder genauso benutzt.
Ja, da habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen und werde so etwas selbstverständlich nutzen. Aber ich habe tatsächlich so diese...
Da reinzurutschen ist nicht verkehrt.
Ja, ganz richtig. Aber was da sonst noch alles so dran hängt, da habe ich tatsächlich den Eindruck, dass ich es nicht mehr länger schaffe, es aufrecht zu halten. Also es ist wirklich so als... Ich habe ja so lange es geschafft, dem aus dem Weg zu gehen. Sicherlich auch mit Hürden, die ich dann genommen habe. Oder die Sache auch, dass ich ständig irgendwo fragen muss, wo geht es denn jetzt lang? Oder auch für irgendwelche Strecken, ein Taxi genommen habe, wo man sagen könnte, das hätte man mit der U-Bahn wahrscheinlich besser hinbekommen, wenn man es hätte googeln können und so weiter. Aber das habe ich ja alles gemacht. Und das hat mir am Ende sehr viel mehr Freiheit gebracht, würde ich sagen. Und dass ich jetzt an so einem Punkt bin, an dem ich sagen kann, es ist nicht mehr möglich, das finde ich gruselig.
Du müsstest eigentlich jetzt ein Techniktagebuch führen, so wie Kathrin...
Passig?
Passig, genau. Damals, indem du so Sachen aufschreibst, wie dann fragte ich nach dem Weg und sie schaute mich an und fragte zurück, hä, führen wir heute nicht nur noch Selbstgespräche, wieso reden sie mit mir? Ja, oder solche Sachen könnten dann auftauchen. Ja, interessant. Also ich hoffe, das ist eine laufende Erzählung. Ich möchte jetzt jeden Monat die Nisten drei Monate absägen zu diesen.
Du kannst jetzt triumphieren, dass du mich jetzt auch zum Apple-Jünger gemacht hast. Ja, ja, natürlich.
Dass du dir ein Apple-Ding gekauft hast, ist ja schon mal, wie kam es dazu? Typischerweise geht man ja nicht in einen allgemeinen, da liegen ja eigentlich immer 100 Android-Telefone und dann gibt es halt nochmal so einen Apple-Tisch.
Das wurde extra geholt auch, dieses iPhone. Wolltest du ein iPhone oder warum machen wir den nicht? Das hast du mir ja schon immer empfohlen.
Also ich finde es eine sehr richtige Entscheidung. In dem Falle bin ich wirklich ganz...
Und der gute Freund, der mir das jetzt einrichtet, hat auch gesagt, also Apple und ich habe es ehrlich gesagt auch deshalb geholt, weil ihr alle Apple habt. Das heißt, wenn ich meine Schwierigkeiten bekomme, wenn ich jetzt demnächst hier in Frankfurt stehe und mein Auto nicht mehr fährt, weil mein Apple-Gerät irgendwas macht, dann kann ich dich einfach fragen und du wirst es dann alles wieder in Gang setzen.
Ja, ich freue mich da auch sehr drauf, denn jedes Mal, wenn es heißt, es gibt ein 3 Update des Betriebssystems, gucke ich mir sofort sieben Videos an, um immer auf der Höhe der Zeit zu sein. Also ich glaube, ich kenne alle Einstellungsmöglichkeiten und jede einzelne Bedienungshilfe. Ich zeige dir dann, was du mit drei Tipps auf dem, was du alles auslösen kannst.
Ja, aber nicht, dass du mir nachher 70 Sachen draufspielst und ich aufständig nur noch damit beschäftige, irgendwelche Pings zu verwalten.
Das ist natürlich mein Ziel, dich jetzt zu infizieren.
Jaja, also da sind wir jetzt hingekommen. Die Autonomie des Subjekts ist vorbei. Tut mir leid, aber es geht nicht anders.
Ein ganz neuer Wolfgang wird das jetzt.
Ja, und jetzt bekommt Apple eine Strafe. Kaufe ich gerade ein iPhone, gibt es gleich eine Strafe. Wir hören da mal rein, ein Tagesschaubericht.
Milliardenfach werden die Geräte von Apple verkauft und das Unternehmen entscheidet, welche Apps, also Programme, auf den Telefonen oder Tablets installiert werden dürfen. Die EU-Kommission sagt, Apple habe im eigenen App Store andere Anbieter benachteiligt. Wer seine Dienste in diesem App Store verkauft, muss seine Kunden eigentlich hinweisen dürfen, dass es die Angebote woanders außerhalb des App Stores auch günstiger gibt. Es muss auch möglich sein, die Kunden dorthin umzuleiten. Wir wollen sicherstellen, dass Innovationen in der EU auf den Markt kommen können, dass niemand seine sehr dominante Marktposition nutzt, um andere Innovationen auszuschließen oder die Auswahl der Verbraucher einschränkt. Die zuständige EU-Kommissarin, heute zu Besuch bei einem Supercomputer in Jülich, sagt, wer sich nicht an europäische Spielregeln halte, müsse Strafe zahlen. 500 Millionen Euro im Fall Apple, das Unternehmen, will dagegen Beschwerde einlegen. Die Entscheidung schade der Sicherheit der Nutzer.
Längst überfällig, fast möchte man sagen, auch aus einer vergangenen Zeit. Denn diese Art von Log-in-Effekt, die vor allem das Social-Media-Zeitalter prägt und darüber hinaus eben alle Geräte, die uns Social Media nahe führen, wurde wirklich krass ausgebeutet von diesen Unternehmen. Wir sind jetzt in der neuen Zeit, jetzt ist es KI. Und KI ist ja große Pluralität. Es gibt verschiedene Anbieter und große Konkurrenz. Die alle Promts, die ich benutze, habe ich einfach in einer separaten App gespeichert. Die kann ich also überall abfeuern. Einfach ein Anbieter auszutauschen ist gar kein Problem. Und das war 20 Jahre lang nicht so. Diese Empfehlung, kauf dir doch ein Apple und nichts anderes. Du hast ja selber jetzt gesagt, weil ich es auch habe und alle anderen und so, da ist man sofort drin in diesem Log-in-Effekt. Und den hat Apple einfach in alle kleinsten Kapillaren, App-Store, der Chip zum Bezahlen, alles wurde auf Apple zugeschnitten. Und jetzt, ich schlafe immer noch viel zu klein, aber...
Genau, über die sollten wir jetzt mal reden. Wir haben noch mal einen kleinen Kommentar aus der Tagesschau dazu. Also auch interessanten langer Bericht, also 100 Sekunden hat man dem ganzen eingeräumt. Das ist schon relativ viel für eine solche doch eher technikpolitische Aktion.
Eine Sekunde pro 0,7 Mio.
Zweite Strafe 200 Millionen Euro für den Meta-Konzern, zu dem unter anderem Facebook und Instagram gehören. Der Vorwurf bis November 2024 habe des Unternehmen Kunden vor die Wahl gestellt, entweder personalisierter Werbung zustimmen oder zahlen für eine werbefreie Version. Kritik an der Entscheidung. Die EU-Kommission versucht, erfolgreiche amerikanische Unternehmen zu behindern. Die US-Tech-Krisen wehren sich schon länger gegen die Digitalgesetze der EU. Die EU-Kommission betont, die Verfahren hätten mit dem Zoll- und Handelskonflikt mit Donald Trump nichts zu tun. Und doch, auch wenn die Situation mit den USA angespannt ist, die EU scheut sich nicht davor, die US-Tech-Krisen mit Strafen zu belegen.
Ja, sie scheut sich nicht, aber du hast schon gesagt, es ist sehr gering. Also wie ist denn eigentlich dieser Digital Markets Act ausformuliert? Nämlich dieser DMA besagt ja eigentlich, dass man bis zu zehn Prozent des Jahresumsatzes des Konzerns als Strafe verhängen darf.
Global, nicht nur der europäische Umsatz.
Genau, der globale Umsatz. Das heißt, der weltweite Umsatz von Apple war 2024 sehr hoch, nämlich der lag bei 383 Milliarden.
Ja, sehr hoch.
Das heißt, man könnte 38 Milliarden etwa als Strafe veranschlagen. Man hat jetzt aber 500 Millionen veranschlagt. Bedeutet 0,15 Prozent vom Jahresumsatz, 24, statt zehn Prozent. Bei Meta ähnlich, nicht ganz so hoch. Also Jahresumsatz 135 Milliarden. Da hat man jetzt auch nur 200 Millionen berechnet. Das heißt, man hat statt zehn Prozent 0,17 Prozent genommen. Die Frage ist ja, was will man jetzt eigentlich damit bezwecken? Also man kann natürlich jetzt sagen, es ist möglich, dass Apple und Google neue Wege suchen, um das nicht wieder zu provozieren, dass eine Strafe kommt. Meinetwegen. Aber man wird sie ja jetzt nicht groß davon abhalten, wieder schnell vorwärts zu gehen und dann zu gucken, ob sie das irgendwie später nochmal einholt. Denn das ist ja in etwa so, wenn ich jetzt meine gesamte Einkommenssteuer hinterziehe und man mir dann sagt, Herr Schmitt, so geht es aber nicht. Sie zahlen jetzt mal 150 Euro Strafe, aber sie müssen die Steuer nicht zahlen. Dann denke ich mir, na gut, die 150 Euro, das ist ja gut. Also das ist ja im Prinzip ein Knöllchen, das man denen jetzt da gegeben hat. Mehr nicht, deswegen schafft man nicht das Auto ab.
Also diese Art von, ich sage jetzt auch da mal, Log-In-Effekte, dass der Staat mittlerweile auf Infrastruktur angewiesen ist, die er nun auch marktwirtschaftlich als externe Irritation sozusagen zur Verfügung hat, in die er sich dann nicht reintraut, haben wir überall. Ein Beispiel ist sozusagen von der sozialen Tragweite genauso, aber jetzt ein anderes Metier. Mobilität hier in Frankfurt am Main.
Ja.
Ein Taxi zu fahren ist teuer, aber da weiß man, das sind angestellte Leute, die haben Stundenlohn, die sind sozialversichert und so weiter. Dann gab es Uber, wo es schon hieß, da weiß man nicht so genau, Uber wirkt halt irgendwie an, und dann machen die Leute so ein bisschen begleitetes Fahren und irgendwann auf eigene Faust, App-Angebot, alles wird versteigert, es regnet, es kostet zwei Euro mehr. Okay, jetzt gibt es Bolt. Mit Bolt kannst du durch Frankfurt eine halbe Stunde lang fahren und es kostet dich zehn Euro.
Wie kann das sein?
Das kann gar nicht sein. Genau. Das ist einfach nur, weil die Stadt trotz schlechtem Gewissens sagt, wir brauchen diese Mobilität. Wir haben den Nahverkehr verschrottet, Ticket kostet 3,80 Euro. Wenn jemand zum Döner fahren will, kostet der Döner 8 Euro, das Ticket 3,80 Euro. Das macht alles keinen Sinn. Zum Sushi ja, aber so nicht. Also lässt man es zu, dass hier einfach, keine Ahnung, ein paar tausend superarme Bolt-Fahrer noch den Wirtschaftskreislauf am Laufen halten, der Mobilität braucht. Und so ist das auch hier. Wir sehen ja, dass wir diese riesigen Zollstreite haben und Donald Trump zum Glück zu dumm ist, um zu verstehen, wie die moderne Welt funktioniert und er das nur an Atome hängt. Ja. So. Und die Europäer dann schon überlegen, sollten wir diesen digitalen Dienstleistungssektor eigentlich mal Revanche-Zoll blocken? Also, ich habe mir vorgestellt, jedes Update kostet irgendwie einen Euro oder so. Und ich denke mir, nee, so wie die Chinesen gerade die amerikanischen Häfen austrocknen lassen und Amazon schon solche Moves macht wie, wir schreiben mal lieber dran, dass Trump dran schuld ist, wie viel es kostet. Und dann gibt es eigentlich einen Zollstreit zwischen Amazon und Trump, so um die Frage, wer gewinnt das Blame Game und so. Also, wenn die Europäer sagen würden, wir machen jetzt mal die digitale Infrastruktur teurer, die so aus Amerika kommt. Und die deutschen Unternehmen hätten nur eine Ahnung davon, also so eine Angst davor, dass sie mal eine Woche lang keine Google-Suche und kein GPT nutzen könnten.
Und PayPal wird schwierig.
Da wäre hier Ende Gelände. Und daher lässt man diese Unternehmen lieber ein bisschen in Ruhe.
Ganz richtig, denn die Rechnung von Donald Trump ist ja völlig idiotisch, wenn man sich nur mit der Hardware beschäftigt. Ja, also wir werden da noch drüber sprechen. Und die Software, also das wäre ja genau die Dienstleistung, wäre Word funktioniert nicht, WhatsApp funktioniert nicht und und und.
Wir bestrafen jetzt die Amerikaner, indem wir uns die Google-Suche ausschalten. In Redaktionsschluss ein zehn Jahre altes Buch von mir, ja, steht schon drin. Google kann einfach, die sehen ja, wer unter welcher IP was googelt. Die wissen einfach 17 Uhr, wie die FAZ vom nächsten Tag aussieht. Weil jeder Artikel, jede Überschrift, jeder Rechtschreibfehler wurde einmal durch die Google-Suche gejagt. So, die sind so abhängig, diese Unternehmen, von allem. Den kannst du jetzt nicht ausschalten.
Ja, und deshalb ist das hier natürlich schön.
Das alternativlose allgemeine Infrastruktur.
Schön, dass man es mal gemacht hat. Da ist die EU wenigstens mal in der Tagesschau mit irgendwas. Aber eigentlich ist das kein großer Akt. CBS News hat es auch aufgegriffen. Da war Matt Binder zu Gast. Der sagt jetzt Folgendes dazu, dass jetzt die Konzerne sehr genervt darauf reagieren, sehr empört sind, wenngleich sie ja sich eigentlich bedanken müssten. Also das ist natürlich auch so ein Spiel, dass die jetzt sagen müssen, wie unglaublich das ist, was die EU sich da rausnimmt. In Wahrheit müssten die ja sagen, ja wunderbar, dass wir so glimpflich davongekommen sind. Wie gesagt, Stichwort Steuerhinterziehung, wenn man da nur gesagt bekommt, hier sind 150 Euro Strafen, sonst ist alles super, würde man sagen wunderbar, wir sprechen uns nächstes Jahr wieder. Aber nein, die wüten jetzt auch. Und interessanterweise verknüpfen die das gleich mit Trumps Lieblingswort, nämlich Tariffs.
So, Matt Binder, ein Reporter von Mashable, uns jetzt live mit mehr auf das. Danke, dass du hier bist.
Frage für dich. Metta nennt das ein Verbrechen, wie ein Tariff.
Was meinen sie von dem?
Ja, klar. Danke, dass du mich hast.
Ich denke, die Grundlage, warum Metta das Tariff nennt, ist, weil sie wissen, dass das jetzt ein bisschen die Buzzerworte ist, die die breiteren amerikanischen Publiken mitfahrend sind und ein negativer Sentiment gegen Tariffe haben. Also hoffen sie, dass das Publikum in der gleichen negativen Weise sieht. Die EU legt ein Tariff auf eine amerikanische Firma, Metta, die Facebook, Instagram und diese Services, die du genießen kannst.
Aber in der Wahrheit ist Metta für die Verbrechung der EU-Lahmung beigetragen. Ja, es ist eine Strafe und kein Zoll.
Aber ich hätte es lustig gefunden, wenn du dir ein Auto kaufst, dann hörst du, ich brauche dafür ein Smartphone. Dann kaufst du dir ein Smartphone und am selben Tag ist die Nachrichtenlage, jedes App-Update kostet jetzt euren und so weiter. Und du so, oh Mist. Ja, diese schöne neue Welt, von der mir immer erzählt wurde, ist einfach nur auch für alle anderen. Das ist 15 Jahre Vergangenheit und du steigst quasi am Tiefpunkt ein, wenn alles kotz und klein geschlagen wird.
Ich hatte dann auch noch das Handelsblatt zu Hause liegen, das ich dann am Abend las. Und dort war noch mal ein großer Artikel darüber, dass Apple ja seine Produktion auf China abziehen will, eben in Indien hauptsächlich produzieren will, wenngleich diese ganzen Rohstoffe, die man braucht, um in Indien zu produzieren, weiterhin aus China kommen. Aber das ist ganz interessant, dass ich eigentlich an einen Punkt zu Apple gehe, an dem wirklich mal dieses Unternehmen in großen Turbulenzen sich befindet. Und ich bin übrigens auch dann extra in diesen Elektronikmarkt am verkaufsoffenen Sonntag, weil ich dachte, hier kann man noch so ein bisschen sehen, wie so der Laden läuft, ja. Also wie funktioniert Deutschland? Also man freut sich auf diesen verkaufsoffenen Sonntag. Ich hab vor mir ein paar stehen, die beide Mann wie Frau tragen Vincent Weiß T-Shirts. Weißt du, dieser Pop-Sänger. Und ich, also es war eine interessante Stimmung dort. Und für viele war es auch, glaube ich, ein großes Ereignis. Also ich glaube, wenige sind mit so einem bedrückten Gefühl dahin gegangen wie ich, sondern für viele war das jetzt eher so ein...
Du hast jetzt meine Fuß fesselt...
.ein Freiheitsgewinn, dass sie ein neues Smartphone sich kaufen.
Ja, ja. Aber wahrscheinlich warst du ja im Laden unseres neuen Digitalministers.
Das ist naheliegend, ja. Ganz genau. Unser neuer Digitalminister.
Also zu diesen Zeulsachen, die haben wir ja eigentlich schon gut vorbereitet im Salon. Also wir haben ja über Mirrens Plan und Ben, wie heißt er, Bezent, also Finanzminister, Chief Economic Advisor und alle, wir haben ja die Literaturgrundlage schon gelegt. Wir wissen jetzt Bescheid, wie das ist mit Seewege freischießen, Dollar bereitstellen, Zölle und so. Deswegen machen wir nachher eine ausführliche Zollbesprechung, bei der auch klar wird, das ist wirklich Trumps Signature Politik. Also man kann jetzt die ganze Zeit darunter leiden, das ja hier und da und die Abschiebung und so weiter. Wenn man sich Orientierung verschaffen will, räumt man das alles zur Seite und sagt, ist auch wichtig, aber diese Zollpolitik ist es. Und zwar auch die, die Trump das Genick brechen wird. Also ist auch ein schönes Schauspiel. Wir müssen nachher bei der Beobachtung der amerikanischen Zollpolitik eigentlich das chinesische Jahrhundert ausrufen.
Ja.
Denn die Sachen scheinen jetzt ziemlich geritzt zu sein. Vorher aber Weimar. Du hast irgendwie Weimars Buch gelesen.
Ich bin nicht mit vielem da beschäftigt, aber du hast ja erst musst du sagen, du hast ja im Gegensatz zu mir den Sonntag nicht in Elektronikmärkten verpasst, sondern du hast dich mit dem Papst weiterhin beschäftigt.
Ich war in Wien mehrere Tage jetzt und habe mir dort alles angeschaut, was die Stadt so bietet. Ich war also auch in der Schatzkammer und die Schatzkammer ist, also es gibt so zwei Schatzkammern, ist ja klar, Wien ist ja groß. Die Habsburger liegen dann irgendwo am Stadtrand, aber es gibt im Zentrum eine Schatzkammer, direkt da Hufburg näher und so. Und es ist wahnsinnig interessant, man kommt so rein und es ist plötzlich so dunkel und man darf auch nicht fotografieren und man sieht so Stoffe, bei denen es heißt, nee, wenn mir da zu viel Licht draufscheint, dann machen die Protonen irgendwie den Stoff kaputt oder was auch immer. Und umso weiter man in die Vergangenheit zurückgeht und es reicht ja da bis zur Reichskrone, wo die Jahre noch dreistellig waren und so. Alles genauso erhalten, wie damals gemacht. Umso mehr fällt die staatliche und die sakrale Macht eigentlich zusammen. Ja. So, also ist ja dieses Prinzip, wie es halt so ist, ne? Und dann kamen wir zurück in die Wohnung und dann lief grad die Papstbeerdigung. Ich sah sie bei YouTube, bin nochmal zurückgesprungen und hab mir gedacht, nee, die Idee war vielleicht nicht allzu gut zu sagen, ich habe irgendwie dieses höchste Abend der Welt, aber gleichzeitig will ich die Beerdigung bitte so langweilig wie möglich. Wobei es immer noch witzig ist, zu sagen, es ist eine super langweilige Beerdigung, es waren nur 100 Kardinale da und so. Aber es war halt nicht viel los. Er wurde ja diese Stufen da reingetragen, man hat quasi nur mit diesen Trägern mitgelitten, weil sie schon die ganze Zeit so zwei Hände brauchten und er war echt schwer und überhaupt. Und in dieser ganzen ewigen Prozession da rein wurden ja wirklich nur ein Chorus gesunken die ganze Zeit. Also man hat ja auch irgendwann genug davon gehabt, ich musste wirklich leiser machen, weil ich habe das jetzt gehört, so irgendwann wurde es auch nervig. Dann stellte sich aber raus, so langweilig war es gar nicht, denn der Papst hat ja einen tollen Kniff gemacht. Und ich erinnerte mich an meinen Besuch in Rom im Dezember 2023 und fand es plötzlich das Genialste überhaupt. Wir hören das mal hier in den Nachrichten zuerst. Etwas gedämpft im Heute-Journal.
Der Papst hatte bestimmt, dass er nicht im Petersdom, sondern in der Basilika Santa Maria Maggiore zur letzten Ruhe gebettet wird. Das heißt also, zusätzlich zur Feier auf dem Petersplatz muss auch ein Trauerzug durch das gesamte historische Zentrum organisiert und abgesichert werden.
Sehr schön.
Da hat sie aber noch mal vor Ort durch Rom tragen lassen. Sie sagt jetzt so, ja, das muss dann noch organisiert werden und so weiter und so fort. Einen Tag später dann in den Tagesthemen wirklich kommt gut drüber, ob der Plan aufging.
Und dann eine Besonderheit, die auf jeden Fall noch erwähnenswert ist. Papst Franziskus wurde ja nicht wie viele seiner Vorgänger hinter mir im Petersdom beerdigt, sondern in der Basilika Santa Maria Maggiore. Die befindet sich auf der anderen Seite des Tibers, so ungefähr sechs Kilometer von hier entfernt. Und um dahin zu gelangen, ist Papst Franziskus oder der Leichnam des Papstes mit einem Trauerzug im Schritttempo durch die Stadt gefahren worden. Es waren spektakuläre Bilder und für viele Leute, mit denen wir auch hier vor Ort gesprochen haben, ein Gänsehautmoment, selbst wenn sie nicht religiös waren, wie sie uns erzählt haben.
Ja, sehr schön.
Einfach noch mal ein Gänsehautmoment für alle, einfach nur weil sie anwesend sind. Zuerst dieses Bitte keine Selfies vom Toten Papst. Und dann noch mal die komplette Präsentation sechs Kilometer durch die Stadt. Also wirklich ein guter Papst.
Also das möchtest du auch, dass man dich hier in Frankfurt nochmal quer durch die Stadt zieht.
Nee, ich finde es einfach in dem Falle wirklich nur auf den Papst bezogen. Ich will nicht, dass hier lauter tode Leute durch die Stadt getragen werden.
Naja, dann ist der Tod auch wieder ein bisschen mehr präsent im Leben. In Wien, eine Stadt, die das mobile liebt, ist es ja so, dass dort die Burgschauspieler, wenn sie sterben, auch noch einmal um das Burgtheater im Sarg geschleppt werden.
Sowas fände ich vielleicht albern. Aber ich meine, spezifisch auf den Papst bezogen. Es gibt jetzt im Zuge des Papstes interessante Berichterstattung, zum Beispiel zu John Paul, John Paul, also mein Papst, als ich groß geworden bin, Johannes Paul II., genau, der Termine mit Reagan und so weiter hatte. Danach waren die Berater des Präsidenten beeindruckt davon, wie viel geopolitisches Wissen der Pole mitbrachte nach Amerika. Und sie fragten sich, wer ist ja eigentlich der religiöse Führer? Und zwar natürlich Reagan in dem Moment, so ja. Also wir haben schon so Verdrehungen von Tatsachen irgendwie. Und hier finde ich es halt super interessant, dass der Papst, der ja immer darauf Wert gelegt hat, also spezifisch hier Franziskus, noch mal ein weltliches Argument zu machen, vor Ort zu sein, eine echte Tat zu erledigen und so, dass der einfach noch mal sagt, ich hole jetzt noch mal alle ab. Auch die, die in der Straßenbahn sitzen, die einfach nur da so die Straße lang laufen und so weiter und so fort. Also, dass er mal so einen richtigen weltlichen Einschlag von einer religiösen Stätte zunäßt. Dass er sich da so auf den Berg hoch schleppen.
Auch seine letzte Predigt war ja durchaus vom Weltlichen geprägt. Er hat ja noch mal ganz klar zum Frieden aufgerufen und nicht nur so allgemein, sondern er hat auch ganz klar gemacht, dass diese Aufrüstungen, die wir uns jetzt hineinbegeben, nicht dazu führen wird, dass mehr Frieden auf der Welt entsteht und dass er sich auch da so sehr angelegt hat mit den Herrschenden. Das war eigentlich der so ungewöhnliche. Man kann nur hoffen, dass das wieder jemand wird, der das in ähnlicher Weise tut.
Mal sehen, wir hatten jetzt so einen Supersakralen, jetzt hatten wir so einen Weltlichen. Ich fand beides super attraktiv. Inhaltlich auf jeden Fall super interessant, alles. Das war halt ein letzter guter Move von diesem Papst. Mal gucken, was dem nächsten reinfällt.
Wir wollen uns jetzt mit dem neuen Kulturstaatsminister beschäftigen. Es ist Wolfram Weimer geworden, der Chefredakteur schon von der Welt war, der mit seiner Frau zusammen einen Verlagskonglomerat leitet. Er ist jetzt, glaube ich, aus dem Vorstand erst mal zurückgetreten, um dann sich diesem Amt widmen zu können, der mit Zizero verbunden ist, mit vielen konservativen Publikationen, häufig auch in Talkshows zu Gast ist. Und da gab es nun jetzt sehr viel Kritik an dieser Entscheidung. Und interessant ist auch, dass sich eben sehr viele Konservative über diese Entscheidung aufregen, weil sie dann doch vieles auszusetzen haben. Interessant ist dann aber auch, wie andere Journalisten wieder darauf reagieren. Und das ist so symptomatisch. Veit Medig vom Stern, der frühe Spiegel jetzt Stern, schreibt dann bei Twitter, alle schimpfen über Wolfram Weimer. Wir haben ihn einfach mal gefragt, wie er die Vorwürfe sieht, er sei ein rechtskonservativer Ideologe. Wie stell ich mir das jetzt vor? Dann sagt man, guten Tag Herr Weimer. Ihnen wird vorgeworfen, ein rechtskonservativer Ideologe zu sein. Stimmt das? Und sagt er, nee, bin ich nicht.
Ich finde das genial, also das finde ich wirklich genial. Weil immer, wenn Journalisten dem geschriebenen Wort misstrauen und denken, sie könnten es durch ein Gespräch nochmal gerade rücken, finde ich es irgendwie genial. Und zu einem Autor zu gehen, der eine 20-, 30-jährige Publikationsgeschichte hat und zu fragen, also ihn einfach direkt zu fragen, das ist ja die Reformulierung. Herr Weimer, wir haben Ihre Texte gelesen, aber das kann ja gar nicht wahr sein, was Sie da schreiben. Können Sie es noch mal sagen?
Das passiert aber dann genau nicht. Also das Interview ist dann...
Aber im Subtext kommt man ja gar nicht raus.
Das Interview ist aber dann genau nicht so, dass er tatsächlich mit dem Geschriebenen konfrontiert wird, sondern nur mit den Vorwürfen, die es gibt, über das Geschriebene, aber ohne, dass man sich selbst damit auseinandergesetzt hat, was er geschrieben hat. Und ich weiß, das ist für viele Journalisten nichts, woran sie sich auch halten würden, oder für viele ist es auch verpönt, so was zu tun. Und es tut mir auch leid, dass ich es gemacht habe, aber ich habe tatsächlich mich hingesetzt und habe das Buch einfach gelesen von Wolfram Weimer. Ich habe einfach gedacht, dann lese ich doch mal dieses konservative Manifest, dann kann ich ja doch was dazu sagen. Und wir hören aber erst, bevor wir jetzt die Postzüge daraus hören.
Ich hätte eine Frage zu Kaube, bevor wir das alles. Gut.
Jürgen Kaube in der FAZ.
Ich lese mal diesen Anfangs. Also der Zeitschriftenverleger und ehemalige Wirtschaftsjournalist Wolfram Weimer. Und ich lese, wie ihr seht, von einer echten Zeitung. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ist von Friedrich Merz für das Amt des Kulturstaatsministers ausersehen. Das überrascht. Okay, das ist schon mal kritisch, aber jetzt. Denn Weimer ein Interesse an irgendeiner Kunst oder Geist zu unterstellen, wäre spekulativ. Eigentlich ist hier erwartbar Kunst oder Kultur. Jetzt hat er aber den Geist mit reingebracht. Also hier wird zum ganz großen Schlag ausgeholt. Ich fand das nicht schlecht, dass die größte konservative Zeitung sich mit dem konservativen März und dessen konservativen Entscheidungen den konservativen Weimer reinzuholen. Ich dachte, wir führen diese Kulturkämpfe gegen die, aber jetzt sind die Konservativen unter sich im Krieg.
Ja, beziehungsweise es sind natürlich auch immer Eitelkeiten. Wer bekommt was und aus welchen Gründen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Kaube jetzt Kulturstaatsminister werden wollte oder so.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber ich glaube, dass das ja auch eine sehr heterogene Gemengelage ist, die man unter Konservativen vorfinden kann. Es ist ja nicht so, dass da jetzt alle in die Richtung von Merz gehen. Und ich fand auch erstaunlich, was in der Süddeutschland veröffentlicht wurde von Hans-Jürgen Jacobs. Der hatte einen längeren Artikel zu Friedrich Merz und beleuchtet so ein bisschen, woher er da eigentlich kommt. Friedrich Merz hat sich ja für Wolfram Weimer nicht ohne Grund entschieden, sondern die sind seit Jahren gut verbandelt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel so ein Ludwig-Ehrhard-Gipfel, der wird organisiert von dem Ehepaar Weimer. Und da ist natürlich auch Friedrich Merz zu Gast. Man kann da auch gleich ein Interview finden bei YouTube. Da geht es dann, liebe Herr Merz, ja, liebe Herr Weimer. Man kann sich vorstellen, wie dann so ein Gespräch verläuft.
Es könnte sein, dass man hier wirklich nicht richtig vorwärtskommt im Text, weil man die ganze Zeit so irre Fragen hat. Ludwig-Ehrhard-Preis oder dieser ganze Kram. Der Gipfel. Das ist ja wirklich so, als würde man den Linken unterstellen, sie würden so eine Erich-Hunniker-Tagung machen irgendwie und so. Weißt du, die unterstellen den Linken immer zu einfaches Denken, zu viel Ethologie und überhaupt. Dann machen die so Ludwig-Ehrhard-Preis.
Ludwig-Ehrhard ist nun die Stütze unserer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft, würde ich jetzt sagen.
Haben wir nicht Wirtschaftswunder und so alles entzaubert? Ist das nicht schon zehn Jahre durch?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Da werden wir jetzt gleich noch einiges zu hören. Wiederholt steht hier in dem Text in der Süddeutschen. Kürte Weimer seinen Golfpartner Friedrich Merz bei NTV zur Person der Woche.
Ja, ist doch alles absurd.
Man hat auf der Welttribüne als Vielkommentierer zwangsläufig nicht immer recht. Aber all das hat Friedrich Merz bei seiner Ministerkühe nicht aufgehalten. Die beiden ordo-liberalen 198-Meter-Männer verbindet, Stipendiaten der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung gewesen zu sein und am selben Tag, es ist der 11. November, ihre Geburt zu feiern. Auch in Fragen der Freizeitgestaltung geht das Duo d'accord. So wurden sie auf dem Golfplatz von Bad Wiessee beim Einputten beobachtet. Nicht weiter verwunderlich also, dass die persönliche Weimer-Publikistik in Sachen Merz eine auffallende Elogenhaftigkeit durchzieht. Weiter heißt es dann noch, dass dieser Gipfel bald wieder stattfindet. Er kostet 3.213 Euro, aber ohne die Gipfelnacht, weiß nicht, was das nochmal ist. Verlegerin Götz Weimer, also das ist dann die Ehefrau, macht erst gar keinen Hehl daraus, dass sie ihren gutbürgerlichen Ludwig-Ehrhard-Gipfel als Zitat-Keimzelle der neuen Bundesregierung betrachtet. Hier, abseits des kalten politischen Berlins, seien sich die neukoalitionäre Klingweil und Merz erstmals, Zitat, auf andere Weise begegnet, erklärt sie im Münchner Merkur. Letzter Satz von Jakobs ist Menschelte offenbar.
Ja, das ist ganz toll.
Wir sind gerührt, hören jetzt aber erst von 2018 einen Auftritt von Wolfram Weimer bei Markus Lanz, der auch ganz begeistert ist.
Und das meinte ich mit dem, es gibt eben eine neue Generation von Politikern, die auch eine andere Form von Wahrhaftigkeit in ihrer öffentlichen Kommunikation mit sich tragen. Das ist übrigens keine Frage von Parteilichkeit. Die gibt es in allen Parteien, die sind auch deswegen besonders geschätzt. Ich glaube ja sowieso, dass diese Wende in Betrachtung von Politik heutzutage gar nicht mehr nach Parteien, häufig gar nicht mehr nach Meinungen geht, sondern nach Persönlichkeit. Und die Leute schätzen, wenn jemand authentisch ist, wenn er wahrhaftig ist, wenn er zu seinen Werten steht. Und das ist ja mein Thema, mit dem es kommt diese Wertkonservative Welle.
Das ist ja ein globales Phänomen tatsächlich.
Das ist ja nichts typisch Deutsches oder so. Nein, ich meine, vor 20 Jahren war konservativ, das war so attraktiv wie Mottenkugeln und Maggie Thatcher, irgendwas so dazwischen. Kein Mensch wollte konservativ sein. Heute will man von einem konservativen Mediziner behandelt werden. In der Bank höre ich, diese Anlage ist ganz sicher, die ist konservativ.
Gap es eine Zeit, in der man unsichere Anlagen bevorzugt und sagte, Mensch, das ist aber toll, da gehe ich ja ein hohes Risiko ein und hab vielleicht gar nichts davon. Also wir merken ja schon, hier wird der Begriff konservativ so erweitern, dass er auf alles zutrifft. Gap es eine Zeit, in der man sagte, ich wünsche mir vor allem unehrliche Politiker, das wäre toll.
Zeitgeist ist ein ganz scheues Reh und zum Glück ist der Jäger Wolfgang Weimer, Wolfram Weimer, losgezogen, um es für uns zu fangen, geht noch weiter.
Autokauch sagt mir, der Autoverkäufer, der Benzinverbrauch ist ganz niedrig, das ist ganz konservativ. Also auf einmal ist das Konservative, was vorhin noch unappetitlich war, irgendwie angesagt. Und der wahre Wertkonservative, der sagt, konservativ sein ist nicht ein Hängen an dem, was gestern war, sondern ein Leben aus dem, was immer gilt. Also Treue zum Beispiel. Jeden Morgen, wenn ich aufwache, sehe ich meine Frau und ich bin jetzt 30 Jahre mit ihr zusammen und jeden Morgen bin ich in sie verliebt. Da bin ich sowas von altmodischem Konservativ.
Das ist wirklich ja Konservativismus.
Frau Bauer fangt die Augenbraue, weil sie genau weiß. Die Frau verlangt, dass mal wieder ein Zeichen kommt und wo, wenn nicht Balance.
Aber das ist auch eine unpolitische Kategorie. Ich glaube deswegen, dass diese Form von Konservativen, deswegen wird es im Moment so debattiert. Die Zeit hat ja die Titelgeschichte diese Woche dazu gemacht. Da wundern sich die Menschen, warum verändert sich Gesellschaft eigentlich in diese Richtung? Wir schauen häufig Politik an, das sind wie Boote auf einem See. Die sind mal die Roten, die Schwarzen, die gehen hoch und runter. Aber da drunter gibt es gerade eine große Strömung hin zu alten Werten. Die Leute wollen wieder Anständigkeit, Ehrlichkeit, Aufrichtigkeit, so ganz altmodische Dinge, die eine Zeit lang ziemlich verwufen werden.
Ehrlichkeit und Aufrichtigkeit waren ja lange Zeit verpölen. Und jetzt aber kommt es wieder.
Also ich finde das wirklich genial.
Lange Zeit wurden wir gerne belogen, aber jetzt wollen wir mal wieder Ehrlichkeit.
Aus welchem Jahr ist das Buch?
2018.
Okay, das ist ja nicht so lange her.
Nein.
Seitdem ist ja Corona und so ein bisschen ein paar zäsurale Wenden sind ja passiert.
Ist aber alles eigentlich noch ehrlicher geworden. Und das ist ja der Beweis, dass er jetzt da der höchste Mann in der Kultur wird. Und ich finde, wir sollten das Phänomen jetzt folgendermaßen haben. Mir geht es ja jetzt gar nicht darum, zu sagen, so denkt Wolfram Weimer. Ja, das ist auch wichtig. Aber die Tatsache ist ja einfach, dass das ja eine Richtungsentscheidung ist, für diese Koalition zu sagen, das wird jetzt unser Mann für die Kultur. Und man hat hier es ja zum Glück einmal mit jemandem zu tun, der schon sein Credo aufgeschrieben hat. Wir müssen ja nicht bei 1000 Interviews jetzt nachforschen, wie könnte er es wohl gemeint haben.
Es sind nicht nur Legenden wie bei Claudia Roth. Die war mal Managerin und hat mal unsere.
Er nimmt sich vor, ein Buch zu schreiben, das Konservative Manifest. Ich habe diese 110 Seiten gelesen, um zu wissen, was denkt er. Und ich glaube, dass Weimer jetzt ja nicht nur ein Solitär ist, sondern der steht natürlich für eine gewisse Entwicklung in der Gesellschaft. Und das jetzt auch die junge Union das besonders begrüßt, dass sehr Konservative aus der Union diese Entscheidung begrüßen. Und dass wir ja ohnehin schon einen gewissen konservativen Backlash aus den USA gut kennen, den wir hier thematisieren. Da ist es also sehr gut, das in diesen größeren Kontext zu stellen. Denn wir haben es hier tatsächlich mit etwas zu tun, was man als so einen recht vulgären Konservatismus bezeichnen könnte, der aber zugleich sich auch so wahnsinnig modern gibt. Also es ist ja gerade jetzt nicht, dass man sagt, wir ziehen einmal wieder die Tracht an und machen mal wie 19. Jahrhundert oder so etwas, sondern man hat zugleich auch so eine gewisse Modernität, die man ausstrahlen möchte.
Also ich finde auch, du stellst uns jetzt vor eine große Probe. Ich sehe, wie lang die Liste ist an Weimar Clips, was ja bedeutet, wir müssen da jetzt was rausholen, was vielleicht nicht drinsteckt. Wir können jetzt nicht einfach sagen, Wolfram Weimer sagt und das nehmen wir dann für voll oder kritisieren oder wie auch immer. Ich habe ja, also wir hier in Hessen haben ja einen Ministerpräsident, der auch genau durch sowas auffällt. Ideenreichtum, was man Leuten erzählen könne, damit sie sich wohlfühlen. Und dann kommen solche Lügen zustande, wie ja hunderte lang dachten die Leute bei der Bank, ich möchte die risikoreiche Anlage, die auf jeden Fall in 30 Jahren sich in Luft aufgelöst hat und so. Aber jetzt endlich kommt die Vernunft runter. Gott hat wieder mit uns gesprochen, wir müssen ihm nur folgen wie auch immer. Und dann wird es so runtergebrochen auf Kurs statt Chaos. Herr Boris Rhein, sagen Sie bitte was zur Ampel. Ich bin für Kurs statt Chaos. Ich denke mir so ein bisschen, wir können das jetzt nicht mehr so, also ernst nehmen sowieso nicht, aber wir können es auch niemanden mehr durchgehen lassen, das überhaupt ernst zu nehmen. Wir sind jetzt in einer Lage, in der die Demokratie bedeutet, 160 Millionen Amerikaner gehen wählen. Die meisten davon könnten sich selber wählen lassen. Die Frage ist nur, wer macht die Ochsentour und so weiter. Das Resultat ist Donald Trump. In Deutschland genau dasselbe. 60 Millionen Menschen können wählen. Jeder davon könnte sich auch selber aufstellen lassen. Man müsste nur ein bisschen Ochsentour und ein bisschen IQ und so weiter. Aber das Ergebnis ist Friedrich Merz. Hinter diese Realität können wir nicht zurück. Das Losverfahren wäre besser, Würfeln wäre besser, ein Rotationsverfahren jeden Tag, ein neuer Bundeskanzler wäre besser. Alles wäre besser als das, was wir haben. Wir müssen es wirklich mal ganz kurz in so einem meditativen Moment feststellen. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig bescheuert. Und es könnte sein, dass jemand, der sagt Kurs statt Chaos, einfach selber nicht weiter weiß und genau weiß, es ist alles Chaos. Er sagt nur noch Kurs. Ja, und so ist das hier auch.
Die Rhetorik ist noch ein bisschen vorhanden, aber der Inhalt, den werden wir jetzt gleich suchen gehen. Beziehungsweise wir fragen uns, welches Gebäude entsteht eigentlich, wenn man diese ganzen Versatzstücke zusammennimmt, die uns Wolfram Weimer da anbietet.
Also es könnte sein, dass wir auf die Logik von oh, das große KI-Zeitalter, ist es wirklich so klug und so, was die Maschinen da machen. Es könnte sein, dass wir jetzt feststellen, dass unsere Bundesregierung wirklich nur noch funktionierende Grammatik aufzuweisen hat und sonst nichts mehr. Und dass selbst diese Grammatik noch mal rückgekoppelt ist, sagt GPT auch, das ist korrekte Grammatik, ja, dann können wir es publizieren, ja. Dann können wir, und so. Und Wolfram Weimer ist für mich eigentlich diese Galionsfigur dieses totalen, nicht nur einfach Untergangs, sondern dieses verlotternden Untergangs. Weißt du? Also, dass einfach gar keine Bemühungen mehr statt sind, irgendwem irgendwas zu erklären, sondern man hat einfach so eine Textbook-Idee wie Zölle oder so. Also Trump macht das super offensiv, macht einfach 100 Prozent Zölle auf China. Was bedeutet 100 Prozent der Schiffe fahren nicht mehr so aus Gelände. Das nächste Weihnachtsgeschenk ist jetzt schon, die Geschichte ist schon geschrieben, sie kann jetzt noch erlebt werden. Und das ist hier in Deutschland auch, nur während bei Trump einfach gesehen wird, das ist Evolution und da steckt ja eine gewisse Ehrlichkeit drin. Das wurde ja immer beobachtet so. Trump lügt zwar immer, aber im Grundsatz ist er halt der große Ehrliche. Es ist Chaos, also macht er Chaos und versucht es gar nicht mehr zu verstecken. Diese Leute hier in Deutschland, die versuchen uns das, gegen das sie sich nicht wehren können, nämlich Chaos und Evolution immer noch als Konvention zu verkaufen, als den Normalfall mit so Zauberbegriffen wie, ja das ist konservativ.
Das ist Bürokratieabbau.
Zum Beispiel sowas. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was in diesem Buch drin steht.
Wir beide haben ja in diesen konservativen Koalitionsvertrag geblickt und sind ja dann auch entsetzt darüber, dass es nur solche wagen Ankündigungen sind und dass man sich einfach denkt, wenn man 80-mal Bürokratieabbau schreibt, dann wird der auch schon von selbst kommen.
Ja, vor allem dieser Koalitionsvertrag besteht ja immer, wenn die CDU beteiligt ist, zu 50 Prozent aus Mondlandung, irgendwas mit Kernfusionen und so weiter, der ganze Kram, wo man sich denkt, gib den Forschern einfach Geld. Das ist die Aufgabe der Forscher, nicht deine, nur weil du die Worte magst und so. Und so ist das hier auch. Ich mag das Wort konservativ. Es ist das letzte, was Oma Erna noch etwas vorgaukelt, bei dem sie ganz kurz denkt, stimmt, so irgendwie.
Diese Leute, so sehr daran hängen, ist ja auch interessant, dass auch so ein Markus Lanz da gleich affiziert wird davon. Das ist ja erstaunlich. Die leben ja nun eigentlich ein relativ unkonservatives Leben. Also deren Lebensstil ist ja einer, der mit so einem konservativen Weltbild sich relativ wenig deckt.
Also ich will nur noch eine kleine Pointe machen, weil Lanz, Lanz hatte Heidi Reich in der Gestern zu Gast, nur der Koch hat Videos gemacht. Ich sehe, wie er mit Heidi Reich in der über den Mietendeckel spricht oder jede andere Versuchung, Mietenpreise zu senken. Und statt das irgendwann mal von 99 Prozent der Leute auszusehen, die einfach die Miete bezahlen statt bekommen, hantiert er die ganze Zeit mit diesem, da haben sich Leute 30 Jahre lang dauernd erspart und dann kaufen sie sich 30 Quadratmeter, vermieten das und dann kommen sie mit dem Mietendeckel. Und dieses ganze Bild, das Lanz da propagiert, scheint ja wohl in einem extrem großen Kontrast zu sein. Denn jedes Mal, wenn man in Italien ist, hört man einfach nur, Südtirol, das hat Markus Lanz aufgekauft. Also die Leute sind gar nicht mehr in der Lage, mit einem Ballon über die Alpen zu fliegen, ohne nur Markus Lanz, alles was das Licht berührt, in den Ländern zu sehen. Ich weiß es nicht genau, Spekulation, würde mich nicht wundern, das Geld dafür wäre da. Aber es scheint hier eine ganz große Diskrepanz zu geben zwischen dieser Semantik, Wolfram Weimer und Co. und so, und dieser strukturellen Grundlage, die dann noch verteidigt wird, mit so einer Semantik, die nur noch als Lüge eingesetzt wird.
Wir können ja mal sagen, wir finden eigentlich das Konservative gut, wo etwas bewahrt wird. Zum Beispiel, dass man in seiner Wohnung bleiben kann, dass man sich die weiter leisten kann. Man findet das Konservative da gut, wo bewahrt wird, dass es einen gewissen Ausgleich gibt, dass also diese Schultern, die ohnehin viel tragen können, auch dann durchaus etwas mehr tragen. Stichwort progressive Steuer. Wir können das ja mal alles so auch als konservativ frameen und uns fragen, ob wir das wiederfinden in dem Manifest von Wolfram Weimer.
Ich finde, konservativ ist zum Beispiel auch der Anspruch, dass eine Sache einen gewissen Sinn hat, den man auf Dauer stellen kann.
Ja.
Und wenn eine Mieterhöhung kommt und man stellt die Rückfrage, warum, also wer hat was davon, welcher volkswirtschaftliche Beitrag liegt drin, dass jetzt diese Veränderung in der Zahlungspflicht erstellt. Wenn das nicht erklärt werden kann, dann ist das per se eben nicht konservativ.
Kommen wir gleich zu.
Also das passt gar nicht zu solchen Sachen.
Denn du denkst natürlich wieder nicht ans Eigentum. Dazu kommen wir jetzt, also Wolfram Weimer, das konservative Manifest. Wir hören erst mal uns das Vorhaben an. Das heutige Wertegerüst wird systematisch sortiert, denn Konservative mögen Ordnung. So entsteht ein Manufaktum des Geistes. Bei dem gilt, es gibt sie noch, die guten alten Dinge.
Das hat er geschrieben?
Ja, die möchte er uns jetzt präsentieren.
Also ab jetzt hören wir sein Wort laut mit deiner Stimme. Das muss man natürlich im Kopf ein bisschen auseinanderbauen.
Also ich denke das nicht, sondern das denkt Wolfram Weimer und wir versuchen das jetzt immer so einzuführen, jetzt kommt Wolfram Weimer, Originalton.
Ich kann ja die Tonspur mit deinen Lesungen ein bisschen verblassen oder ein bisschen... Ja, nur dass man es erkennt, dass es jetzt...
Aber dass es angenehm wird zu hören weiterhin.
Ja, ich spiele mal nachher ein bisschen.
Nicht, dass es klingt wie von der Scheller-Platte.
Ordnung, ja genau.
Weil wir was Altmodisches noch machen wollen.
Die Ordnung, konservative mögen die Ordnung. Vladimir Putin mag auch die Ordnung. Und die Ordnung garantiert ihm gerade nur der Krieg. So ist es auch mit Netanyahu. Netanyahu weiß genau, wenn der Krieg endet, ist für mich Chaos. So, das ist einfach ein Konflikt. Nichts ist ordnender als ein Konflikt, der beide Seiten so langsam auszehrt. Wir sind hier schon, die Begriffe halten jetzt schon nicht stand. Und wir haben gerade mal wahrscheinlich den Buchrücken gelesen.
Wir hören jetzt, dass die linke Hegemonie vorbei ist. Das Comeback des Konservativismus hängt eng mit dem Niedergang linker Weltanschauungen zusammen. Diese erinnern viele Menschen im besseren Fall an depressive Gewerkschaftsseminare, an Zeigefingernde Weltverbesserung und an ältere Männer mit Vaterproblemen. Im schlechteren Fall wittert man, die Partei hat immer recht Betondenker, sozialistischen Stacheldraht und Unterdrücker von Venezuela bis Nordkorea. Während das Rotsein einstmals helfend warm mitfühlend war, wirkt es zusehends nur mehr soziologisch, kratzig oder kasernenhaft.
Ja, es ist für mich ein Mann der Kultur, denn er verlässt sich darauf, dass die reine Auswahl von Worten und ihre Kaskade im Satzbau von Bedeutung ist. Egal, was sonst, was er da draus drücken will.
Auch kein Argument. Ich habe zehn Worte, das reicht.
Das ist doch nicht schlecht.
Er versteht viel, das ist auch nicht so ganz richtig. Ich will jetzt nicht alle Beispiele bringen. So glaubt er, dass man Novalis gegen den Islam in Anschlag bringen kann. So hat er auch eine eigenartige Auffassung vom Böckenförde-Theorien. Wir hören jetzt mal, was er dazu sagt. Schon der Staatsrechtler Ernst Wolfgang Böckenförde hat darauf hingewiesen, dass eine demokratische Verfassung nicht aus sich heraus garantiert werden könne. Sie brauche Wertegrundlagen. Kurzum, die moderne Demokratie lebt von Voraussetzungen, die sie selber weder geschaffen hat, noch gewährleisten kann. Aber Böckenförde, Punkt ist ja gerade jetzt nicht zu sagen, und jetzt brauchen wir mal einen Wertekanon, sondern er zeigt uns das Dilemma des modernen Staates, oder man kann auch sagen der Moderne dann an sich, und er sagt nicht, wir müssten mal auf 100 Seiten aufschreiben, was jetzt unsere Werte sind, und dann ist das hier plötzlich doch die Grundlage, die der Staat aber gar nicht gewährleisten kann. Also das ist einfach Böckenförde nicht verstanden.
Böckenförde hat einfach nur gesagt, wir brauchen keine Bürokratie und die ganzen Regeln, wir haben doch Werte.
Oder Max Weber. Und noch etwas. Max Weber hat einst im Protestantismus die Urkraft für den modernen Kapitalismus erkannt. Vielleicht liegt heute eine Ursache für das Zeitlopen Hafte des erodierenden Europas gerade in seinem Nihilismus. War ich zu blöd, das zu lesen, oder ist irgendwas schief bei Wolfram Weimer? Max Weber sagt doch nicht, toll, dass wir den Protestantismus haben. Der hat so wunderbar den Kapitalismus hervorgebracht. Das ist eine Urkraft, die man braucht. Und in gewisser Weise knüpft sich daran dann an, was Weimer sagt. Und schade, dass wir das heute nicht mehr haben. Heute haben wir so viel Nihilismus. Deswegen schwächelt auch der Kapitalismus. Also das ist doch einfach falsch verstanden, diese Analyse, die Weber da vornimmt.
Ich für meinen Teil leide mit Wolfram Weimer darunter, dass wir heute keinen Max Weber mehr haben, der als politischer Berater dem Kanzler sagt, zünde doch mal eine religiöse Idee als Grundlage, als Motor, die die Wirtschaft zieht.
Jetzt hast du natürlich schon hier Enteignungsfantasien laut werden lassen mit Mietendeckel etc. Hier wirst du jetzt sofort von Weimer eingenordet. Kommunismus, Sozialismus, Nationalismus, Nationalsozialismus oder Islamismus. Sie alle gehen von einer Gruppe, einer Klasse, Rasse, einer Uma, einem Kollektiv aus, das letztlich wichtiger sei als der Einzelne. Sie denken nicht in Kategorien von Würde des Einzelnen, sondern von Gerechtigkeit oder Erfolg oder Bestimmung einer Gesellschaft.
Ja, also das ist sowas finde ich genial, denn wir haben jetzt aus verschiedenen Richtungen und ich meine ganz konkret, ich habe die Clips vorliegen so. Vielleicht kommen wir heute zu Jordan Peterson, aber wir können das mal richtig zusammenbauen. Hoss und Hopf, Jordan Peterson, Wolfram Weimer haben ein ganz interessantes Paradox, nämlich zum einen Grenzen zu. Ganz wichtig, wir müssen hier unter uns, wenn wir hier ausfransen, dann führt das zu gar nichts, und wenn wir nicht wissen, wer da ist und überhaupt und so weiter, Grenze zu. Auf der anderen Seite haben die aber immer einen großen Themenblock, du kannst alles schaffen, du brauchst nur dich selbst, deine Kraft steckt in dir, du musst nur richtig denken und so weiter und so fort. Was ja, finde ich, eins plus eins ist, ja, das sind die Flüchtlinge, die ihr beschreibt, die können alles schaffen, egal wo sie sind, die brauchen keinen Kontext, die wissen, was Arbeit ist, die sind fleißig, ja, weißt du, und das passt nie zusammen und hier natürlich auch nicht.
Nee, der Nationalismus ist dem natürlich im Wege, und da ist das dann auch völlig in Ordnung. Also man kann es vom Tellerwäscher zum Millionär schaffen, innerhalb der nationalstaatlichen Ordnung. Aber man darf niemals diesen Aufstieg vollziehen über eine Grenze hinweg, es sei denn, man hat einen Vater, der diese Grenze schon überwunden hat, wie zum Beispiel im Falle von Elon Musk. Dann geht das natürlich, dann kann man erst in Südafrika sein und dann später auch in den USA. Es geht darum, dass die Gesellschaft nur minimal vorhanden ist. Du hast ja in deinem Buch Kinderwüste geschrieben, die Familie wird gar nicht als Institution ernst genommen, weil sie einfach so ein Ausfall ist für alles. Wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert, Schule klappt nicht, da braucht man Lockdown, da muss dies sein. Und die Familie wird es verrein.
Als in Vater und Mutters Hände.
Ja, und das finden wir hier wieder. Die neue Bürgerlichkeit kommt also aufgeklärt, nüchtern und bescheiden daher, in ihren Blick auf politische Entwürfe. Sie hält sich an die Würde und verachtet Würfe. Der französische Philosoph Jean-Claude Michère nennt die neubürgerliche Gesellschaft das Reich des kleineren Übels. Der Konservativismus von heute steht wie der klassische Liberalismus für die Idee einer minimalen Gesellschaft bei einer maximalen Achtung der Würde des Einzelnen. Auch das ist übrigens wieder interessant. Er hat dann nur den Titel genommen von dem Buch Das Reich des kleineren Übels. Das ist eine Kritik dieses Buch, eine Kritik an genau diesem bürgerlichen Ideal, das Wolfram Weimer hier glorifiziert. Es ist verrückt, dass er da sagt, ach ja, da haben wir noch so einen französischen Philosophen, nehmen wir dazu. Es ist genau das Gegenteil gemeint. Also ein ganz interessantes Buch.
Wir sind ja hier wirklich am Startpunkt einer großen, sag ich jetzt mal, konservativen Aufklärung. Denn dieser Konservativismus funktioniert natürlich, wie so viele politische Ideologien, immer sehr gut als Opposition, bis man dann plötzlich im Präsidentenamt ankommt und eine Praxis draus machen muss und die lautet dann, Hilfe, Hilfe, überschwemmt mich nicht mit euren billigen Produkten, Schlaraffenland ist die Hölle. Und alle anderen stellen dann so fest, nee, das war schon ganz cool, als wir im Schlaraffenland lebten. Das war richtig gut. Und jetzt, ich verstehe diese Magerwelt nicht und so, dass wir diese Aufklärung jetzt hier immer bekommen, minimale Gesellschaft in Deutschland. Ja, dann macht auch minimale Gesellschaft nur, wenn ich höre, dass teilweise ein Meter Autobahn 100.000 Euro kosten, auf dem die dann gerne in ihr, das Auto ist mein Freiheitsversprechen und so rüberfahren, dann braucht man maximale Gesellschaft dafür.
Die Autobahn ist maximale Gesellschaft, das ist so.
Das ist nicht minimale Gesellschaft, so im Sinne von Gott hat mir die Autobahn gegeben, na gut, Hitler war's, aber das verschweigen wir mal so. Nein, das ist einfach maximale Gesellschaft, die hier eigentlich gefordert wird von den Leuten, die uns sich selber das Gegenteil versprechen wollen.
Wir haben ja jetzt gerade die Earnings bekommen von Elon Musk. Tesla funktioniert überhaupt nur, ist überhaupt nur noch profitabel deshalb, weil Elon Musk es geschafft hat, sich noch mehr staatliche Zuschüsse zertifikat zu geben.
Zertifikate zu geben und so weiter. Auto-Verkäufe waren es nie.
Die Auto-Verkäufe sind massiv gesunken und die Profite sind für Elon Musk gestiegen, einfach nur, weil der Staat ihn finanziert. Das können wir natürlich bei so vielen erdeben. Wir reden ja hier auch über jemanden, der in der Verlagsbranche ist. Also wie sehr man da gerne zugreift, wenn was angeboten wird oder man lobbyiert, dass man zum Beispiel den Mindestlohn umgehen kann, wenn Zeitungen ausgetragen werden, solche Dinge.
Genau, Mindestlohn wird eingeführt über alle Branchen, außer eine Nachtzeitung austragen. Ja. Das ist Wolfram Weimer.
Aber die Gesellschaft meint, er wird immer übergriffiger. Wenn nun die Gesellschaft ihr instinktives Selbstbewusstsein nach und nach verliert, dazu die Geborgenheit in Tradition und Geschichte, sie sich also nicht mehr sicher ist, was wichtig und unwichtig ist, dann neigt sie zu Sicherheitsreflexen. Sie definiert kindische Regeln, weil sie nicht mehr sicher ist, ob auch alle erwachsen genug sind, mit der Freiheit umgehen zu können. Die Folge sind ein schleichender Freiheitsverlust und Bemutterungsgesten von Staatlichkeit. Allein die Verkehrsüberwachung ist ein Repressionssymptom. 20 Millionen Straßenschilder prägen Deutschland. Alle 28 Meter steht eines, mit jedem Atemzug wird jemand geblitzt. Mit jedem Wimpernschlag gibt es einen Strafzettel wegen Falschparkens. Da muss man ja einfach sagen, ja wir sind 80 Millionen Leute, wir haben, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Millionen Autofahrer, 30 Millionen Autofahrer. Wenn man das jetzt mal hochrechnet, wird das so sein, dass tatsächlich jede Sekunde jemand geblitzt wird und mit jedem Wimpernschlag jemand ein Knöllchen bekommt. Das ist ein Zeichen der modernen Gesellschaft. Aber es geht wirklich auch ganz, ganz massiv gegen die, die sich doch eigentlich kümmern. Neun Millionen Bürger haben inzwischen Punkte in Flensburg. Der Staat drangsaliert mit seinen in Büschen kauernden Polizisten selbst brave Muttis auf Ausfallstraßen. Die Mütter, ihre Kinder, zur Schule bringende Ausfallstraßen, die werden am Ende noch von den im Gebüsch kauernden Polizisten geblitzt. Da muss doch der Konservative sich mal erheben.
Also ich habe es ja selbst erlebt, wie die alten Leute hier, oder ich meine die wirklich alte Leute, die FAZ macht eine Abendveranstaltung, Podiumsdiskussion der Bürgermeisterkandidaten. Frankfurt, teuerste Mietstadt mit Europas und so weiter. Das einzige Thema ist, kann ich mit meinem Auto bis zum Ding vorfahren oder nicht? Wie lange darf ich da parken und so weiter? Ich denke mir so, wie sehr kann man eigentlich die Gesellschaft ausblenden, um einfach die Häuser, die Lieferketten, die Produktionsstätten, den Grund und Boden zugespachtelt und alles ist genau bereit da?
Schulze, die Fahrradwege.
Wie kann man das alles ausblenden und sagen, das größte Thema ist jetzt dieses Straßenschild, das eine einzige Regel hier aufstellt, nämlich, wenn aus drei verschiedenen Richtungen auf diesen Parkplatz zugesteuert wird, hat der, der von rechts kommt, Recht. Das ist die Regel. Und dann sagen die, ne, das schränkt mich in meiner Freiheit ein. Und daraus stricken die ein ganzes Programm, das ja irgendwann auf diese Realität trifft als politisches Programm.
Und das enttäuscht mich auch, das ist tatsächlich so intellektuell. Ich hatte gedacht, ich lese jetzt ein konservatives Manifest. Und ich bin zwar kein Konservativer, habe aber durchaus ja Sympathien für gewisse konservative Punkte. Und hätte mich auch darüber gefreut, ein Programm zu lesen, das mir jetzt beschreibt, welchen Wert der Konservatismus eigentlich hat. Wenn ich aber dann nur sowas höre. Jede einzelne Steuererklärung in Deutschland ist ein Beweis für die These vom Marsch in das Freiheitsdefizit. Dann frage ich mich, was hat das jetzt mit einem konservativen Manifest zu tun? Ist das dann nicht eher ein libertäres Projekt, das hier angestrebt wird? Und da verbindet sich ja so vieles. Wenn wir nach Amerika blicken, dann sehen wir ja, wie wir eine konservative Strömung haben, die zugleich aber auch eine Libertäre ist. Also die sagt, weniger Staat, also natürlich nicht für mein Unternehmen, da möchte ich schon noch weiter eine Staatsknete bekommen, aber weniger Staat an sich. Und zugleich brauchen wir wieder strengere Abtreibungsregeln und und und. Und haben dann aber auch noch so einen Staat, der sagt, wir kümmern uns nicht um dich, aber du kümmerst dich bitte um den Staat, wenn er irgendwo einen Krieg führen will oder so, dann gehen wir rein. Also das ist ja sehr interessant, dass man so eine Melange hat aus absoluter egoistischer Politik, die eigentlich sagt, ist mir alles egal, Gesellschaft gibt es nicht und zugleich aber immer wieder diesen Ruf nach Kollektivierung sich einzuordnen etc. Und da ist dann die Steuer ist dann das Schlimmste, was einem passieren kann. Konservative schützen uns aber dann vor dieser Übergriffigkeit. Was aber schützt vor der Übergriffigkeit einer Gesellschaft? Die glaubt alles regeln zu müssen, weil es keine Selbstverständlichkeit im Regelwerk der Tradition, der Kommens, der herkömmlichen Usancen gibt, der Konservative kennt sie noch und vertraut ihnen, weil sie die gesiebte Vernunft von Generationen zeigen. Er muss nicht alles geregelt haben, aber die großen Regeln der Vorväter prägen ihn. Wir brauchen gar nicht so detaillierte Steuergesetze, sondern wir wissen ja dank unserer Ahnen, deren Geist wir noch in uns tragen, wie eigentlich Gerechtigkeit aussieht. Das bedeutet natürlich, dass wir weniger Regulierungen brauchen, was Steuern anbelangt. Wir müssen auch nicht über eine Erbschaftssteuer oder irgendetwas nachdenken, denn unsere Ahnen haben es uns doch schon gesagt. Den Auftrag tragen wir doch alle mit mit unseren Werten. Warum uns jetzt noch um Regeln scheren, die irgendwelche Steuergesetze zeigen?
Also, er hat ja eben in dem Clip vorher schon so von dieser instinktiven Herangehensweise und das wir eben Shows der Geschichte und so weiter. Das finde ich wirklich sehr gut, denn wenn man das ernst nehme, würden wir ja so ein sakrales Ding aufziehen, in dem ältesten Räte immer wieder über noch ältere Texte befinden und so einen originalistischen Ansatz fahren. Und das ist ja das, was wir in Amerika sehen. Ja. Und mir wäre schon wichtig, dass wir jetzt einfach, vielleicht klappt das schon ab diesen Clips, aber jetzt auch dauerhaft, das, was wir gerade in Amerika sehen, ist das als politische Praxis. Ja. Das ist nicht irgendwie Trump dreht durch oder das ist irgendwie idiotisch oder so, sondern es ist das hier, aber in Praxis.
Ja. Und der Kulturtransfer findet ja immer noch statt. Der Kulturtransfer von Amerika ausgehend sah so aus, dass wir alle gerne Cola trinken, ich ja zum Beispiel, dass wir gerne diese amerikanischen Filme gucken. Und bedeutete dann auch, dass deutsche Filmemacher, zum Beispiel Til Schweiger wäre zu nennen, versuchen, auch amerikanische Filme auf deutschem Boden zu drehen. Und was wir jetzt gerade mit der März-Regierung erleben, ist, dass man versucht, deswegen hat man ja jetzt Amthor auch in gute Positionen gesetzt, oder Jens Spahn, das, was die Amerikaner machen, auch hier in Deutschland umzusetzen. Es ist dann natürlich alles nicht so wirklich sexy und nicht so viel Entertainment dabei, wie das bei einer Trump-Veranstaltung sein kann. Das ist so, wie auch der Til Schweiger Film, nicht so gut ist wie der Bruce Willis Film, aber man bemüht sich. Und dieser Kulturtransfer, der findet ganz eindeutig statt. Und wir haben natürlich den Vorteil, dass wir uns auch nochmal auf unsere ganz Alten rufen können. Vielleicht einfach mal zwischendurch so ein Friedrich Schlegel Zitat für dich. Friedrich Schlegel formulierte das 1809 so. Unsere Ahnen alte Kunde ist es, was mir Hoffnung gibt. Wann belehrt in treuem Bunde man das Alte widerliebt? Ich denke, dass ich das einfach schreiben werde, wenn das Finanzamt mich auffordert zur nächsten Steuererklärung. Einfach dieses Zitat und dann müssten die sich damit zufrieden geben. Die Alten wussten es schon. Jetzt fragt mich nochmal genauer nach. Die öffentliche Moral hat einen neuen Fetisch, die Kleinigkeit. Ob im Alltag oder in der Weltpolitik, die Tugendwächter sind auf dem Vormarsch. Die am schnellsten wachsenden Aktivitäten in unseren Konzernen kommen daher aus den Compliance-Abteilungen. Dort arbeiten die neuen Moralapostel der Moderne. Es ist jetzt zumindest mal eine halbrichtige Beurteilung der Lage, dass diese Compliance-Abteilungen sehr bedeutsam geworden sind und sehr viele Bedenkenträger die ganze Zeit da sind, um nichts falsch zu machen. Das ist aber auch nicht einfach nur eine Entwicklung, die herrührt aus einer linken Hekomonie, sondern die rührt ja daher, dass es gerade die Kapitalgeber sind, die große Angst haben, dass irgendetwas nicht korrekt läuft, dass da irgendjemand etwas falsch macht, was dann am Ende einen Skandal auslöst. Ich hörte vor einer Weile einen Podcast mit einem Mode-Experten und der wurde gefragt, warum gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr so Leute wie Yves Saint Laurent oder Lagerfeld, wo sind die dann alle hin? Und dann sagte der, naja, diese großen Mode-Konglomerate, die ja oft börsennotierte Konzerne im Hintergrund haben, wo die Konzernchefs auch gar nichts mit Mode oder Kunst oder sonst was zu tun haben, die wollen keinerlei Störungen. Die wollen nicht jemanden haben, der im Interview plötzlich irgendetwas da erzählt, wo man denkt, oh Gott, wo wird das noch hingehen? Dann haben die direkt Sorge um ihren Aktienkurs. Dann sagen die, wir wollen lieber so brave Manager, die alles genau nach der Compliance-Abteilung abliefern, sich mit der Compliance-Abteilung ganz eng schalten und ja nicht künstlerisch extravagant und sonst was auftreten, damit es ja nicht irgendwelche Turbulenzen gibt. Das heißt, es ist ja die Kapitalseite, die gerne keine Kontroverse will, die alles, was irgendwie problematisch sein könnte, egal in welche Richtung, sofort sanktionieren möchte. Gar nicht irgendwas politisches, weder in die eine noch in die andere Richtung. Es ist also nicht irgendein linker Zeitgeist einfach, sondern es ist quasi das Kapital selbst, das sagt, nee, nee, lieber mal nicht, lieber jemand, der alles schön abnickt.
Genau. Also diese Erfahrung macht man ja häufiger, sobald man den Justiziar fragt, sagt der, ah nee, lieber nicht, das macht nur Ärger, wie auch immer und so. Bitte keine Störungen im Betriebsablauf. Fragt man in der Forschung und Entwicklung nach, heißt es ganz anders. Bitte mehr Irritation. Ja. Bitte mehr und so weiter. Und dann ist die Frage, ja, wie kriegt man das denn hin? Und dieser große Kulturkampf auch in der amerikanischen Regierung, dass plötzlich irgendwelche YouTuber, die keine Ahnung von nichts haben, dann ihre Grenzen zu, wie heißt dieser, ethno-pluralismus und so weiter, diese ganze Ideologie durchpacken, der widerspricht halt sehr diesen Elon Musk braucht einfach Leute, die mit diesem, wie Hossen Hopf und so sagen, bis und hier und meine Biografie gestalten und so weiter. Und die findet man unter allgemeinem Arbeitnehmermangel halt insbesondere da, wo man Prüfungen durchläuft. Wir haben das ja immer aus moralischen Gesichtspunkten kritisiert, dass durchs Mittelmeer eben nur die allerstärksten Flüchtlinge schaffen. Aber wenn die anlanden, sind sie halt da. Und die stellen halt auch alle anderen in den Schatten. Also jetzt mal so ganz grob drüber gebügelt.
Also womit wir jetzt nicht das Unrecht rechtfertigen. Dass da Leute jetzt einen Kommentar noch schreiben. Aber das ist ja eigentlich die Blickweise, die neoliberale Hayek und Milton Friedman durchaus auf die Migrationsfrage eingenommen haben. Was du jetzt ja gerade schilderst.
Wir kriegen demnächst eine sehr große Auswertung und Aufarbeitung, was es bedeutet, wenn sich ein Land abschottet, dass eigentlich diese Diversität im Denken, die nun mal nur durch Diversität in der Biografie kommt und so, was das bedeutet. Also wenn Silicon Valley jetzt einfach fünf Jahre lang Einstellungsstopp macht, weil in Washington YouTuber Entscheidungen treffen, so ist das halt ein echtes Problem. Ja.
Und all diese Erfolgspodcasts berichten immer nur von Leuten, die sagen, ja kommt aus einer kleinen Provinz in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, hat sich dann mit 17 Jahren Taschengeld verdient, ist dann rüber in die USA, ist dort erfolgreich geworden, hat dann erst ganz spät die Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen. Und das sind genau diese Migrationsgeschichten, die da drin liegen. Und wir haben ja jetzt gerade den Geburtstag gefeiert, 20 Jahre YouTube. Und da ist das erste YouTube-Video von jemanden erstellt worden, der aus Deutschland kommt, Migrationshintergrund hatte, aufgrund des Rassismus in den 90er Jahren mit seinen Eltern, in die USA ging. Ja, so ein hoch talentierter Mensch geht in die USA und ist dort dann einer der Gründer von YouTube geworden.
So, und das muss man aber, um das zu fördern, dass das funktioniert, so Schmelztiegel-artige soziale Zusammenleben, muss man halt moralisch, kleinteilig organisieren.
Ja.
So, wie die Anstrengung war, von YouTube zu sagen oder von Google allgemein, wir werden hier der beste Arbeitgeber. Wir machen extreme Anstrengungen. Bei uns gibt es einen Kindergarten, bei uns gibt es Menüs, wir haben Sterneköche zu Gast, bei uns gibt es Geselligkeit organisiert und so weiter. Das sind alles Regeln. Das fällt uns nur immer nicht auf, wenn das so wohltuend als Komfort und Annehmlichkeit verkauft wird. Aber genauso sind die Unternehmen natürlich auch hinterher, dass diese Vorzüge nicht durch, ah, da gab es da doch wieder Streit, Missverständnisse und so weiter, das muss man halt moralisch, kleinteilig regeln. Die Frage ist dann immer, kann man das, was betriebswirtschaftlich gut funktioniert, auch volkswirtschaftlich organisieren? Also kann die Politik überhaupt, oder muss man das halt immer im etwas kleineren Rahmen, also so Subsidiaritätsprinzip, Probleme nur da lösen, wo sie anfallen, statt so mit so einer Pauschallösung, wir sind jetzt alle weltoffen und so weiter. Also da würde ich auch sagen, ja, da hat man halt über die Stränge geschlagen. Nur das hätte halt eine vernünftige Evaluation auch ergeben, dass es nichts bringt. Vor allem nicht, wenn Google Jahrzehnte als, das ist ein super Arbeitgeber, ihr müsst es nur alle so machen wie Google, und dann kommen irgendwelche Politiker auf die Idee zu sagen, ja, dann mache ich das jetzt auch so, und dann stellen die so einen Tugendkatalog auf. Das sind natürlich Fehler, einfach so, handwerkliche Fehler, aber dass man das einfach alles gar nicht durchschaut und auch diesen Mehrwert und die Erfolge, die damit kamen, sondern einfach mal wieder nur das Straßenschild sieht, statt die ganze Infrastruktur, in der man das Straßenschild festgeschraubt hat. Das ist einfach ein ganz blinder Mann, dieser Wolfram Weimer.
Naja, diese neue Kleinigkeit, wie sieht sie aus? Weimer macht es konkret. Unter dem Siegel der Regeltreue und Korruptionsbekämpfung entfesseln sie Kontrollsucht und Regelbürokratie. Geschenke gibt es fast keine mehr, denn immer lauert irgendwo der Geldwertevorteil oder der mutmaßliche Bestechungsversuch. Geschäftsessen und Dienstreisen unterliegen zusehends dem Ruch halbkrimineller Veranstaltungen. Und selbst auf den Geburtstagsblumenstrauß blickt der Compliance-Officer inzwischen wie ein Terrorismusjäger. Also wir merken ganz klar, wohin das geht. Schade, dass ich jetzt nicht mehr einfach meine Freunde für ein Wochenende einladen kann und das auch noch absetzen kann. Schade, dass ich das jetzt selbst bezahlen muss. Also es wird jetzt die ganze Zeit, wird hier aus einer Perspektive beklagt. Also das ist ja ein Manifest, das wird dann gelesen von meistens ja einfachen Leuten, die auch überhaupt nie ein Geschäftsessen oder irgendwas veranstalten und schon gar nicht irgendwo hinreisen.
Also es ist schon sehr voraussetzungsvoll, mal ein Geschäftsessen anzugeben bei der Steuer.
Sie sind jetzt da und lesen ein konservatives Manifest und sollen sagen, ah ja stimmt, aber eigentlich ist das jetzt so ein Klagen der obersten 5% oder des obersten Prozents darüber, dass man irgendwelche Dinge nicht mehr absetzen kann. Und das wird dann so radikalisiert, dass selbst der Blumenstrauß nicht mehr möglich ist. Oder auch folgendes. Der neue Puritanismus verändert den Alltag. Eine Stewardess wird sich nicht mehr trauen, einen Gast auf einen besseren Platz zu setzen. Ein Hotelrezeptionist hütet sich, besonderen Gästen ein besseres Zimmer zu geben, als just genau das Gebuchte und Bezahlte. Ein Bankangestellter wird auch dem beinamputierten Helden eines Katastropheneinsatzes kein tausendstel Zinsvorteil mehr gönnen dürfen. Und daran war immer diese linke, kleinliche Hegemonie schuld, dass die Zinssätze so hoch sind.
Das ist ephalogen.
Was ist denn das für ein Quatsch?
Also das ist eh von vorne bis hinten verlogen.
Die Bank macht Risikoabwägungen. Und da würde ich sagen, die Bank wird denjenigen, der ein Bein amputiert hat, schlechter stellen als denjenigen, der beide Beine hat. Und das ist aber ein Problem, weil alles nach Profitabilität berechnet wird. Und das hat überhaupt nichts mit einem Wertekern zu tun, nämlich dieses Gegenteil davon. Und das andere, was er da anführt, ist ja überhaupt nirgends zu sehen. Also hast du erlebt, dass du keinen Upgrade mehr bekommst, aus irgendwelchen Compliance-Grunden? Ich würde sagen, nee. Ich würde sagen, gerade diese ganze Upgrade-Geschichte hat ja zugenommen in einem erheblichen Maße.
Also hier kriegen wir jetzt sowieso, das ist ja schon im laufenden Gange, dass wir sehen, Elon Musk, es wird quasi von der New York Times zitiert, mit Wortlaut Elon Musk, ich wollte eine Billion sparen und es sind nur 150 Milliarden. Also er revidiert sein eigenes Bürokratieabbauziel um 85 Prozent und die einzige Bürokratie, die er abgebaut hat, war Kostenposten streichen. Ganze Häuser einfach schließen, USAID oder das Bildungsministerium. Und jetzt stellen wir fest, naja, damit sinkt aber auch die Leistungsfähigkeit der amerikanischen Regierung. Also das war eigentlich ein gutes Geschäft und er hat einfach nur den Kostenposten, aber den Nutzenanteil nicht mit kalkuliert. Gleichzeitig schreibt Donald Trump eine Executive Order nach der anderen. Und jede Einzelne bedeutet Bürokratie.
Natürlich.
Jede Einzelne bringt mehr Bürokratie. Und so ist das ja hier auch. Dieser ganze Scheiß, dass es das gab, also hier was absetzen, da 70 Prozent vom Essen, da jeden Kilometer vom Autofahren und so weiter.
Gibt's ja immer noch.
Ja, aber das sind konservative Errungenschaften.
Ja, genau.
Die wollten das so kleinteilig. Die haben sich gesagt, nee, wenn wir einfach nur jedem die Straße zur Verfügung stellen, wir müssen erstens denjenigen, der und so weiter unsere Klientel ist, das Auto noch kostenlos machen oder billiger und ihm dann noch pro Strecke, die er fährt, Geld überweisen. Das ist doch deren Bürokratie. Warum wendet er sich dagegen so?
Er hätte es wahrscheinlich gerne noch einfacher, dass sobald man ein Auto hat und ab S-Klasse bekommt man noch 10.000 Euro so geschenkt. Ich weiß es nicht.
Zugespitzt heißt es, das ist wirklich Trump-Extremität zu sagen, das mir nicht geschenkte Auto schränkt mich in meiner Freiheit ein. Ich hasse diesen Stahl.
Ja. Und zugleich sind das ja die Leute, die genau nachgucken, ob irgendein Hartz-IV-Empfänger noch drei Mark mehr bekommen hat.
Grenze, Armut, Bürokratie. Die werden so krasse Bürokratie aufbauen jetzt.
Bezahlkarte ist ein Bürokratie-Monstrum. Aber es geht natürlich um diejenigen, die sehr viel haben und dann plötzlich belangt werden von dir oder Heidi Reichenegg, die dann sagen, jetzt müssen wir mal mit Vermögen steuern, wir müssen mal gucken, wie reich sind denn die Reichen. Nee, da habt ihr nichts verloren. Ob Erebschaften, Managergehälter oder Geldanlagen. Die Politik fordert neue Transparenzregeln. Denn die Transparenz ist immer der Schritt in die Sozialisierung. Es wird öffentlich gemacht, was eigentlich privat sein sollte. Eine strukturelle Neugier treibt die Bürokratie. Eine Gier also. Der Steuerstaat raubt uns über das Finanzamt nicht nur unser Geld, sondern auch Detailinformationen unserer Lebensumstände.
Transparenz ist Gier. Herzlich willkommen im Jahr 1984.
Das ist verrückt, oder?
Genial.
Also da sind wir jetzt wirklich nicht mehr entfernt von Hoss und Hopf.
Also Constanze hat mir eine Geschichte erzählt aus, ich glaube Deutschland, ich weiß nicht genau. Jemand vertreibt Enten, also ein chinesisches Restaurant vertreibt Enten. Und dann kommen die in den Laden rein und sagen, den Leuten geht es irgendwie nicht so gut, wenn die ihre Enten hier immer essen, können wir uns das mal anschauen. Und dann finden die aufgehangene, gerupfte Tauben in diesem Restaurant. Die haben also Tauben serviert. So, ich bin da für Transparenz.
Ja, da kann man ruhig mal in die Küche rein geben.
Wenn jetzt da einfach jemand sagt, aber ich habe hier ein Profitinteresse, ich bin hier gegen Transparenz, finde ich nicht gut. Und die Taube ist hier wirklich Schiffre für ganz viel.
Naja, das ist natürlich eine Aussage, die sagt, lasst uns bitte nicht nachgucken, ob irgendjemand sein Geld in eine Steueroase verlegt hat.
Alles privat.
Alles privat, denn das Individuum, das ist uns heilig. Der Konservative denkt so, das Individuum ist früher da als die Gesellschaft. Das Individuum ist zeitgleich der finale Bezugspunkt, um den es bei Gesellschaft immer gehen sollte. Am Individuum entscheidet sich die Qualität einer Gesellschaft. Ich finde das nicht falsch.
Ich finde es sehr falsch.
Lass mich mal sagen, also das Individuum an sich kommt ja tatsächlich zuerst. Ja, also wir sind zwar geboren, aber wir sind als Menschen, sind wir auch in unserer Autonomie diejenigen, die in der Autonomie geschützt werden müssen. Es ist also nicht nur Gesellschaft, sondern wir sind auch als Individuen da. Und das finde ich erst einmal richtig, das zu bemerken, weil das mitunter tatsächlich verloren geht. Dass man, dass man, man kann nicht alles nur als kollektiv betrachten, sondern es gibt auch Individuen. Das hat mich auch damals sehr geärgert, wenn z.B. Leute sagten, ich möchte nicht AstraZeneca, sondern den besseren Impfstoff haben. Dass dann gesagt wird, ja, aber statistisch ist das hilfreich, wenn auch erst mal die Leute AstraZeneca nehmen. Dann denke ich mir, ja, das mag statistisch so sein. Aber ich als Individuum hätte trotzdem gerne den besseren Impfstoff. Und genau diese Denkweise, finde ich, ist eine, die wir häufig jetzt antreffen. Deswegen finde ich diese Aussprache für das Individuum an sich richtig, die ihr da vollzieht. Was dann aber verrückt ist, ist, dass er zugleich sagt, der Konservative ist Patriot. Er fühlt sich seinem Vaterland verbunden, ohne es zu glorifizieren und ohne andere Nationen herabzusetzen. Das unterscheidet den Patrioten vom Nationalisten. Na, wenn ja das Individuum erst mal das eine und alles ist, warum brauche ich dann jetzt den Patriotismus? Und dann gibt es natürlich noch diese und ja?
Ganz groß, also wirklich einen gigantischen Widerspruch üben.
Also du findest das Individuum ist überfetzt?
Vielleicht den größten Widerspruch ever, den ich in einem Podcast gemacht habe. Denn das ist ja genau diese Denke. Das Individuum. Beim Familienbuch begegnet mir das ja immer wieder. Die Zeugung eines Kindes ist ein biologischer Akt. Der fand auch schon so statt, bevor es Gesellschaft gab.
Richtig.
Nur bei der Unterscheidung zwischen Natur und Kultur können wir einfach nicht sagen, die Biologie ist es und der Rest ist nachrangig. So im Sinne von, wenn keine Menschen geboren sind, gibt es ja gar keine, mit denen man Gesellschaft machen kann. Oder wie auch immer. Oder wir sehen ja jetzt, wenn keine Menschen mehr kommen, dann fallen Unternehmen in sich zusammen, dann ist die Nachfolge nicht klar. Und dann ist das Unternehmen Geschichte. Aber diese ganze Idee vom Individuum ist eine gesellschaftliche, soziale, kommunikative Praxis. Die Idee des Individuums folgt als Effekt auf die schon vorhandene Gesellschaft. Es muss hergestellt werden. Es ergibt sich nicht einfach so. Das kann auch Wolfram Weimer selbst mal feststellen. Er fährt einfach in die Wüste und sagt, ich, das Individuum, schaffe es ohne Gesellschaft. Und da ist ja völlig klar, hier ist nichts mit Individuum und Kultur.
Nein, das finde ich ja, ist ja wichtig zu betonen. Deswegen kritisieren wir ja auch da immer die libertäre Position, die sagt, ich kann das alles ganz allein. Nur würden wir ja doch beide zustimmen, dass das Individuum an sich einen Wert hat und auch schützenswert ist und auch in seiner Autonomie nicht uneingeschränkt eingeschränkt werden darf.
Um das Individuum zu schützen, um es ernst zu nehmen, um es wahrzunehmen, braucht es Gesellschaft. Es sind kommunikative Akte erforderlich, damit das Individuum überhaupt als Individuum wahrgenommen werden kann und dann noch alle möglichen Labels, Freiheit hier, offene Zukunft da und so weiter und so fort. Die Gesellschaft steht dir nicht im Wege, sondern genau oben getreten. Das ist wie beim Markt. Es gibt keinen biologischen reinen Markt ohne Gesellschaft.
Vielleicht wird es besser verständlich, wenn ich sage, für mich geht es ja mehr um eine philosophische Anthropologie. Also zu sagen, dass der Mensch ein Bewusstsein hat und sich seiner Selbstbewusstsein werden kann. Seiner Selbstbewusst werden kann. Das ist ja etwas, was den deutschen Idealismus prägt, was man dann eben der philosophischen Anthropologie in der ersten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts wiederfinden kann. Dann ist das ja etwas, dass man dieses Selbstbewusstsein als solches erst einmal haben kann und als solches dann auch sich selbst verwirklichen kann, womit ich jetzt nicht meine verwirklichen heißt, ich gehe da zur Schule, gehe da auf die Uni und so weiter. Das gibt es auch, aber da verlassen wir quasi die philosophische Bühne und gehen dann zu dem, wie man Gesellschaft organisiert. Und da geht das nur mit Gesellschaft, da kann das Individuum nur diese Verwirklichung machen. Aber wenn wir rein deskriptiv bleiben, also von dem, was der Mensch als Einzelner vermag und ist potentiell, und das muss ja gar nicht alles aktualisiert werden, da würde ich sagen, ist das Individuum tatsächlich eine Tatsache, hinter die ich auch nicht zurückgehen will. Weil das dann tatsächlich sonst eine Art der Kollektivierung oder eine Untertanenmentalität wäre, die ich ja zutiefst verachte. Und deswegen ist da das Individuum wichtig.
Ja, das Individuum ist super wichtig. Nur, wir unterstellen ja jetzt, Wolfram Weimer schon die ganze Zeit eine, also wir haben eine spezifische Kritik, die wir ja jetzt nochmal explizieren können. Wenn er sagt, die Menschen, die Freiheit, das Individuum, er meint ja sich.
Ja.
Und dieser kleine heilige Humor bei Niklas Luhmann, dass er immer ihm unterstellt wird, in seinem Gesellschaftssystem finden ja Menschen nicht statt und so, ne? Dann muss man sagen, nee, doch, da finden Menschen statt. Man muss nur sagen, welche man meint. Und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Denn wenn wir einfach nur sagen, das Individuum, und es gab mal eine Zeit, wo das Individuum und dann hat es so gute Ideen gehabt und eine Gesellschaft ist entstanden, dann reden wir über eine Zeit, sagen wir mal vor 50.000 Jahren, da gab es überhaupt nur eine Million Menschen. So diese ganze Idee, dass wir heute acht Milliarden Menschen haben, also acht Milliarden mal uns das Individuum und seine Freiheit diese Frage stellen. Diese ganze Frage steht überhaupt nur im Raume, weil wir eine extrem erfolgreiche Gesellschaft haben, die Voraussetzung dafür ist, dass diese Individuen überhaupt biologisch geboren werden. Also am Anfang, man kann nicht sagen, zuerst war das Individuum und dann fiel die Gesellschaft über das China und dann hat sie es wieder freigekämpft. Nein, genau umgedreht. Das ist wie ein Hühnerstall. Wenn diese Hühner keiner braucht, dann werden die nie geboren. Wenn wir einfach sagen, ich möchte nicht, dass Tiere leiden, ist die Folge nicht, ja dann lassen wir sie einfach aus dem Stall raus auf die freie Wiese, wo sie als Naturgeschöpfe in der Natur und dann einfach Gras fressen. Nein, die Erfolge wäre, diese Tiere müssen nicht befreit werden, weil sie ja nie geboren würden. Ja, so. Ja, und das ist ganz wichtig. Deswegen auch, wer Menschheit sagt, lügt halt so ein bisschen. Man darf ruhig ehrlich sagen, es geht um mich. Unterm Strich zähle ich. Wenn Wolfram Weimer sagt, ich verteidige hier nicht das Konservative und das Individuum, sondern mein Lifestyle, wäre das alles super ehrlich. Deswegen kann man daraus auch kein allgemeines politisches Programm schreiben, weil es gibt nur in Landen mit 80 Millionen Menschen, kann sich 10.000 Wolfram Weimers leisten. Mehr nicht. Danach ist Sense. Wenn es nur 20.000 gäbe, die so leben und das verteidigen wollen, ist schon Klimakrise. Und zwar nicht erst übermorgen, sondern schon morgen. Von daher ist das diese ganze Verlogenheit, die da drinsteckt. Umso enger er das hinführen will, um das Individuum, umso größer wird nur die Lüge.
Ja, ihm gelingt es ja auch dann nicht, wenn er sagt, aber da brauchen wir schon auch Patriotismus. Und dann plötzlich macht er eine Unterscheidung, nämlich, wer darf dann überhaupt patriotisch sein? Wer ist denn der wahre Patriot? Beziehungsweise, wer ist der richtige Staatsbürger? Die Patriazivitatis, das staatsbürgerliche Vaterland, steht für den Konservativen neben der Patria Naturae, dem natürlichen Vaterland. Um auf die Begrifflichkeit Zizeros zurückzugreifen, die Nation wird als offene Gemeinschaft von freien Staatsbürgern verstanden. Zugleich aber auch als eine in sich geschlossene kulturelle Abstammungsgemeinschaft. Ja, und das ist dann Ethnopluralismus. Dass man sagt, ja, das Individuum, wenn es denn deutsch ist, deutsch geboren ist und die Ahnen auch noch da sind, ja, oder zumindest nachweisbar sind, dann kann ich sagen, dieses Individuum hat in der freien Gesellschaft, wenn es dann sich auch patriotisch genug verhält, das Glück, sich zu verwirklichen. Alle anderen, die das nicht haben, die diese ganzen Akzendenzen nicht aufweisen, die mögen zwar auch Individuen sein, aber damit haben wir nichts zu tun.
So, wir verraten jetzt mal nicht, welches Auto du dir gekauft hast, sondern wir stellen mal zwei Möglichkeiten vor. Ein Fiat 500, aber schon Baujahr, zehn Jahre alt. Oder eine neue S-Klasse. Okay. So, wie sähe das Gespräch von dir oder auch deine Gedankenwelt in der S-Klasse aus? Und würdest du ernsthaft bei dieser Argumentation bleiben, wenn du in den Fiat 500 einsteigst? Und das ist diese Verlogenheit hier. Er redet nicht über den Staat oder dieses ganze Patriazivitatis und so. Nein, er ist schon eine Stufe weiter. Er redet über den S-Klasse Staat, Deutschland, seine Heimat, das Einzige, was er kennt.
Warum ist hier eine Baustelle?
So würde er über Ghana nicht schreiben. Diese Argumentation taugt überhaupt nicht für einen 15-jährigen Nigerianer.
Nein, aber warum sagt er da nicht einfach Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland? Nein, er ruft philosophische Begriffe auf, will so eine Art philosophische Anthropologie vom Individuum herleiten. Und macht das aber dann nicht. Er macht das dann nicht. Und übrigens, in der S-Klasse, da fährt man, glaube ich, dann nicht mehr selbst, da wird man gefahren. Also das ist...
Soweit ich weiß, macht S-Klasse fahren noch Spaß.
Ja, aber da muss ich jetzt auch mal fragen, wo will man dann damit noch gut durch die Gegend fahren?
Also ich habe Reportagen mit Felix Lobrecht gesehen, der mit seiner Lila beleuchteten Interieur S-Klasse durch Berlin fährt und sich einen Döner holt.
Ja, das...
Scheint ihm Spaß zu machen, so wie ich das gesehen habe.
Also ich würde mal sagen, wenn ich in der Liga wäre, dass ich mir eine S-Klasse leisten kann, dann muss man auch in der Liga sein, dass man sich darin fahren lässt und das macht ja keinen Spaß.
Und dann über den Fiat 5, da müsstest du neben dem Fahrer sitzen.
Nee, hinter. Geht ja nicht, im kleinen Fiat. Ach so, im Fiat? Nee, dann natürlich nicht.
Also wenn du noch mit dem Fahrer umsteigst auf...
Genau, das wäre die Idee, um sich einen Chauffeur leisten zu können, fährt man einfach Fiat.
Wenn wir diese verlogene Argumentation mal deabstrahieren, also vom Konservativen zu dem Konkreten, was er eigentlich meint, von das Individuum zum eigentlich Konkreten, von die Gesellschaft zum Konkreten, dann wäre das einfach, ich, Deutscher, will in Deutschland in einem deutschen Auto fahren.
Und zwar schnell.
Genau. Und bloß keine Verkehrsschilder. Und wenn ich da jemanden dabei habe und wir fahren zum Essen, will ich das von der Steuer absetzen. So billig ist diese Argumentation.
Richtig.
Nur weil er die ganze Zeit begrifflich irgendwo hin transferiert und sich dann klug fühlt. Aber solange man einfach nur Publizist ist und Texte schreibt, fällt das halt nicht auf. Wenn man Politik macht, dann ist Realität einfach näher.
Wir dürfen gespannt sein. Nun ist das, was er machen kann als Kulturstaatsminister auch nicht so groß. Ich meine, wir wollen das hier nochmal ganz ausdrücklich sagen. Ich fand, ich will Folgendes sagen. Man kann nicht das, was er hier steuerlichen Sachen oder so gerne umsetzen würde, das kann er nicht gestalten als Minister für Kultur. Das wollte ich damit sagen. Natürlich ist seine Gestaltung, die er jetzt als Kulturminister hat, relativ groß, weil er natürlich wahnsinnig viel wegkürzen kann.
Wenn er die ganzen Überbau nicht erkennt.
Ja, wir werden jetzt noch ein paar kulturpolitische Äußerungen von ihm auch sehen, was ich hier deutlich sagen will. Ich war ja jemand, der Claudia Roth von der ersten Stunde an wirklich schrecklich fand und ich nehme auch kein Wort zurück und bin auch sofort nochmal dabei, mich hier in Rage zu reden.
Du musst jetzt aufsatteln.
Aber es wird natürlich schlimmer. Leider muss man sagen, es wird schlimmer.
Absolut.
Dem Konservativen aber ist Heimat nicht nur ein Kompensationsraum, der eine Zuflucht vor den Zumutungen der Moderne verheißt. Er ist das Ureigene, das einfach da war und da ist. Heimat ist ihm im Sinn Heideggers das Boden Ständige, ein Boden, der ständig da ist. Und so freut sich der Konservativen. Der Boden, der ständig da ist, es sei denn, der Vermieter hat was anderes vorgesehen. Dann ist der Boden plötzlich nicht mehr da. Dass die Heimat plötzlich bei allen beliebt ist, sein Wert wieder populär ist. Die Sehnsucht nach Wurzeln und Lokalkolorit ist ein gewaltiges Zeitgeistphänomen. Die Globalisierer fangen selber an zu regionalisieren. So erklären sich auch die Nürnberger Bratwürste auf dem Bürger bei McDonalds. Ja, da haben wir es doch, da haben wir doch alles erklärt. Wir werden wieder alle konservativ. Endlich Nürnberger Rostbratwürstchen bei McDonalds. Rechtstreue, denn wir wissen ja, Recht und Ordnung sind wichtige Prinzipien für Konservative.
Und in Gefahr.
Sind in Gefahr und wir können uns schon ein bisschen denken, wohin es geht, aber es wird alles noch viel schlimmer. Rechtstreue hält der Konservative darum für ein hohes Gut, selbst wenn er fallweise politisch anderer Meinung sein kann, als die Parlamentsmehrheit oder ihre Gesetze. Er achtet die Integrationsfunktion des Rechts, da die Rechtseinheit zugleich eine politische Einheit herstellt und den Staat als Ganzes legitimiert. Ja, Recht ist wichtig, das haben wir jetzt verstanden. Was heißt das aber konkret, bzw. wann muss der Konservative sich empören? Uns würden ja da so paar Dinge einfallen.
Er hat ja schon ein paar genannt.
Wenn die Autorität des Rechts also untergraben wird, dann ist die Kritik des Konservativen nahe. Das ist zum Beispiel der Fall, wenn etwa linke Randalierer oder kleinkriminelle Migranten aus politischen Gründen weniger streng sanktioniert werden als andere. Das gilt aber auch in größeren politischen Zusammenhängen, wenn mit zweierlei Maß gemessen wird, etwa bei der Einhaltung von Euro-Stabilitätskriterien oder Verschuldungsgrenzen oder bei Grenzverletzungen nach den Regeln des Dubliner Abkommens. Dichtung gegen Migranten, Austeritätspolitik, wenn das nicht eingehalten wird, Rechtsbruch, dann müssen wir uns empören als Konservative.
Aber hier gehe ich schon ein bisschen verloren, weil hat er nicht eben noch so von der instinktiven Wahrhaftigkeit des Gerechtigkeitsgefühls irgendwie und so weiter.
Plötzlich brauchen wir ganz viele Regeln, brauchen wir Austeritätsregeln. Wir könnten ja auch einfach sagen, unsere Ahnen haben es schon immer gewusst, wie man das Geld ausgibt, deswegen brauchen wir gar keine Regeln. Warum eine Schuldenbremse? So könnte man ja auch argumentieren. Aber nein, hier brauchen wir plötzlich ganz dringende, künstlich geschaffene Normen, die wir einhalten müssen auf Teufel komm raus.
Das ist alles, ja.
Oder die Zyniker und Machtmenschen, die Karrieristen und Realpolitiker folgen Nietzsche heute mit einer Selbstverständlichkeit, mit der Wind durchs Land weht.
Schöne Worte.
Und wir denken, wen könnte er damit meinen? Wir springen mal gerade einen Clip weiter. Wen könnte er damit meinen? Also diese Machtpolitiker, diese Karrieristen. Meint er am Ende jemanden aus der CDU? Ja, durchaus möglich, aber vielleicht nicht so wie wir. Wir könnten jetzt an Bayer-Card oder sowas vielleicht denken. Na, ist ein bisschen anders. Die Selbst-Digitimation von Recht durch Macht ist ein Gift, an dem nicht nur Diktatoren schnüffeln, es versucht auch demokratische Politiker, die Recht zu weilen einer selbst definierten, höheren Moral unterordnen. Als die Bundesregierung nach dem Unfall von Fukushima schlagartig den Ausstieg aus der Atomenergiebefall brach sie damit geltendes Recht. Auch als die Euro-Kriterien für Staatsverschuldungen für ungültig erklärt wurden oder als Grenzgesetze aus humanitären Gründen beiseite geschoben wurden. Also 2015 Merkel, Fukushima-Ausstieg, Merkel und diese Neuverschuldung, Merkel. Dreimal Antin Merkel. Das ist also das, wo Großrecht gebrochen wird, wo machtbewusste Karrieristen sich durchsetzen. Man denkt also nicht an andere, da würden einem ja aus der CDU viele einfallen. Wir haben ja jetzt mal über die Agrarpolitik der CDU gesprochen. All das könnte man ja mal nennen. Nein, also immer da, wo der Staat was Sinnvolles tut, um Menschen zu unterstützen, zum Beispiel mit offenen Grenzen. Oder man sagt, ja, vielleicht so ein Super-Gau im eigenen Land wäre nicht so schön. Da bricht man das Recht.
Das ist Rechtsbruch. Während Cum-Ex, ganz recht, und zwar stand ja in den Büchern.
Wir wollen mal jetzt nicht drüber reden, muss man auch mal schauen. Aber ja, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Wir springen nochmal ganz kurz zurück, denn interessant ist, dass Wolfram Weimer sich auf, glaube ich, niemanden so häufig in diesem Manifest bezieht, wie auf Oswald Spengler, also der rechte Denker, der geschriebenen Untergang des Abendlandes. Wir werden ja von Peter Sloterdijk da sehr gut nochmal unterrichtet, wie dieses Denken von Spengler funktioniert. Wir haben das im Salon ja sehr ausführlich gemacht, das Sloterdijk Buch. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt niemanden mehr gefunden, außer jetzt vielleicht aus so einem Schnellroderkreis oder so, der sich konservativ nennt und dann sich auch positiv durchweg auf Oswald Spengler bezieht und auch noch nicht mal so einen Verlegenheitssatz einbaut, so na ja umstritten oder so was. Ja, nein, man zitiert einfach Oswald Spengler. Oswald Spenglers Kultur philosophische Analyse zum Untergang des Abendlandes beschreibt die Bedrohung bzw. den Zerfall der westlichen Kultur. Nach Spenglers Geschichtsvorstellung können Hochkulturen als Riesenpflanzen angesehen werden, die aus einer mütterlichen Landschaft heraus geboren werden, wachsen, reifen und schließlich eingehen. Ja, und das hier bald alles eingeht, davon handelt dann das Buch, denn es geht um die Familie. Dein großes Thema? Mal gucken, ob es da Überschneidungen zwischen deinem Buch und Weimers Buch gibt. Ich würde mal sagen eher nicht. Kaum eine andere soziale Institution hat in den letzten 20 Jahren einen solch hohen Zustimmungszuwachs erhalten wie die Familie. Für 80 bis 90 Prozent der jungen Menschen ist Familie wichtig bis sehr wichtig. Ebenso viele wollen selbst eine Familie gründen und auf Dauer mit einem Partner zusammenleben. Klingt ja erst mal gut. Die meisten wollen Kinder. Der Shell-Studie zufolge kommen 92 Prozent der deutschen Jugendlichen derzeit gut und sogar bestens mit ihren Eltern aus. Die Werte sind in den vergangenen Jahren deutlich gestiegen. Interessant ist auch, dass der Erziehungsstil der Eltern große Zustimmung erfährt. Kurzum, das Verhältnis von Eltern und Kindern ist so gut wie lange nicht mehr. Damit sind nicht nur die Ideologen der kritischen Theorie widerlegt. Das vierte Gebot trägt gewissermaßen einen Sieg davon. Nee, die sind nicht widerlegt, die Leute der kritischen Theorie. Die 68er und alles, was dann an Pädagogik und so weiter kam, die haben dafür gesorgt, dass die Kinder heute ein besseres Verhältnis zu ihren Eltern haben, dass sie Probleme ansprechen können, dass sie in der Lage sind, ihren Eltern mitzuteilen, was sie im Inneren betrifft, dass sie über ihre Sexualität, ihre Neigung sich äußern können, dass sie nicht wegziehen müssen und den Eltern irgendwas vorspielen müssen, dass Eltern Kinder nicht mehr schlagen. All diese Errungenschaften von 68 haben dazu geführt, dass heute tatsächlich das Verhältnis von Kindern und Eltern besser denn je ist. Warum widerlegt hier irgendwas die Frankfurter Schule?
Genau. Plus, ein ganz pragmatischer politischer Einschlag. Das Buch ist jetzt 2018. Damals brauchte man schon die Mietbürgschaft seiner Eltern mit 27. Also stellte man sich mit ihnen besser gut. Außerdem, mit wem sonst? Man hat ja nur noch Social Media Freunde gehabt. Also hier greifen ja ganz viele Sachen. Wir haben ja dann danach, Corona-Krieg, Krise und der ganze Kram, die Kinderzahl ist jetzt in Berlin bei 1,1 Kindern pro Frau. Ja. Und da kann man, also es stimmt ja soweit, die jungen Frauen und Männer wünschen sich einen Partner und die wünschen sich Kinder. Und das mit dem Partner klappt auch meistens. Also die Unzufriedenheit ist da gar nicht so groß. Auch wenn es immer Dating-Geschichten gibt, die natürlich so ein bisschen was anderes erzählen und so. Aber wer steht dem eigentlich im Wege? Ein Staat, der ihm die ganze Zeit sagt, du musst es selber machen. Das Individuum bist du. Wir haben ja kein Geld für dich. Das Kinderzimmer muss 700 Euro kosten. Das ist ja immer ein 15 Quadratmeter groß.
Wir hören mal rein. Die Familie ist das fundamentale Band zwischen den Menschen, auf das Nation und Staat aufbauen können. Politik und Sozialstaat können die familiären Bindungen und die menschliche Fürsorge weder ersetzen noch schaffen. Siehst du, das ist genau das, dass man so tut, als hätte der Staat gar nichts damit zu tun. Naja, die menschliche Fürsorge kann erst dann gewährleistet werden, wenn zum Beispiel genügend Wohnraum vorhanden ist, damit man nicht in so engen Verhältnissen lebt, dass man sich gegenseitig hassen muss. Der Staat hat eine Verantwortung dafür, wie weit Schulwege sind, wie das Essen an den Schulen sind. Das ist ja etwas, was primär staatliche Aufgabe ist. Und jetzt wird aber so getan, als wollten Linke die mütterliche oder väterliche Fürsorge ersetzen durch den Staat. So, als müsste der Staat abends die Kinder ins Bett bringen. Nee, das machen ja immer noch die Eltern. Die Frage ist nur, ob das Bett im Schlafzimmer der Eltern mitstehen muss oder ob das Kind ein eigenes Zimmer haben wird.
Also hier muss man einfach ganz deutlich werden, diese Ideologie von ihm steckt ja in allem drin. Jordan Peterson war jetzt bei Joe Rogan wieder. Da geht es genau darum, wie diese elementare Eltern-Kind-Liebe so einen Tribalismus begründet, also mein Kind und das alle meiner Nachbarn und Freunde und so. Und dann erwächst daraus irgendwie so ein Nationalstaatsgefühl oder sowas. Weil du weißt ja, die Freiburger Kinder sind ja uns so da wie nicht die Warschauer Kinder. Also irgendwie so eine komische Idee.
Und das ist ja auch immer die Frage, die gestellt wird, die aber würdest du nicht für deine Kinder oder für die Nachbarskinder sterben wollen? Würdest du für die nicht kämpfen wollen?
Wo kommt die Solidarität her? Dann bricht man es runter, bis auf im Schützengraben hängt man sich die Kinder und die Ehefrau auf und für die kämpft man. Und dass da noch Politik stattfindet, ist irgendwann nicht mehr eingeblendet. Diese Idee, die er da hat, ist ja nun ein politisches Programm gewesen seit Ronald Reagan. Ja, also diese ganze Idee von die Zeugung und Geburt eines Kindes sind so entweder Natur oder göttlich. Kann man sich dann aussuchen, aber mit Gesellschaft hat das nichts zu tun. Weil wir haben ja gelernt, zuerst das in die Video oben und so. So, und die FDP hatte ja 2015 oder 2016 so ein Programm German Mood, wo sie das mal so richtig explizit reingeschrieben haben. Der Staat kann höchstens Geld zahlen, aber auf gar keinen Fall Zitat Herzenswärme spenden. Eine soziale Zuwendung ist ja keine Herzenswärme. Das kann nur die Familie selbst. Also hält sich der Staat lieber raus. Und dann war jetzt in Wien auch wieder die Frage, wenn ich da so anfange über Familie zu reden, ist das nicht falsch, Liebe so zu politisieren oder sowas? Dann sag ich einfach, nee, es geht mir nicht um Liebe zu politisieren, sondern Familie ist, wo Kinder sind. Dass da auch noch Liebe sein kann, okay, aber geht erstmal nur um die Kinder. Wenn Kinder da sind, reden wir von Familie. Dass die Eltern Eheleute sein könnten, die sich lieben, wie auch immer. Wenn man das forcieren möchte, muss man die Familie politisieren. Und mit politisieren ist halt einfach gemeint, Geld geben. Eltern wissen sehr gut, was sie mit Geld machen, genau wie Forscher. Die brauchen kein Programm von Söder, weil er auf den Mond fliegen will, sondern die Forscher kennen ihre Fragestellung ziemlich genau. Die brauchen nur Geld. Familien auch. So und wenn dann das Kind im Bett liegt, muss man, klingt sehr hart, aber das ist jetzt meine Überzeugung, muss man die Liebe der Eltern erkaufen. Und das ist halt ein Babysitter oder sowas. Denn einfach nur sich um das Kind kümmern die ganze Zeit. Also ja, da hat man so eine Pseudo, ich bin dem ausgeliefert, ich muss jetzt Zeit mit dem Kind verbringen, wie auch immer. Also da ist wenig Spielraum. Aber wenn es plötzlich ist, ach so, wir können jetzt Service in Anspruch nehmen, wie so ein Arbeitnehmer, wie so ein Wolfram Weimer. Wenn wir uns bewegen, kriegen wir Geld. Auto wird billiger und so. Wenn das alles gegeben wäre für eine Familie, dass man sagt, geht doch mal abends ins Restaurant, aber euer Sushi kostet nur halb so viel, weil ihr tragt ja schon für den Nachwuchs bei. Dann hätte man sofort eine Liebesexplosion in Deutschland. Also dann würden sich die Leute übereinander herfallen. Also Freiraum für Liebe schaffen, nicht umgedreht. Auch hier wieder diese Idee von, nee, die Herzenswärme kann nur von den Eltern kommen, da dürfen wir uns nicht einmischen. Nein, nein, nein.
Schon gar nicht mit Geld, so was.
Genau, genau.
Das ist ja so kalt.
Darf ich sagen, Vorzeichen einfach mal komplett umdrehen.
Geld ist ein allgemeines Äquivalent. Das ist das Schöne daran und deshalb kann das so wunderbar überall eingesetzt werden. Bedeutet, die jungen Leute brauchen mehr Geld, damit sie Liebe erleben können, weil sie dann mit dem Zug da hinreisen können, wo der Liebste die Liebste lebt. Das ist der Punkt und das heißt nicht, der Staat organisiert die Liebe zwischen den beiden in dem Sinne, dass der Staat mit im Bett ist. Nein, die Spielräume, das ist das entscheidende. Und das ist ja bei Wolfram Weimer so. Und das ist ja bei Markus Lanz und bei all diesen Leuten so. Die brauchen ja nur zu sagen, wie organisiere ich das, wen soll ich anrufen oder wer ruft für mich jemanden an, der das organisiert. Und dann ist Geld nicht die Frage, weil es da ist. Und für alle anderen stellt sich immer die Frage, ja, aber kann ich mir das denn überhaupt jetzt gerade leisten?
Söder arbeitet bis 22 Uhr und 22.20 ist ja zu Hause, weil sein Fahrer steht bereit und bringt ihn nach zu Hause. Und jeder andere arbeitet bis 20 Uhr und ist 22.20 zu Hause. Und das ist halt dieser Unterschied. Da muss man einfach Geld reinbringen und dann klappt es auch mit der Liebe.
Ehe und Familie. Ehe und Familie sind dem Konservativen keine zufällige soziologische Konstruktion, sondern die Wiege der Gemeinschaft, jener Raum, in dem sich soziale Kompetenz und Ethik entwickelt. Linke wollen diese Aufgaben tendenziell kollektivieren und den Kitas, Schulen, Staatsinstitutionen, familiäre Kompetenzen zuweisen. Der Konservative hält sich an Hegel und will die Unmittelbarkeit der Sittlichkeit leben lassen. Gut, demnach können wir ja auch einfach die Schulen abschaffen und sagen, das sollen die Eltern auch noch gerade selbst machen. Wir erziehen einfach unsere Kinder selbst, unterrichten sie ein bisschen Mathe, was jeder kann und das reicht.
Also Ehe und Familie darf man nicht zusammen denken. Familie ist etwas ganz Eigenständiges. Und da kann man auch sagen, Familie ist alles. Also wenn wir es uns historisch anschauen, ist Familie das Dorf, die Solomutterschaft, heute alles. Also Familie ist, wo Kinder sind. Das ist so die Definition.
Nicht für Wolfram Weimer.
Die Ehe, wie wir sie heute leben in diesem Industriezeitalter, die Fabriken brauchten Arbeiter, die Arbeiter braucht niemand, der die Sachen sauber macht. Und der aktuelle Bundespräsident dankt noch den unbesungenen Helden des Kohlezeitalters, den Ehefrauen, die die Klamotten gewaschen haben und so. Also Ehe, wir haben uns jetzt, also dieses Ehe-Modell, was wir gerade fahren, das ist konstruiert.
Natürlich.
Jeder, der sich die Geschichte anschaut und sieht die Pastorenfamilie und dann die dynastische Eheschließung als politischer Akt, wer da sagt, ne, das war Gott gegeben, das ist völlig absurd. Ja, also das ist total konstruiert. Dieses Pastorenfamilienpaar hat diszentrale Gebäude neben der Kirche im Dorf bekommen. Da sollten die leben. Und dann haben sie idealtypisch, wir die Eheleute, er ist eigentlich mehr so mit Gott und so. Ja, und dann hat man so versucht, so eine, und das ist ja dann diese protestantische Ethik und so, aus dieser Reformidee so eine allgemeine, das ist die Keimzelle der Gesellschaft, so zu bauen. Das heute einfach so, Ach, Ehe und Familie war immer, ja.
Immer eins.
Die Natur hat es quasi, es geht gar nicht anders. Das ist auf gar keinen Fall soziologisch konstruiert. Na, soziologisch nicht, soziologisch ist es beobachtet, aber sozial ist es total konstruiert. Nichts ist so konstruiert wie eine moderne Ehe.
Ja, und das ist ja gerade das, was ich diesen konservativen...
Das heilige Steuerrecht besteht daraus, diese Ehe zu konstruieren.
Ja, und diese Unredlichkeit kreide ich ja den Konservativen wie Wolfram Weimer und vielen weiteren an, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, diese Konstruiertheit einmal einzugestehen. Und dann kann man ja auch sich noch fragen, was ist denn bewahrenswert? Also die Frage stellt sich ja trotzdem, auch wenn man diese Konstruiertheit erst einmal voraussetzt. Aber indem man einfach so tut, als sei es immer alles schon da gewesen und als müsse man sich jetzt gegen jede Modernisierung wehren, ist man ja intellektuell so unredlich, dass der Rest dann auch blöde wird. Hören wir mal weiter. Der Trend zur Verzweckung des Menschen ist dem Konservativen zutiefst fremd. Alles war nur Verzweckung. Die gesamte Ehe ist Verzweckung, damit der Mann schaffen geht und die Frau bügelt zu Hause. Das ist Verzweckung. Gerade sein Familienbild bezieht den autonomen moralischen Wert von Schwachen, Alten, Kranken als Teil der liebens- und schützenswerten Familie mit ein. Nützlichkeitsmaßstäbe lehnt der Konservative daher ebenso ab, wie theoretische Ersatzkonzeptionen oder Ideologien für Ehe und Familie, etwa die Genderideologie der vergangenen Jahre, die den Unterschied und die natürliche Aufeinanderbezogenheit von Mann und Frau leugnet. Ja, also wir können uns denken, wie Ehe sich vorgestellt hat von Wolfram Weimer.
Diese Genderideologie, die dazu führte, dass eine junge Frau noch mal kurz anmerkte, ich weiß nicht, ob das mein letzter Lebenssinn ist, jetzt den Schwiegervater, den ich gar nicht kenne und den ich auch nie kennenlernen werde, weil der hat ja Demenz. Jeden Morgen muss ich wieder sagen, ich bin übrigens Diana. Wer? Und so. Am Ende prüben die sich gegenseitig tot. Also das ist so Realität in Deutschland. Wurde da nicht drüber geredet, wie viel Gewalt ist in dieser Art von, ne ne, da darf sich keiner einmischen. Das ist so. Die, das ist wirklich absurd.
Du schreibst ja in deinem Familienbuch darüber, dass wir ja ein demografisches Problem haben und du sagst, es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass der Staat Spielräume erweitert, damit die Menschen, die gerne Kinder hätten, auch dies realisieren und nicht Angst haben müssen, dass sie sich das nicht mehr leisten können oder so etwas. Und dann gibt es noch das zweite natürlich, das migrationspolitische Feld, dass man sehr viel Zuwanderung zulassen kann. Und damit hätte man das demografische Problem auch gelöst. Was du ja nicht machst, ist das, was Wolfram Weimer hier jetzt tut. Er sorgt sich ja, er um wen eigentlich? Jetzt wird es wirklich gruselig. Europa vermehrt sich nicht mehr biologisch. Die Geburtenraten sind hier so niedrig wie nirgends auf der Welt. Der alte Kontinent wird buchstäblich alt. Seine Bevölkerung ist so hoch betagt wie keine andere. Also biologisch.
Wir hören uns nicht mal biologisch.
Nein, das soll bedeuten, also es gibt weniger. Die europäischen Gene, das europäische Blut, das wird jetzt weniger. Wir wissen ja, in Afrika gibt es ganz, ganz viele Geburten und Südamerika auch mehr als vier.
Weiß er, dass Nigarianer auch biologisch funktionieren?
Ja, aber er meint, mit biologisch meint er tatsächlich, also wir sind ja jetzt eigentlich in der Kategorie von Rasse und Blut.
Das ist eigentlich superwitzig. Ich habe ja eben noch kritisiert, er konkretisiert nicht, was er sagt, sondern zieht sich auf die allgemeinsten Verlegenheitsbegriffe, das Individuum, die Gesellschaft und so weiter. Jetzt redet er aber plötzlich von der europäischen Biologie. Ganz konkret.
Na ja, da sind wir halt sehr nahe an einem Ethnopluralismus.
Ja, aber glaubt ihr, er ist entschuldigt, weil er ja nicht deutsche Biologie sagt?
Ja, wir hören mal weiter. An der Expansion der Menschheit sind die Europäer nicht mehr beteiligt. Jenseits der Expansion der Menschheit, wir kennen das schon so ein bisschen von Elon Musk und Jeff Bezos. Wir brauchen eigentlich 1000 Motsats. Also wie kriegen wir das hin? Machen wir erstmal Abtreibungsverbote, damit da schon mal niemand mehr verloren geht. Aus der düsteren demografischen Zahlenspiele ist dem Konservativen die biologische Selbstaufgabe das markanteste Zeichen für den zivilisatorischen Untergang Europas. Also biologische Selbstaufgabe. Das bedeutet also, wir als Rasse, also hier ein Anführungszeichen gesetzt, das ist unser Problem. Also dass wir uns als Rasse nicht mehr vermehren. Weiter, Oswald Spengler erkannte diesen Zusammenhang schon lange vor den so dramatisch fallenden Geburtenraten und formulierte stechend– und nun geht aus der Tatsache, dass das Dasein immer wurzeloser, das Wachsein immer angespannter wird, endlich jene Erscheinung hervor, die im Stillen längst vorbereitet war und jetzt plötzlich in das helle Licht der Geschichte rückt, um dem ganzen Schauspiel ein Ende zu bereiten. Die Unfruchtbarkeit des zivilisierten Menschen. Hier liegt eine durchaus metaphysische Wendung zum Tode vor. Der letzte Mensch der Weltstädte will nicht mehr leben, wohl als Einzelner, aber nicht mehr als Typus, als Menge. Was Spengler schon 1917 so ahnungsvoll final beschrieb, gehört zu den erschütterndsten Diagnosen über die Befindlichkeit Europas. Spengler hatte übrigens auch keine Kinder. Das ist also jetzt der Bezugspunkt. Auswahl Spengler, Ende der europäischen Zivilisation und jetzt kommt tatsächlich noch das Thema Blut. Während Generation um Generation in einer Jahrtausende währenden Selbstverständlichkeit die Fortdauer der eigenen Familie, des eigenen Blutes, der Sippe, des Stammes, der Nation, der Kultur, der Zivilisation als einen heiligen Moment des Lebens begriffen hat, so bricht dieses Bewusstsein plötzlich in Scherben. Dieser Bruch ist bei Gebildeten zerstörerischer als bei Ungebildeten. Er ist in Städten tiefgreifender als auf dem Land, was den zivilisatorischen Zerfall noch beschleunigt. Man weiß gar nicht mehr, was man dazu sagen soll. Wir sind jetzt in dem Bereich angekommen, wo wir sagen, wir müssen jetzt wieder das eigene Blut verteidigen. Ich weiß nicht, Kinder für den Führer und fürs Vaterland.
Das ist ja total durchgeknallt.
Ja. Ich war auch, ich konnte es gar nicht glauben. Ich lese das und dann denkt man so, ja, nächsten Mal den Absatz nochmal davor und danach. Ist irgendwas zum Kontext gezogen? Nein. Es steht da so drin. Ich habe es ja jetzt in aller Ausführlichkeit vorgelesen. Das ist die Position. Wir gehen los von, ja, schade, die Leute wollen ja eigentlich Kinder haben. Und dann könnte man sich ja Fragen stellen, wie verwirklichen wir das? Dann kommen wir eigentlich dazu, ja, wie kommt das nicht? Das ist dieser Drang, doch über Generationen, das eigene Blut und so weiter. Als hätte je irgendjemand Kinder machen wollen aus so einer Ideologie heraus. Und wenn dann eben, ja, war man völlig ideologisch verblendet, wenn man das tat. Und jetzt will er genau dahin wieder zurück. Also nachdem er erst das Individuum völlig glorifiziert, sagt er jetzt, jetzt muss man sich wieder einreihen in eine Blutslinie. Also wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2025 und sind jetzt bei solchen Denkkonzepten wieder angekommen, von denen sich ja auch vernünftige Konservative zu Recht in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten weit distanziert haben, wollten davon nichts wissen. Er ist auch jemand, und er streicht das noch, das sind jetzt Abschnitte, die ich nicht mitgebracht habe, da sagt er nochmal ganz gern, dass er sich gegen den Staatsbürgerpatriotismus stellt. Das würde nicht ausreichen. Also das, was habermaßen andere vorgestellt hatten, dass man sagt, naja, man kann sich mit dem Verfassungspatriotismus, Entschuldigung, man kann es mit der Verfassung identifizieren. So ist ja auch ein merkwürdiges Konzept, aber ist ja zumindest eines, das sich wirklich dezidiert löst von so etwas wie Blut und Boden. Und das ist aber hier wieder was kommt und wo man sagt, ja, das ist jetzt ja unser neuer Konservatismus.
Ja, aber der Typ wird in eine wahllose Oper gehen und sich fragen, warum der große Puccini, der doch unser europäischer Blutitaliener ist, plötzlich eine Oper in Japan spielen lässt. Und er würde das nicht gut finden.
Ja, man kann das ja natürlich so inszenieren, dass das nur so ein Exotismus ist, aber vielleicht wird ihm dann der Lohn kriegen.
Stell dir mal vor, du hättest jetzt wirklich die Sorge, ein Programm schreiben zu müssen.
Vielleicht wird ihm ja der Lohn kriegen dann gut gefallen.
Wie schreibst du ein Programm für eine Spielzeit, bei der jeden Abend die Gefahr sein kann, dass Wolfram Weimer davon Wind kriegt, was da passiert? Das kriegst du ja gar nicht abgesichert. Also du müsstest ja alles abreißen und abbauen, was es hier ausmacht.
Es gibt ja nicht nur Kritik daran. Ijoma Mangold, der ja vor allem Bitcoins im Kopf hat, hat ja auch sich zu Weimer geäußert in einem längeren Artikel und schreibt da, aber er ist doch das vernehmbare Widerwort zum linksliberalen Mainstream, der in den vergangenen 15 Jahren nicht nur die Kulturpolitik geprägt hat. Wenn es also weltweit einen kulturellen Vibe-Shift gibt, dann ist dieser jetzt in der denkbar maßvollsten und abwägensten Verkörperung im neuen Berliner Kabinett angekommen.
Wer hat das nicht gelesen?
Nee. Aber wenn man nach den Worten sagt, das ist maßvoll und abgewogen, dann ist man ja völlig schief gewickelt.
Das ist dieser Punkt, die lassen sich noch einwickeln, weil es ja so konventionell aussieht.
Ja, ja. Es ist nicht wie Tucker Carlson. Es ist nicht wie Tucker Carlson im Auftritt. Aber im Inhalt im Prinzip nicht zu unterscheiden. Oder wir können ja jetzt auch immer sehen bei TikTok, Ross und Hopf und wie sie alle heißen, das römische Reich. Der große Bezugspunkt, mit dem man sich auseinandersetzen muss, darf natürlich auch bei Wolfram Weimer nicht fehlen.
Trotz der rührend bemühten Familiengesetzgebung des Augustus, trotz der massenhaften Adoptionen, der aktiven Immigrations- und Ansiedlungspolitik, trotz der großen Sozialwerke von Nerva und Trajan entvölkerte, verödete sich das römische Reich, um sich für seinen Untergang bereit zu machen. Was also heißen soll, die haben ja damals auch Sozialpolitik gemacht, Stefan. Die haben ja auch Migration zugelassen und sozialen Wohnungsbau und sowas. Und es hat alles nichts geholfen. Wir gehen, wie die alten Römer, dem Untergang entgegen, wenn wir uns nicht auf unsere eigentlichen Tugenden wieder besinnen. Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, räumlich müssen wir wieder anders denken. Und wir haben ja hier schon gehört, man kann irgendwelche, was war das, Suess-Kanal oder so, freischießen. Wir hatten jetzt ja eine Kulturpolitik, die sehr viel sich mit dem Kolonialismus auseinandergesetzt hat. Restitution war das große Wort. Und ja, man kann natürlich schärfen, Ich würde mir schmerzhaft sagen, mitunter hat man Claudia Roth nur noch dabei beobachtet, wie sie irgendwas zurückgibt, macht sie auch sonst noch was außer was zurückgeben. Das wäre auch eine Polemik, zu der ich mich gerne hinreißen lasse. Aber...
Ich befürworte jede Zurückgabe.
Ich grundsätzlich, also ich bin auch gar nicht gegen diese Politik.
Sachen sind ja dann nicht aus der Welt, sie stehen nur nicht nur in Deutschland.
Ganz richtig, ganz richtig. Ich bin auch gar nicht gegen diese Restitutionspolitik. Ich wollte nur sagen, es war so ein bisschen, dass man so dachte, hat sie noch was anderes außer was zurückzugeben? Ja, also macht sie noch sonst Gestaltung? Nein, hat sie nicht gemacht. Was aber jetzt wieder ganz deutlich, was jetzt kommt, wird eben sehr viel schlimmer, beziehungsweise ist das tatsächlich in meinen Augen Geschichtsrevisionismus, aber jeder mag selbst beurteilen. Europa vermehrt sich nicht mehr räumlich. Das Zeitalter der europäischen Expansion, der Manifesten oder Latenten der politischen oder kulturellen Kolonialisierung ist 1945 zu Ende gegangen. Ja, Potsblitz, was war denn da los?
Ja, also schon, ja, ich verstehe den Gedanken, aber nein, denn 1945 ist das zu Ende gegangen. Also wir haben nicht mehr Lebensraum und so, aber 1965 begann die Containerschifffahrt und diese ganze Idee von, für jeden von uns arbeiten 50 Sklaven, wir wissen nicht mal, wo und wo.
Genau, aber er will natürlich Land und da beklagt er jetzt nochmal, wohin uns der Postkolonialismus geführt hat. Und ich bin, also ich hab's nicht glauben können. Wir hören jetzt einen Auszug. Als letzte portugiesische Kolonie wurde 1999 Macau an die Volksrepublik China abgetreten. England gab Hongkong 1997 ab. Um die Falklandinseln wird mit Argentinien gestritten, wie auf einer grotesken Nachhutveranstaltung, bei der man um prosamen streitet, nachdem man die Großbäckerei verloren hat. Im Alten Kontinent wurde dieser erdrutschartige Machtverlust nicht einmal bedauert. Man betrachtete die eigene Kolonialgeschichte mit moralischen Gewissensbissen als illegitime Expansion. Wie kommt man auf solche Idee? Das war echt eine Erfolgsgeschichte. Und jetzt hier, großes Augenwischen bei Wolfram Weimer erblickt auf die Schulen. Noch heute wird in den Lehrplänen der Schulen vor allem Mittel- und Nordeuropas die dunkle Seite der Kolonialisierung als durchgehender Sündenfall dargestellt und kritisiert. Ja, warum nennt man das denn als als ein Sündenfall? Also wir sind hier an einem Punkt, wo wir jemanden haben, der nicht bereit ist zu sagen, dass der Kolonialismus ein Sündenfall und nicht nur das ist, sondern eine riesengroße Schweinerei, sondern wir haben es hier mit jemandem zu tun, der sagt ja, wir müssen doch auch das mal wieder anders betrachten lernen. Und warum expandieren wir eigentlich räumlich nicht mehr? Also du hast eben gefragt, wie sieht eigentlich da ein Theater aus? Na ja, also alles, was jetzt in der bildenden Kunst oder in der Literatur oder so sich kritisch mit dem Kolonialismus auseinandergesetzt hat, bekommt hier natürlich ein großes Problem. Weil man jetzt gesagt bekommt, naja, aber der Kolonialismus war doch vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. Und dann hat man noch jemanden wie Ejoma Mangold, der sagt, das ist eine ganz abwägende, feine Art, über Kultur nachzudenken.
Also wir bekommen demnächst Aufklärung darüber, weil wir ja die eigenen Lügen nicht mehr aufrechterhalten können. Wie zum Beispiel, die ganze Welt ist abhängig von uns, sondern stellen wir fest, nee, China macht es selber. Also die setzen das einfach aus. War ja ein sehr interessantes Zitat von diesem Sprecher der Regierung, der da einfach sagt, auf die Frage hin, sind sie jetzt in Gesprächen mit Donald Trumps Regierung? Und er sagt so, nee, wieso sollen wir denen reden? Wir machen doch Wirtschaftskrieg. Also die wollten doch Wirtschaftskrieg, da redet man nicht. Also es wird so, während Donald Trump noch denkt, ah ja, die alten konventionellen Logiken, dann redet man halt darüber. Jetzt ist das nicht mehr. Und wir haben ja hier beim Kolonialismus zwei Etappen, weil er bezieht sich ja sehr auf diesen geschichtlichen Teil, wo man auch sagen kann, okay, wir hatten da so Räume, es waren so Gebiete irgendwie, Afrika gehört uns. Nur Kolonialismus bedeutet ja nicht nur das, sondern diese Containerschifffahrt und alles, was darauf folgte. Und in der Soziologie ist es eigentlich völlig klar, dass der Sklavenhandel nicht überwunden wurde oder die Sklaven befreit wurden oder wie auch immer, sondern letztendlich waren es auch betriebswirtschaftliche Abwägungen, nämlich zu sagen, ein Sklaven, um dem ich mich komplett kümmern muss, ist ganz schön teuer, weil irgendwo übernachten muss er ja doch und so. Und dann ist man so eine Rechnung eingegangen und meinte, ich brauche eigentlich nur seine Arbeit.
Und das kann man ja für viele Kolonien auch so sehen.
Genau.
Das hat man ja auch dann später noch mal durchgerechnet.
Genau, man braucht ja gar nicht die Länderei.
Das war gar nicht sinnvoll.
Wir brauchten das ja nur als Werkbank, als Rohstoffquelle und so weiter. Warum besetzen? Ist ja totaler Quatsch.
Warum sollte man Macao haben?
Genau. Also hat man globale Lieferketten aufgezogen, alles so ein bisschen ins Obskure. Wir wissen gar nicht genau. Und dann kommt einer und sagt, wir bräuchten mal eine Lieferkette. Und dann sagen die Deutschen so, nee, das ist so aufwendig, das zu machen. Wir wissen gar nicht, was da passiert und so. Und ich denke mir so, ja, das ist ja der Sinn der Lieferkette, dass ihr mal wisst, was da passiert. Und nicht einfach nur preisschild, achja, klick mal bestellen. Und diesen Teil des Kolonialismus und die ganze Debatte dreht sich ja eigentlich auch um diesen modernen Teil, der historische. Klar, der wird halt mitgeschleppt. Und als Warnung und sehr explizite, weil die Geschichtsschreibung da so eindeutig ist, da hängt das schlechte Gewissen dran, das Belassen halt. Aber jetzt gerade sehen wir ja, unser Neokolonialismus funktioniert nicht mehr. Und die größte Gefahr für Europa und Amerika ist, dass die Chinesen auch Neokolonialismus machen. Und wir dann irgendwann Werkbank sind. Also es ist eigentlich wichtig und wirklich politisch auch notwendig, jetzt eine Aufklärung zu schaffen, damit wir nicht auf die Opferseite geraten, weil die Chinesen machen uns platt. Also das ist einfach, wenn die durchziehen, ist einfach aus die Maus. So, können wir jetzt noch Sachen, also positive Erkenntnisse aus einer Täterschaft herausziehen oder nicht? So, und wenn wir das so wie er machen, einfach Deckel drauf und so weiter, ja dann müssen wir gleich im nächsten Kapitel das chinesische Jahrhundert zweifach einleiten. Nicht nur materiell, sondern dann auch noch, wir werden die Non-Opfer sein. Weil Wolfram Weimer sich nicht zugestanden hat, dass man eine Täterschaft mal aufarbeitet. Und dann wird es wirklich brenzlig.
Kulturelle Expansionen? Europa vermehrt sich nicht mehr kulturell. Was immer die global community an kulturellen Massenprägungen erlebt, vom Kino über die Popmusik bis zu technologiegetriebenen Kommunikationsformen wie Facebook und Co., kaum mehr etwas kommt aus Europa. Die weltweite Filmindustrie wird von den großen amerikanischen Produktionsfirmen Warner Brothers, Paramount, Sony Pictures, Buena Vista und Twentieth Century Fox komplett dominiert. Aber auch bei Musik, gedruckten Erzeugnissen, Internetinhalten, Nachrichten, Informationen spielen die Europäer nur mehr eine nachgeordnete Rolle.
Also wenn das jetzt Lesezeichen ist für der neue Kulturstaatsminister, der demnächst einfordert, eine ideelle europäische Hegomonie und sei es nur als Renaissance mal wieder zu kultivieren, möchte ich gern meinen Wunsch zurückziehen, dass die Oper Frankfurt auch mal Klassiker spielen sollte. Das will ich da nicht. Nicht unter diesen Voraussetzungen.
Du meinst das Schauspiel?
Nee, auch die Oper. Es wird ja immer noch die Werktreue hochgehalten und so, aber dass man auch mal ein bisschen abgeholt wird mit, können wir nicht einfach Wiener Klassik hören und so. Also das ist so ein bisschen einfach.
Naja, aber ich finde, dass die Frankfurter Oper ja doch so beide Sachen ganz gut bedient.
Ja, aber für Wolfram Weimer ist sie, glaube ich, zu verspielt.
Das mag sein. Vor allem frage ich mich jetzt hier, wenn er sagt, die Filme kommen alle aus Europa, kommen alle aus Amerika.
Ich glaube, fünf Jahre noch.
Ich kann ihm ja sagen, wann die deutsche Filmindustrie ganz groß war. Genau vor 100 Jahren, nämlich in den zwanziger Jahren, war die amerikanische Filmindustrie noch lange nicht so bedeutend. Die deutsche schon. Alfred Hitchcock war beispielsweise auch in Deutschland, hat da gelernt. Murnau, Fritz Lang, das sind alles Namen, die damals eifersreich waren und die dann auch den amerikanischen Film mit geprägt haben bzw. emigriert sind. Das würde also bedeuten, dass man für einen Weltmarkt in Deutschland Filme produziert. Das müsste man dann erreichen. Wie das zu machen ist, ich verrate es mal, mit sehr viel Geld wäre vielleicht irgendetwas herzustellen in diese Richtung, aber all das, was hier an kultureller Piefigkeit zum Vorschein tritt, das noch dem Ausland anzubieten, glaube ich, wird nicht gelingen. Er sieht aber uns hier sowieso nur als eine Große.
Weißt du nicht, dass wir nochmal Dieter Hallerforden-Filme für den Weltmarkt herstellen können?
Ja, ganz bestimmt. Es dämmert eine Tugendrepublik herauf, in der hohe Priester des Gutmenschen-Tums uns mit ihren Geboten umstellen.
Mama, stopp.
Du sollst kein Fleisch.
Das ist ja er. Er dämmert uns mit seinem Tugendkatalog, der von einer Partei jetzt in dieses Amt...
Nur die anderen Tugenden.
Genau.
Keine veganen Tugenden, sondern seine Tugenden.
Also man muss ja wirklich Angst haben, dass nachdem Hessen und Bayern es schon gemacht haben, jetzt ein Sprachtugendgesetz demnächst kommt, abgesegnet von Wolfram Weimer, in dem drinsteht, welche Pronomen und so wir, wo und welche Abschlussarbeit verwenden dürfen und man Punktabzug droht. Das ist hier in Hessen Realität.
Oder wenn man sich zu kritisch über den deutschen Kolonialismus äußert.
Oder sowas.
Ich bin übrigens sehr gespannt, weil ich ja doch nicht viel halte von Kulturschaffenden, um mal diesen Begriff zu nehmen. Also im Sinne von sie sind große Anpassungskünstler. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie jetzt gerade die, die sich der links-siberalen Idee so angedient haben, jetzt auch bereits in da so einen Umsprung hinzulegen. Denn ob es da zu einem großen Widerstand kommt, ich bin da sehr skeptisch. Also die, die da erfolgreich jetzt gerade so sind und irgendwelche Pavillons bestücken und was weiß ich alles machen auf allen möglichen Bühnen, die werden sich da schon entsprechend anpassen. Also da von den kulturellen Eliten erwarte ich mir nichts. Die machen immer gerade das, was gewünscht wird.
Und die Renaissance des deutschen Gute Nacht Liedguts steht auch aus.
Ja, wir werden so große volkstümmelnde Inszenierungen, irgendwas bekommen. Also wir können da sehr gespannt sein. Man sollte das wirklich nicht unterschätzen. Die Leute, die in der Kultur arbeiten, ich würde ihnen jetzt nicht, also wenn ich jetzt dringend, wenn ich in Not wäre, ich würde mich jedem auf der Straße anvertrauen, aber nicht jemanden aus den kulturellen Eliten. Das ist so... .mit ihren Geboten umstellen. Du sollst kein Fleisch essen und kein Kaminfeuer anzünden. Du sollst nicht glückspielen. Du sollst nicht nach Leistung beschäftigen, sondern nach Geschlecht und Herkunft. Mit Quoten und Verboten kommen sie daher, die Verbraucher und Familienschützer, die Gleichstellungsbeauftragten und Integrationsberater. Sie tragen Menschen teure Bildungspakete hinterher, die gar keine haben wollen, denn sie wissen alles besser. Sie sind Profiteure des Freiheitsentzugs, jene Armutsbekämpfer, Präventionsräte und Klimaretter, Lobbyisten der Gewissheitsindustrie, die ihr Geschäft mit der Besserwisserei so verfolgen, dass sie ihre Nachfrage mit Problemstudien immer selbst erzeugen. Ihre Absicht, das Land in eine gigantische Besserungsanstalt zu verwandeln, folgt einer ganz eigenen Logik. Denn dann haben sie als Besserungspädagogen ihr Auskommen. Wir hatten jetzt, bevor überhaupt mal was von der Regierung bekannt wurde, gleich diese Anfrage nach der Wahl von der CDU, welche NGOs unterstützt eigentlich die Ampelregierung. Da wurde ja genau so etwas, was hier kritisiert wird, schon abgefragt. Das bedeutet, wenn wir jetzt diesen Minister haben, wird er sich das alle sehr genau ansehen und wird schauen, welches Kulturfestival bringt nicht nur Literatur auf die Bühne, sondern hat auch noch den Anspruch, integrativ zu sein. Wo wird vielleicht noch irgendein pro-palästinensische Stimme artikuliert? Wie können wir mal dagegen vorgehen? Also wir werden hier tatsächlich eine sehr, sehr repressive Kulturpolitik bekommen. Und man darf gespannt sein, wer den Mut hat, sich dem entgegenzustellen. Und das können ja, ich will das hier auch ausdrücklich sagen, nur die Leute machen wirklich, die was an Erfolg vorzuweisen haben und die auch einen gewissen finanziellen Background haben. Wenn das jetzt ganz kleine Kulturinstitutionen alleine machen sollen, mutige Einzelne, die werden einfach vom Tisch gefegt und dann finden die nicht mehr statt und dann verstummen die auch sofort. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob diese ganzen Leute von Deutscher Filmpreis und wie diese ganzen, wie soll ich es ausdrücken, da sagen wir einfach mal Veranstaltungen, wie diese ganzen Veranstaltungen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie die es jetzt aussehen. Die sind nämlich bislang alle sehr stumm. Und sind es ja auch, wir wissen ja auch, während Corona gab es ja auch von denen überhaupt gar keinen Widerstand, als man irgendwelche sinnlosen Regeln immer noch hatte in Opernhäuser. Ich habe ja noch, ich habe es ja schon häufiger gesagt, in Maske in Berliner Theater gesessen. Da haben die im Alten Heim schon wieder Orgien gefeiert und so. Also dieser Anpassungskünstler aus der Kultur, die II, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, werden wahrscheinlich das mittragen, aber sich so ein minimal Widerstand erlauben.
Ich finde es auch nicht gut.
Es wird ganz schlimm.
Es ist wirklich schlimm.
Wie könnte die Kultur aussehen? Wir können ja nicht nur aus der Negation herausleben, sondern wir können ja auch mal darüber nachdenken, wie könnte es werden? Du hast schon überlegt. Wie sieht dann die nächste Oper aus? Na ja, wir werden ja den Parsifal besuchen. Das ist ja ein Bühnen-Weifestspiel. Wir haben es mit einer Rechristianisierung zu tun, so eine Idee des Urchristentums. Möglicherweise geht das. Wir hören jetzt noch einmal abschließend Wolfram Weimer von mir gelesen. Unsere Mythen, unsere Ethiken, unsere Metaphern, unsere Architektur, unser Freiheitsbegriff rekurrieren immer auf die jüdisch-christliche Religion. Ein vom Christentum befreites Europa ist gar kein Europa mehr. Denn just die Religion webt Europas Kleid des Unterbewusstseins. Insofern bedeutet ein Comeback des religiösen Bewusstseins automatisch eine Wiederkehr des Kulturbewusstseins. Das ist, nach Phasen der kulturellen Regression, der Infantilisierung und systematischen Geschichtslosigkeit keine schlechte Aussicht. Hegels provokante Analyse vom Vergangenheitscharakter der Künste muss daher nicht das Ende der Geschichte sein. Die Option ist jedenfalls, dass die Kultur wieder zurückfinden könnte, aus der spielerischen und ornamentalen Funktion zum Definitionscharakter ganzer Gesellschaften. Eine Rechristianisierung der Gesellschaft durch die Kultur. Wir dürfen gespannt sein.
Oh no, oh no, no, no. Und ich bin echt ein großer Fan von, ja, nicht Rechristianisierung, sondern so...
Du willst ja eine Museumisierung dessen haben. Genau. Aber hier geht es ja um eine Wiederbelebung. Und auch mit all den Implikationen, ja. Da schläft der Papa wieder bei der Mama.
Ich bin dagegen. Wir spielen zwei Clips aus der Nachrichtenlage zum Thema Wolfram Weimer wird Kulturstaatsminister, zum einen Michael Bröker. Ist ja im Grunde auch einer, der sich denkt, oh, wenn ich nur noch ein bisschen ein paar Jahre so rede, dann kann ich auch was werden.
Aber den Kulturstaatsminister zu machen, das ist ja auch ein bisschen aus Sicht dieser konservativen März und Weimer eine kleine Schocktherapie für die eher linke Kulturszene. Dieser Gedanke hat den beiden offenbar gefallen. Ich gehe sehr davon aus und habe auch nichts anderes gehört, als Wolfram Weimer selbst gesagt hat, dass das für ihn in Frage kommen würde und dass er darauf Lust hätte und nicht auf den Regierungsprecher.
Ja, das ist so ein typischer Fall von, also wenn wir jetzt Trump wählen, dann wird das für die Arbeitnehmer ganz schön schlimm. Und dann stellen irgendwie die Arbeitgeber fest.
Shit.
Ich dachte, das wäre die Schocks für die anderen. Plötzlich sind sie selber so geschockt.
Micky Beisenherz, der Politizist, Wolfram Weimer, ja hier auch schon mehrfach bei unserem Podcast zu Gast gewesen, guter Freund der Sendung, ein sicherlich konservativer Markt.
Sicherlich konservativer?
Ja, ja, also sonst sind wir natürlich da offen für alles, ja. Also das ist ja genau diese, in diesem Duktus wird die große Anpassung laufen. Also Micky Beisenherz ist ja auch so ein Anpassungskünstler an jede politische Gegebenheit immer auf der richtigen Seite. Und das können wir jetzt hier ja schon erleben.
Genau, die große Angst ist ja, dass demnächst die großen Fragen nicht mehr gestellt werden. Wir hören das mal hier...
.liberaler und es gibt jetzt schon die ersten, die aus der Position durchaus nachvollziehbar, also wie zum Beispiel Andréan Kreyer von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, die jetzt schon, wenn ich sage jaulen, dann klingt das so despektierlich, so meine ich es nicht, aber denen ist ein bisschen graus, weil sie jetzt Angst haben, dass da im Grunde genommen ein Rechter jetzt in dieses Amt kommt und was bedeutet das für die Kultur? So, klar, kann man mal, man kann die Frage mal stellen. Und eine Personalie ist natürlich, so man kann ja die Frage mal stellen, aber ich beantworte sie mal lieber nicht.
Genau, damit haben sie ja gestellt.
Weil Wolfram Weimer ja auch ein großer Fan dieses Podcasts ist.
Grüße.
Ja, wir machen mal eine kleine Voraussetzung. Das ist wirklich toll.
Lass uns doch gerade noch hinweisen auf unseren Samar.
Warte, ein Gednacht. Angenommen demnächst wird Kultur produziert. Und sie wird Widerhall finden wollen. So Kultur erschaffen, die möchten gern ihre Sachen, ihre Werke. Wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, es gibt diese Cum-Ex-Serie, Die Affäre Cum-Ex, die ziemlich gut verdeutlicht, um was es geht. Denn der Sachverhalt Cum-Ex wird gleich in den ersten drei Minuten erklärt und der ist auch nicht wahnsinnig kompliziert. Jetzt hören wir, wie diese Serie aus der Mediathek ins CDF-Programm rutscht und worum es Marietta Slomka beim Anpreisen der Serie geht.
Das war's von uns. Gleich geht's weiter mit den ersten vier Folgen der deutsch-dänischen TV-Serie Die Affäre Cum-Ex. Der Stoff ist fiktional, aber, sie ahnen es angesichts des Namens, stark angelehnt an sehr reale Vorgänge. Und kleine Vorwarnung, die Serie kann zu schwerem Binge-Watching führen, weil man unbedingt wissen will, wie es mit all den schillernden Figuren darin weitergeht.
Ja, ein schöner Übergang. So hätte man jetzt auch Dallas oder unter uns ankündigen können. Ja, sehr gut.
Die schillernden Figuren.
Wir weisen kurz darauf hin oder erst einmal weisen wir darauf hin, dass wir uns sehr freuen, wenn dieser Podcast geteilt wird, gut bewertet wird, denn es ist ja so, wir haben jetzt auch nochmal gehört, wie sich das so alles in der Podcastwelt gestaltet. Also bei Spotify und sonst wo, es ist ja so, dass diese Leute, die in großen Medienhäusern ihre Podcast betreiben, durchaus einen Bonus bekommen, indem sie einen kurzen Draht haben, wie man in irgendwelche Rankings reingekommt. Und so ist es ja erstaunlich, dass manche einen Podcast starten, die haben 3000 Klicks bei YouTube, aber sind irgendwie auf Platz eins in allen Podcast-Charts. Man denkt sich, wie kann das sein? Na ja, das sind so gute Connections, die dann da geltend gemacht werden. Wir haben diese Connections nicht, aber wir haben ja ein Publikum, haben euch. Und deswegen würden wir uns sehr freuen, wenn der Podcast viel geteilt wird und wenn er gut bewertet wird, weil das tatsächlich die Sichtbarkeit für den Podcast erhöht auf allen Plattformen.
Genau, wir machen die Hörbarkeit und ihr macht die Sichtbarkeit.
Und wir haben ja eine Möglichkeit, die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen, das ist der Salon. Der erscheint dann immer nach dieser regulären Folge, etwa eine Woche, zehn Tage später. In dem Salon sprechen wir über ein oder zwei wichtige Bücher. Darüber diskutieren wir dann ausführlich, meistens so ja knapp zwei Stunden. Und dann gibt es noch von uns Lektüre, Tipps. Wir lesen diesmal nicht nur ein Buch, sondern zwei Bücher. Einmal Abundance, How We Build a Better Future von New York Times Journalist Esra Klein und Derek Thompson. Die beschäftigen sich mit ja eigentlich dem, was man Infrastruktur nennt. Wie würde eigentlich eine gute Zukunft aussehen? Wie muss man sie bauen?
Vom Nutzer ausgedacht.
Genau. Welche Technikkritik verbietet sich und Vorschrittskritik verbietet sich vielleicht am Malen? Wo muss man tatsächlich mal wie ein Ingenieur über etwas nachdenken? Und zwar nicht so nach dem Motto, lasst mal die Unternehmer ran, die werden es schon machen, a la Elon Musk, sondern wie baut man eigentlich einen guten Staat, der funktioniert?
Worauf haben wir ein Anrecht?
Ja, und das ist das Buch, das in den USA schon heiß diskutiert wird. Wir werden es besprechen. Es wird auch in drei Monaten auf Deutsch erscheinen. Und wir lesen von Albert Wenger Die Welt nach dem Kapital. Strategien für das Zeitalter knappe Aufmerksamkeit. Wenger ist ein weltweit agierender Investor, der nochmal eine ganz andere Perspektive an den Tag legen wird als Alex Kabe. Über den haben wir schon gesprochen. Sein Staatsverständnis, wie wir eigentlich alle zu untertanen werden und dann so einem höheren Prinzip dienen und Kapitalismus und Staat Hand in Hand so eine super Intelligenz hervorbringen und Institutionen schaffen, bei denen es nur noch darum geht, ist das der Staatsinteresse. Albert Wenger legt da einen anderen Fokus und wird als Investor da eine Perspektive einnehmen, die möglicherweise für uns sehr hilfreich ist. Jedenfalls sind das Bücher, die sich sehr einmischen und dabei auch sehr konkret sind. Darüber werden wir reden. Und sag uns doch, wie man das am besten hören kann.
Man geht auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Sehr wahrscheinlich wird die im April auch aufgehübscht nach fünf Jahren. Da ist aber jetzt schon und dann auch ein goldener Button, der heißt Salon. Dann kommt man auf die Steady-Seite. Ab da ist eigentlich alles selbst erklänt. Man kann sich aus drei Paketen, in denen man überall das Label bekommt, aber in einem Paket kann man auch Freunde mitnehmen und so weiter, kann man den Salon buchen. Das ist die Primäre Einflugsschneise. Wir empfehlen das sehr, denn dort ist das ganze Archiv. Dort erscheint der Salon immer als allererstes, noch eine halbe Stunde vor dem anderen und so weiter und so fort. Dann gibt es aber auch für Leute, die schon einen Patreon-Account haben, die Möglichkeit einfach bei Patreon zu buchen. Oder bei Apple, wenn man sowieso seine Podcasts mit der Apple Podcasts App hört und unseren deswegen auch, da taucht ja der, ich will jetzt auch sehen, Salon-Hör-Button einfach direkt auf. Nur kostet bei Apple ein bisschen mehr, weil Apple ja auch ein bisschen mehr Geld verlangt. Wir sind ja da im Silo-Denken. 350 Milliarden Umsatz reicht Apple nicht. Sie wollen auch euren Euro. Den muss man bei Steady nicht bezahlen. Da gibt es das für 3 Euro statt 3,50 Euro.
Das eine oder das andere, das ist alles ganz einfach, selbsterklärend und man kann übrigens auch über Steady den Salon verschenken. Man kann für ein Jahr den Salon verschenken an andere. Also es muss nicht immer ein Netflix-Abo sein, dass man verschenkt oder sonst irgendwas, sondern man kann auch tatsächlich den Salon verschenken. Vielleicht dann gleich noch ein Buch dazu, was wir schon besprochen haben, denn natürlich gibt es dann auch Zugang zum gesamten Archiv. Ich will noch auf zwei Termine hinweisen. Ich bin am 3. Mai in Zürich zusammen mit Jean-Philippe Kindler und Ole Nymon.
In deiner geliebten Schweiz.
In meiner geliebten Schweiz freue ich mich sehr darauf. Und am 5.5. bin ich in Stuttgart mit den beiden. Also dort kann man uns dann zu dritt erleben. Und die anderen Termine stehen auf meiner Homepage. Es wird was im Mai in Trier geben, in Bremen und ich glaube auch noch Erlangen.
Ja, ich bin unter Studenten in Mainz. Am 6.
glaube ich.
Gut, alles steht auch auf meiner Webseite. So, wir haben ein Thema schon im Salon besprochen in großer Ausführlichkeit mit GPT-Hilfe. Aus Sicht von Yannis Varoufakis, aus Sicht des Trump Chief Economic Advisers, das ist also nicht nur ein Beirat, sondern wirklich eine Senatsgeduldete Stelle, die da eingerichtet ist und Zeiten, Texten aus der Zeit, in denen wir dieses Gesamtgefüge aus, wie genau versteht Trump jetzt dieses Gefüge aus dieser Dreifaltigkeit, Dollar als Reservewährung, freigeschossene Seewege durch militärische Hegemonie und eben Zölle, weil Zölle sind dann der Preisschild. Und es ist die Signature Politik von Trump. Er hat da über seit 1985, als er irgendwie bei Oprah Winfrey war, und da war es noch Japan und so weiter, hat er darüber gesprochen. Heute in diesem gigantischen Chaos ist völlig klar, es gibt moralische Verwerfung durch vierjährige krebskranke Kinder, die werden abgeschoben, wo sie Amerikaner sind, aber die Eltern halt nicht. Oder der Typ, der da in El Salvador im Gefängnis sitzt und so. Und diese moralischen Themen erreichen die Amerikaner auch auf inhaltlicher Ebene. Und dann ist man empört und dann macht man noch mal sein Signal in Social Media und so weiter und so fort. Aber da geht es nicht an das Eingemachte. Es kommen aber jetzt vermehrt Videos, in denen Leute einfach sagen, sorry, wir haben uns geirrt. Wir sind als Land nicht vorbereitet auf leere Regale im Supermarkt. Aber sie drohen. Amazon, erstaunlicher Move, hat gestern angekündigt gehabt, zwischenzeitlich. Wir schreiben an die Produkte bei Amazon und 70 Prozent der Sachen, die verkauft werden in Amerika, kommen aus China. Und wir schreiben da, wir machen so ein kleines Preisschild dran, wo drin steht, das kostet es. Und durch den Trump-Tarif kostet es das. Und dann ist es mehr als doppelt so viel. Und dann hat die Regierungssprecherin öffentlich gesagt, das ist ein hostile Act. Ein feindlicher Act gegen die Regierung. Man hat es also gar nicht mehr intern geklärt. Hört mal zu, nehmt mal die Idee zurück. Bisher in der Forense geht man davon aus, also in der journalistischen Betrachtung, dass Amazon das erstmal gemacht hat und Jeff Bezos dann kontaktiert wurde und er dann über seine Eigenschaft da ins Management rein intervenierte und es jetzt doch nicht dazu kommt. Aber wir sehen, die Fäden, an denen alles hängt, sind gerade ganz, ganz, ganz dünn und es sind ganz, ganz große Knalls, die einfach drohen. Und diese Politik betrachten wir jetzt aus Sicht derjenigen, die Trump zu Füßen liegen. Es gibt diesen All-In-Podcast mit David Sacks und so weiter, in dem, in dem Falle, in dem wir gleich reinhören, Ben Shapiro zu Gast ist. Also die versuchen uns das jetzt schön zu reden und wir werden einiges von Wolfram Weimer wiederfinden. Denn wenn die Realität über einen hineinbricht, hat man ja am besten noch so eine Ideologie, egal wie scheiße, der Hauptsache, die Grammatik stimmt. Irgendwas muss man ja dazu sagen. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, wir hören David McWilliams. Ich habe ihn schon einige Male empfohlen. Es ist mein Lieblingsökonomie-Podcaster, noch vor Adam Toos, weil ich ein bisschen mehr nachvollziehen kann, was er da redet. Und man merkt auch, das ist weniger Politikberatung als Bildungsprogramm. Ansonsten läuft auch sehr viel bei ihm über digitale Bildungsprogramme, wo man die Grundlagen lernt. Und David McVilliams steigt hier so in seinem Podcast ein am 8.4., als also gerade das Ganze auf und ab und die Börsenverwerfung und so weiter.
Wie geht es dir da?
Es ist der Podcast, der alles über Tarif, Betriebe, Trump und den Chaos, der in den Finanzmarkt geht, und den Chaos, der um die Welt geht, wie der Rest der Welt zu Trump reagiert.
Aber alles, was John sich um das Thema kümmert, ist, dass ich still bleibe, richtig?
Ich habe, wie jeder, der mich auf Telly oder so gesehen hat...
Nach Jahren der Theorie und ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen und das war früher mal so.
Jetzt kann man es mal zeigen.
Ist jetzt einfach Realität und das war dann im Verlauf des Podcasts klar. Es ist eben eine Textbuch- Theorie-Realität, die keiner mehr erlebt hat. Also es war immer die vorherregende Generation, die das noch erlebt hatte irgendwie und so. Und jetzt ist er ganz außer sich. Er ist wie auf Sugar. Und ehrlicherweise kann man ja auch so an die Sache rangehen. Das größte Problem, das wir jetzt in Europa haben, ist zu viel billiger Kram. Schlaraffenland. So, die Amerikaner haben jetzt Probleme, aber wir Europäer eigentlich nicht so sehr. Man kann also locker an die Sache rangehen und sich entsprechend lustig machen. Vor allem, wenn man im Fernsehen etwas sieht, von dem man sich denkt, nee, sorry, aber das ist einfach dumm. Also die journalistischen Aufklärungen laufen alle fehl, denn es ist einfach dumm. Und ja, muss man eher noch mal Halbsätze reinbauen, wie an diesem Punkt hat Trump alle recht oder irgend sowas, sondern das ist die Einschätzung der Ökonomie.
Wir müssen heute ein paar Dinge auf dem Podcast erklären. Einer ist, dass so viel Bullshit über die Niveau der Tarife und warum es eine Unterschiede gibt. Es gibt eine Formule, John, weißt du, wie ich eine Formule mag? Es gibt eine Formule, aber das Problem mit der Formule ist, wenn ein Kind diese Formule in der Trinity hätte, in der ich diese Woche leite, um Protektionismus zu erklären, dann hätte ich sie nicht geschafft, es ist so einfach.
Und es ist so schiefgezettelt.
Und trotzdem ist die größte Wirtschaft der Welt, die sich auf eine Formule, die keinen Sinn macht, auf ihre Tarif-, Betriebs- und internationale Politikpolitik basiert.
Aber diese Formule, sie kam von Chachi PT oder DeepSeek.
Sieht so aus.
Ich sage Chachi PT., denn DeepSeek ist chinesisch.
Sie würden den Chinesischen verwerfen.
Ich würde sagen, wenn ein normaler Level, ein gewisser Wirtschaftsstudent, das geschrieben hätte, würde er sie lachen. Erstens, wir schauen uns hier an, dass Amateur, also Amateur-Ekonomisten, von unabhängigen Unkompetenzen, die alle unter dem Regime eines Narzissisten sind, die andere Menschen Geld nutzen, um eine Handelspolitik zu machen.
Die Demokratie hat uns jetzt auf ihren Gipfel geführt. Wir haben Amateurökonomie von einem Narzisten-Politiker. Oder spielt Welt einfach keine Rolle. Das ist nur noch in sich gekehrte Logik. Ich würde selbst sagen, wenn man GPT gefragt hätte, mach mal daraus eine Formel, hätte GPT gesagt, nee.
Und der Unterschied ist jetzt auch hier, denn Inkompetenz gab es natürlich immer mal wieder in der Politik, dass diese Inkompetenz jetzt an den Schalthebeln der Macht sitzt und nicht mehr institutionell das abgefangen werden kann. Ich sage mal so, auch Wolfgang Schäuble, der Finanzminister, war nicht in der Lage zu erklären, wie das eigentlich funktioniert, wenn man sich Geld bei einer Bank leit. Dann erklärte er auch, ja, andere haben ja auf der Bank was gespart und das Geld wird dann genommen und das leitet dann die Bank dem anderen. Das war völliger Unsinn, machte aber nichts in dem Sinne. Also klar, es wäre schön, hätte er es gewusst, dann hätte er auch manchen Unsinn nicht reden können. Aber es störte nicht Abläufe, die Unwissenheit, weil ja in den zuständigen Institutionen die Kompetenz da war. Und ob der Minister irgendwas erzählt, was er nicht ganz verstanden hat, sei es drum, ja, hoffentlich fällt es nicht jedem auf. Und jetzt haben wir aber den Punkt, wo wir diese Inkompetenz nicht nur rhetorisch irgendwo in Talkshows erleben, sondern wir haben sie tatsächlich an den Schalthebeln und die sagen jetzt, jetzt mal da rauf, da runter. Die ziehen jetzt an diesen Hebeln, bedeutet aber, dass dann plötzlich diese inkompetente Haltung zu inkompetenter Politik wird, was bedeutet, dass eben auch die Podcast da eigentlich nur noch mit historischem Lachen weiterhelfen können.
Also es gibt eine ganz harte Unterscheidung zwischen Politik und Verwaltung.
Ja.
Und die inhaltliche Programmatik, die sich in Rechtstexten auswirkt, ist Verwaltungsauftrag. Und die wird irritiert durch politische Demokratien halt Mehrheitsverhältnisse. Es spielt sich halt jemand hoch und dann hier und da und so. Nur, wenn die Politik zu hart auf die Verwaltung durchgreift und einfach alles ausräumt, ist sie an ihre eigene Inkompetenz gefesselt. Und nicht nur inkompetent, sondern auch in einer ihr sachfremden Realität. Denn so ein Verwaltungstyp schreibt einen Rechtstext, der sich aufgrund von Erfahrungen, die man schon gemacht hat und Erwartungen, die man hat, eingliedert in ein laufendes Betriebssystem. Während die Politik kommentierend daneben steht und versucht, Wählerheit zu fangen, Mehrheiten zu mobilisieren. Aber eben die Komplexität ist da sehr reduziert, weil Oma Erna muss ja verstehen. Und jetzt hat die Oma Erna Schöpfungshöhe für einen klugen Gedanken, schlägt sich in Amerika gerade komplett auf die Verwaltung nieder. Also ist einfach Intelligenz ausgeräumt.
Ja, machen wir es mit einem anderen Bild deutlich. Nehmen wir mal das Frankfurter Museumsorchester, das wir immer hören, wenn wir in die Oper gehen. Das ist ausgesprochen kompetent und sehr gute Dirigenten arbeiten mit denen zusammen. Wenn jetzt ich kommen würde und sagen würde, ich würde jetzt mal gerne die Lohenkräne-Obertüre dirigieren, dann würde das folgendermaßen laufen, ich würde zwar wahrscheinlich einen Takt angeben können und den einen oder anderen Einsatz kriege ich auch hin, aber natürlich kann ich das Orchester nicht dirigieren. Aber die würden das so spielen, dass man das nicht merkt. Dann würdest du sagen, die haben großartig gespielt, hast voll dirigiert. Das Problem würde jetzt bestehen, wenn ich sage, ja, ich würde gerne die Lohenkräne-Obertüre dirigieren, aber ich tausche jetzt mal hier die Streicher aus und die aus und Stefan übernimmt die Tuba und jeder macht jetzt noch was anders. Und dann würde man sagen, jetzt haben wir lauter Leute, die keine Instrumente spielen können und Wolfgang dirigiert noch, dann kommt halt nichts mehr bei raus. Und so funktioniert das häufig bei der Politik. Die haben ein gutes Orchester und dann hat man mal einen besseren, schlechteren Dirigenten, aber an sich läuft das. Und das ist jetzt nicht mehr vorhanden. Die Musiker sind ausgetauscht.
Also soziologisch streng würde man eigentlich sagen, die Politik gibt es überhaupt nur, um die Verwaltung abzuschotten von ihrem Publikum, weil wir haben eine Volksherrschaft. So, also das musste die Legitimationsvater Morgana, das Volk entscheidet. Ja, ja, ja, das Volk entscheidet so. Dabei entscheidet nicht mal der Minister, sondern die Verwaltung legt ihm einfach klug drei ausgewogene Beschlussvorlagen hin. Damit greift die Unterwachung. Aus Eile muss er einen der drei wählen. Wenn er noch einen super eigenen Wunsch hat, okay, kann die Verwaltung noch mal kurz was aufschnüren und so, dann heißt es aber, ja, wir haben das schon gegengezeichnet mit dem anderen Ministerium und so. Das müsste man dann noch mal, es dauert dann wieder länger und dann sagt er, nee, ich hab's den Wählern versprochen. Na ja, dann machen wir es jetzt. So, im Grunde spielt die Verwaltung die Politik immer aus. Und jetzt funktioniert das einfach nicht mehr. Also dieser zivilisatorische Fortschritt, eine Verwaltung zu haben, 10.000 Leute, die in Hierarchien, und die wachsen eben auch von unten in die Hierarchie rein und werden nicht von oben plötzlich erbeutet und so. Alle solche Prinzipien greifen jetzt einfach nicht mehr. Also es ist ein echter zivilisatorischer Rückschritt, der da stattfindet und der als Counterpart in China auf quasi nur Verwaltung trifft. Da gibt man sich ja schon gar nicht mehr mit Legitimationsfantasmen hin, sondern sagt einfach, so ist es jetzt. Uns gehört das Land und gehört die Armee, du gehörst uns irgendwie auch. Und das ist ein echtes Problem.
Und da ist rohe Expertise. Also ich glaube, diese Fokussierung, die wir die ganze Zeit haben auf Präsident Xi ist zum einen nachvollziehbar, weil er nun der autoritäre, alleine Geherrscher ist. Zugleich aber ist Xi nichts, wenn er nicht die Verwaltung hinter sich hat, beziehungsweise die Partei. Und Partei und Verwaltung geht da natürlich viel mehr Hand in Hand. Das fällt in eins. Das ist ein bisschen anders hier, wo wir politische Beamte haben und unpolitisch und all das. Aber was wir in China sehen können, ist natürlich eine extreme Kompetenz, die auch aus diesen radikalen Versorgungskrisen erwachsen ist, während die jetzt in Amerika natürlich solche Knappheiten überhaupt nicht kennen.
Die Chinesen haben halt diesen Vorteil, dass sie über dieses Einparteien-System andere Streitabsorptions- und Konfliktsensibilitäten haben, weil sie die haben müssen. Beginnt natürlich bei 50.000 Leute kontrollieren, was im Internet steht, damit überhaupt nicht erst Streit entsteht oder Konflikte aufkommen. Und dass man halt Strömungen aus den Regionen, wo man die Parteizentralen entsanden hinschickte, schon wahrnimmt, bevor das als flächendeckendes Phänomen im Publikum auftaucht. Das spart sich ja in der Demokratie alles, indem es einfach heißt, wir machen so einen Wahltag und wer am meisten Unterstützer hat, gewinnt halt. Und die Verwaltung kümmert sich gar nicht groß drum, weil was soll schon passieren? Ging ja bisher immer gut, so ungefähr. Und jetzt haben wir dieses Problem, dass die komplette Kompetenz einer Verwaltung gegen den Nimbus eines Politikers ausgetauscht wird. Und hier greift halt dieses Zölle-Ding. Trump hat ja schon vor 40 Jahren das gesagt, was er heute sagt. Er hatte eine gewisse Issue-Ownership zum Thema Zölle. Kann ja nicht alles falsch sein. Das hätte man ihm ja schon mal ausgeredet oder so. Und das fällt ihm so langsam auf die Füße. Also wir kennen ja die aktuellen Zahlen. Noch nie stand ein amerikanischer Präsident in den Umfragen da wie jetzt. So schlecht. Genau, also nur Trump 1. Er hat Trump zweimal da auf Augenhöhe in irgendeinem. Aber alle anderen Umfragen sind einfach schlechter. Also hier geht jetzt diese Lösung nicht mehr auf, dass in der Masse so eine Weisheit liegt, die sich dann demokratisch niederschlägt und Verwaltungseffekte hervorruft, weil es auch zu rapide geht. Also wir haben vier Jahre und nach vier Monaten liegt schon alles in Trümmern. Wie soll der Mechanismus, der jetzt für Korrekturen sorgt, der kommt ja weder aus der Verwaltung noch aus der Demokratie, weil die müssen jetzt dreieinhalb Jahre so durchhalten. Also es ist wirklich schlecht und es steht halt grandios schlecht. Und es war Anfang April schon absehbar, dass jetzt Trump in seiner zentralen Eignung, die ihm zugesprochen wurde, nicht mehr taugt.
So stabil ist es, weil die Leute alles mit Trump bezahlt haben. Du weißt, oh, ich fand, dass es eine neue Frau gibt, die ihm etwas beantwortet hat. Es ist nicht so, dass das ihre Perzeption von Donald Trump ändert. Aber der eine Sache, die er immer hat, an seinem Vorteil, ist, dass er noch gesehen wird, ist historisch gesehen worden, von der Mehrheit der Amerikaner als ein erfolgreicher Geschäftsführer Und jemanden, der vertraut werden kann, um die Wirtschaft zu handeln. Das verändert sich. Das verändert sich in einem kleinen Weg, aber es ist sinnvoll. Und ich denke, das ist der größte Risiko, den er sich vorstellt.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen dieser Real Deal Knackpunkt, auf den es echt ankommt. Und dieser Nimbus vom Businessman hatte ja immer so einen obskuren Teil, wie auch diese Verwaltung halt. Ja, also man weiß halt nicht wirklich. Man sieht einfach nur, ja, hat die hohe Häuser gebaut oder sowas. Und man muss halt Trump bei dieser Zollpolitik ernster nehmen als dieses, ja da haben jetzt ein paar Leute weiche Füße gekriegt, deswegen wurde das auf 90 Tage aufgeschoben. Nein, dadurch zehn Billionen Börsenwert wieder auszugleichen, ist es dann halt in 90 Tagen. Also der Börsen Crash ist sozusagen wieder vorprogrammiert, wenn auch die Zölle für die restliche Welt wieder greifen. Wenn nicht bis dahin schon die Thematik mit China alleine Amerika so das Genick bricht, dass sowohl die wirtschaftlichen Lieferketten vor Ort, als auch die Consumergewohnheit, ich gehe einfach einkaufen und verschulde mich. Also ich lege eine Kreditekarte vor, ich sehe das Geld nicht und kriege einfach Waren, wenn das dann nicht mehr aufgeht.
Ich meine, du hattest mir ein Video geschickt via Instagram vor ein paar Tagen, es gibt jetzt sehr viel, was viral geht bei TikTok beispielsweise, aber auch Instagram, aus China Leute, die aus Fabriken berichten, jetzt weiß man nicht, inwieweit das gestaget ist oder nicht, dass die Produkte, die da hergestellt werden, diese Luxusprodukte, nun eigentlich dafür fünf Euro gefertigt werden können. Und dann werden sie halt mit diesem Label versehen, der Luxusmarke, und dann verkaufen sie es für den hundertfachen Preis. Und dass das jetzt etwas ist, was jetzt öffentlich wird, also das heißt, die Amerikaner werden durch Social-Media-Kampagnen, ob die jetzt von der KP direkt ausgehend sind oder ob das einfach auch Firmen sind, die sagen so, jetzt stellen wir uns da mal so richtig dagegen. Ist ja mal egal, jedenfalls bekommen die amerikanischen Konsumer gesagt, ihr seid eh immer verarscht worden. Wir produzieren hier billig irgendwas und verkaufen dieselbe Ware ohne das Label hier auch für einen Bruchteil dessen, was ihr bezahlt. Aber weil ihr glaubt, diese Marken haben diesen Nimbus, zahlt ihr sehr viel mehr. Und das ist natürlich etwas, wo man sagen kann, naja gut, wer hat denn das nicht geahnt? Klar, aber wenn du das plötzlich jetzt mal siehst und sagst, ja das ist die Handtasche von dem Luxus, Label und das ist dieselbe Handtasche, die gibt es ja auch zu kaufen, die hat nur dieses Label, nicht? Dann zeigt man natürlich damit den amerikanischen Konsumenten, seht her, ihr wurdet immer verarscht, und jetzt werdet ihr noch mehr verarscht. Jetzt sollt ihr auch noch Zölle dafür zahlen.
Also diese Videos sind wahnsinnig interessant, weil damals, als ich dir das schickte, und es waren ja so mehrere, es gab so eine ganze Welle, sah es ja so als, als ob die das Angebot gerade machen, kauf es doch bei uns, halt ohne das Label, aber ansonsten, die Qualität haut genauer hin. Offenbar war der Move als schon das Medien-Stunt angelegt, denn ich habe jetzt nicht große Geschichten gehört, dass jemand diese Taschen wirklich kaufen konnte. Aber in dem Fall reicht ja die Aufklärung darüber. Also während man gleichzeitig nicht versteht, wie die Wirtschaft funktioniert, bekommt man aus China die Nachricht, ihr habt doch Gesetze geschaffen in eurem komischen Kulturkreis, den wir immer mehr verlachen, in dem es heißt, wir stellen das Zeug her, dann schicken wir es nach Rom, dann wird noch ein kleiner handwerklicher Akt gemacht, nämlich das Logo draufgeschrieben, und dann springt der Preis von 1000 Euro Herstellung auf 40.000 Euro plus, du musst erst mal eingeladen werden und so der ganze Kram, die immer da so hört.
Warteliste für die Handtasche.
Genau, so. Und das ist ja diese Botschaft an die Amerikaner vor allem. Es ist nicht nur so, dass wir das für euch herstellen, und jetzt euer Präsident sagt, ich wähle einen Zoll von 125 Prozent, also doppelt so teuer, sondern ihr könntet es auch für 10 Prozent des Preises haben. Und zwar ohne die Zölle. Also so wie er das gerade nach oben verdummt, könnten wir auch mit einer ehrlichen Einsicht das nach unten, weil handwerklich ist es ja gut. Es war ja auch immer dieses Missverständnis, dass angeblich in China die Arbeit so billig ist. Nein, das hat ja Tim Cook immer beschrieben, aufgrund des sehr guten Engineering geht man nach China, weil dort einfach diese Foxconn Fabriken aufgebaut werden, wo es heißt, hier sind dann auch zehntausend tüchtige und vor allem sich auskennende, know-how habende Ingenieure, denn das iPhone muss ja wirklich zusammengebaut werden, luftdicht, der Prozessor braucht seinen Strom, der Akku und so weiter. Das ist ja auch eine Ingenieursleistung, nicht nur dieses Design bei Apple in Kalifornien und so. Und ich glaube, China fährt diese sehr gute Strategie, die auch für uns gut ist, grundsätzlich mal für Aufklärung zu schaffen. Das, was bei Abandons sehr nahe kommt und Klammer auf Bullshit-Jobs und so. Wir müssen nicht 50 Prozent unserer Werbpotenzial mit Anträge schreiben, Werbung, Marketing und dem ganzen Kram. Wir können auch einfach sagen, da ist die Anlaufstelle, das ist ein One-Stop-Shop, du willst einen Kochtopf, hier gibt es welche. Sie müssen nicht 100.000 Euro kosten, nur weil nochmal die Idee war, jeder braucht einen Kochtopf, ich mache da eine Notwendigkeit draus. Sondern nein, man kann es einfach runterdimmen auf und damit sehr viel befreien und überhaupt. Nur, dass also diese Art von Aufklärung, die ja auch, ich erinnere an Richard-David Sprechts Buch, zu einem Schulterschluss mit den Chinesen führen kann, geht halt nicht, wenn Trump einfach so drauf ist. Das ist eigentlich interessant, weil man jetzt so da sitzt und sehr viele Leute einfach nur sagen, ich will nur genug zu essen haben. Ich will einfach nur vorwärts kommen im Straßenverkehr. Ich will einfach nur, dass meine Kinder was Gutes lernen. Und dann ist aber die Elite, die sich festgezurrt hat auf so ein, nee ich will aber, dass alles grün ist. Und man denkt so, ja dann halt grün. Ja aber grün ist grad nicht verfügbar. Ja können wir dann nicht einfach rot nehmen. Nee es muss grün sein. Und die verkämpfen sich in so sinnlosen, also jeder hat jetzt weit Lotus gesehen irgendwie. Sie haben das größte Zimmer des Hotels. Ich will aber das schönste. Ja aber sie haben das größte. Ich will das schönste. Aber sie haben keinen Mehrblick. Aber ich will das größte. Aber man kriegt ihn einfach nicht so. Es ist einfach, ja es ist diese Absurdität. Das ganze Land denkt sich einfach, wow die einzige Frage, die uns gar nicht interessiert, auf die versteifst du dich jetzt einfach. Und zwar nur aus diesen persönlichen, ich hab das schon immer so gemacht, ich hab das schon immer so gesagt, das ist meine Identität, ich kann hier nicht abrücken. Also es ist so eine Hardcore Persönlichkeitsideologie, Identitätspolitik, bei der wirklich jeder daneben steht und sich fragt, sind es wirklich die Chinesen, die den Gesichtsverlust fürchten oder ist es einfach Trump?
Die Globalisierung funktionierte ja immer auch deshalb so gut, weil die Konsumenten nicht nachgefragt haben, woher etwas kommt. Dann gab es eher linke Bestrebungen, Lieferkettengesetze einzuführen, dann wollte man es aber dann doch nicht so genau wissen. Jetzt durch die Zölle ist man natürlich die ganze Zeit in diesen Fragen, wo kommt da eigentlich was her? Und plötzlich sind also diese geopolitischen Verwerfungen in jedem Einkaufswagen jederzeit spürbar. Das heißt, das ist eine permanente Politisierung des Alltags, die der normale Konsument natürlich überhaupt gar nicht leiten kann. Und deswegen wäre es eigentlich ein genialer Schachzug, wenn alle Online-Shops jetzt anfingen, wie das bei Amazon jetzt mal kurz vorgeschlagen war, das zu markieren. Das würde das kosten, eigentlich wäre es so teuer. Dann nämlich würde das sehr schnell zu einem großen Unmut der Konsumenten führen und würde sicherlich Trump noch stärker unter Druck sitzen, als es jetzt ohnehin der Fall war. Denn warum er jetzt zurückgerudert ist, warum er dann sagt, wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein 90-Tage-Gesmuratorium, aber dann ja doch wieder sehr viele Ausnahmen auch schuf, um schon sehr viel Zölle durchzusetzen, ist ja nicht aufgrund der Unmut der Konsumenten oder auch nicht aufgrund der Unternehmen, die jetzt zersauer sind, geschehen, sondern weil die Märkte selbst darauf reagiert haben. Das heißt also, die sicherste Staatsanleihe der Welt, der Hafen für das Kapital überhaupt, der Dollar nämlich, die amerikanische Staatsanleihe, sank plötzlich in ihrer Beliebtheit. Die Zinsen für diese Staatsanleihe stiegen. Das bedeutet also, wenn die Zinsen steigen, wird das Risiko als höher angesehen. Das ist also für Investoren eine schlechte Situation.
Ja, oder wir sehen erstmal die Nachfrage geringer.
Die Nachfrage war geringer und das hat natürlich dann die Zentralbank auf den Plan gerufen, denn man wusste ja schon, es ist schon einmal passiert, in Großbritannien mit List Trust, dass sie da abgestraft wurde von den Märkten. Das bedeutet, wir haben zwar jetzt eben sehr klar gemacht, dieser Austausch des institutionellen Personals, der Verwaltung, sorgt dafür, dass jetzt Chaos-Politik auch tatsächlich als Chaos umgesetzt wird, aber es gibt natürlich noch eine andere Balance- und Checks-Funktion, nämlich die durch den Markt selbst. Und der kann sozusagen jetzt auch den sich souverän fühlenden Donald Trump etwas einhegen, weil das natürlich jetzt wirklich katastrophal wäre für einen amerikanischen Präsidenten, wenn die amerikanische Staatsanleihe auf absehbare Zeit nicht mehr so beliebt ist. Das heißt, da gibt es also so einen Punkt, wo plötzlich etwas, was überhaupt nichts mit irgendwas Gewähltem, demokratisch oder sonst was zu tun hat, sondern das ist tatsächlich, wie die Kapitalmärkte funktionieren, dafür sorgen können, dass eine gewisse Einhegung der eigentlich demokratischen Macht stattfindet. Was ja auch immer wieder kritisiert wurde. Also aus einer linken Perspektive hätte man ja jetzt auch gesagt, da sieht man es wieder mal, die Kapitalmärkte verringern den Spielraum. Und das ist ja auch das Problem zum Beispiel vieler Entwicklungsländer. Auch wenn da progressive Regierungen dann sind, dann bekommen die sehr schnell von den Kapitalmärkten, von den daran angedockten Institutionen, IWF etc., einen auf den Deckel. Jetzt sieht ja Trump auch, wie muss ich mich eigentlich zur Weltbank und zum IWF verhalten. Und jetzt versucht man ja da auch in irgendeiner Weise, das so zu deichseln, dass das jetzt eine Institution wird, die dieses neue amerikanische Interesse, denn vorher hat man ja auch schon amerikanischen Interessen gedient, wie man dieses neue Interesse jetzt auch in diese Institutionen entablieren kann. Denn ohne die kann er natürlich gar nicht so schalten und falten, wie er das möchte.
Also auf der einen Seite ja, wir können das so hoch dramatisieren, dass wir sagen, seht ihr in diesem Gesamtgefüge, die Chinesen sind nicht nur der Meinung, sie brauchen das amerikanische Militär nicht mehr, sie könnten sich selber den Suas-Kanal freischießen. Und seht ihr, der Dollar ist gar nicht so wichtig, wenn jetzt, wie Mayon das beschrieb, China mit Brasilien Geschäfte macht. Man könnte auch eine andere Währung nehmen. Also der Bedarf, sich erstmal mit Dollar zu versorgen, damit man ein Geschäft machen kann, ist gar nicht so hoch. Ich will nur darauf hinweisen, also wir kommen nochmal auf die Zinslast da zurück, die Zinsfrage. Gerade im deutschen Diskurs fand ich es auch sehr wohltuend, mal so Marius Höfken mit seinem Geld für die Welt oder Marco Herack bei den Mikroökonom zu hören, die einfach sagen, ja es gibt halt so einen Lauf der Dinge in dem Moment, wo Verwerfungen sind und man sagt, ich brauche schnell Cash, ist der kürzeste Weg zum Cash, eine Staatsanleihe zu verkaufen, weil einfach klar ist, der Händler ist klar, der Preis ist klar, ich muss nur hingehen und sie verkaufen, dann kriege ich Dollar. So und es gab wohl auch Bestrebungen von einigen, die sich so verunsichert haben, gefühlt haben, dass sie einfach Geld brauchten. Also sie mussten jetzt Infektionserscheidung, wie auch immer, mit welchem Ad-hoc-Entscheidung man auch so trifft. Und dann sollte man diese Zins-Spikes erstmal nicht zu ernst nehmen, im Sinne von, damit ist jetzt alles in Gefahr, aber wir hören gleich noch so ein bisschen, es bedeutet ja was. Es ist ja nicht ohne Grund, dass wir diese Doppelspur aus echtem politischem Leitzins, den die festlegt und dann eben auch so ein Zins, der sich ergibt durch echte konkrete Käufer-Nachfrage, also der sich am Markt echt bildet, weil an dem hängt ja auch noch einiges dran. Also der ist ja preisgebend auch nicht nur für die Staatsanleihe selbst, sondern eben auch noch für so ein paar Sachen, auf die Trump einfach achten muss. Ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, nur weil wir eben diesen Wolfram Weimer Kontext hatten. In diesem Punkt hier sieht man, dass es Veränderungen gibt in der Realität, sei es die kulturelle Realität, Wirtschaft, die unabhängig von persönlichen Intentionen, also hier spielt kein Individuum mehr eine Rolle, sondern wenn sich die Zinsen so und so entwickeln, ist das einfach eine Realität wie ein Komet, der auf die Erde kommt. Da muss man keinen Alien suchen, dass den Komet abgeschossen hat oder sonst irgendein Bewusstsein, das noch angeschlossen ist, sondern die Selbstreferentialität von so einer globalen Wirtschaft ist einfach ein Ding für sich. Unabhängig davon, wer jetzt welche Kommentare und so dazu schreibt. Also an solchen Sachen sieht man es dann mal ganz deutlich, dass dann nicht nur Trump nicht drum rumkommt, sondern auch die anderen nicht so richtig diesen Einschlag finden. Ah ja, so ist er doch verwundbar. Ja, er ist verwundbar von der Weltwirtschaft, aber hängt noch lange nicht von dir ab. Also das sind alles so neue Erfahrungen, die man jetzt hier macht. Sehr witzig fand ich auch, es gibt in England den Remaniacs-Podcast, der heute Oh Gott, What Now heißt. Also man kam aus einem Krise nicht in die nächste Reihen. Und bei der Frage, wie nennen wir unseren Podcast, war es quasi nur noch, oh Gott, was ist jetzt schon wieder los so. Und die, das beginnt alles mit Brexit, deswegen sind die da alarmiert, deswegen machen die Podcasts und so weiter. Für die ist auch so ein bisschen erlösend, weil die jetzt plötzlich sehen, Brexit war nicht die allerdümmste Entscheidung, die jemals getroffen wurde.
Lass uns sehen, was die heutigen Panel denken, von den aktuellsten Spielen und Spielen in Amerika.
Zuerst, Autor und Kreator von Jam Tomorrow, Ros Taylor. Hi, Ros.
Ah, hallo Dorian.
Also wir wissen, dass Tariffs passieren, auch wenn wir die Details nicht wissen.
Für mögliche Bedeutung.
Aber es ist das große, was er denkt, es wird in Amerika umgekehrt.
Kannst du einen nennen?
Brexit, Nuklearverliferation, Sowjet, 5-Jährige Planungen, die Liste geht weiter.
Also das finde ich eine tolle Liste. Ja. 5-Jahrespläne der Sowjets, Brexit, Trumps Zollentscheidung, Das ist Liberation Day. Auf der Ebene muss man es jetzt sehen, das ist historisch für die schon ganz gut eingeordnet. Trump selber im Oto zu hören zu diesem ganzen Zeug ist wirklich...
Das ist was er gesagt hat, ich glaube es war gestern, es war vielleicht am Sonntag.
Das hier ist David Axelrod bei Hex on Tap.
Wir haben ein enormes Deficitprobleme mit China. Sie haben einen Verlust von mindestens 1 Trillion Dollar pro Jahr. Ich denke es ist etwa 1 Trillion und ich will das lösen. Und keine anderen Präsidenten haben es aufgenommen. Ich hatte es die letzte Zeit aufgenommen, und dann hatten wir eine gewünschte Wahl. Keine anderen Präsidenten haben es aufgenommen. Und China ist... Sie sagen, das Markt ist gespürt. China ist jetzt eine große Hände aufgenommen, weil jeder weiß, dass wir richtig sind.
Sie haben die Zölle zu zahlen, nein, die Zölle zahlen ja die Amerikaner.
Genau, es ist schon ein Eingangszoll. Also die Chinesen schicken halt los, aber wenn die Nachfrage nicht kommt, weil dort die Preispolitik bescheuert ist, ist halt wie es ist. Ich finde es auch witzig, dass man hier in diesem David McVilliams-artigen, ja wir verstehen halt wirklich, wie es gemeint ist. Trade-Defizits, Handelsbilanz-Defizite, wir haben es ja in Deutschland immer kritisiert, dass wir so viel rum exportieren, aufgrund billiger Lohnkosten, die wir so gemacht haben, durch die Schaffung des größten Niedriglohnsektors der Welt. Und wenn wir jetzt also diese Idee von, ich schaue mir die Länder einzeln an statt den Gesamtmarkt und ich versuche jedes kleine Handelsdefizit auszugleichen, das ist wirklich so schräg. Also so wie man Cum-Ex mit, man gibt die Flasche zweimal zurück beschreibt, ist das wirklich genau das gleiche. Wir gehen in den Supermarkt und beschweren uns erst mal, dass sie nie bei uns kaufen. Und dann fragen die was, also sie haben doch nichts im Angebot. Stimmt. Nur Amerika hat ja was im Angebot. Also die sind ja im großen Zirkel in der Zirkularität.
Sie haben zwei Dinge im Angebot. Sie haben einmal die digitalen Dienstleistungen.
Genau, diese digitalen Dienste. Die ganze Welt wird damit beliebt.
Und sie haben den Dollar im Angebot. Also das ist ja das Dollar-Privileg, wird ja nicht von Trump als solches erkannt. Microsoft ist ja ein Bemerkenswert.
Vier Billionen, alle sind Billionen Dollar wert. Und es sieht er einfach gar nicht.
Man hätte ja zum Beispiel, wenn man einfach sagt, mir geht es ums Business, sagen können, ich muss sehen, dass ich meine amerikanischen Dienstleistungen, zum Beispiel Apple, Microsoft und und und, auch dahin verkaufe, wo sie bislang sehr restriktiv behandelt werden. Und das wäre China als Markt, China in so und so weiter. Ja, das würde aber dann bedeuten, dass man ja auf die zugeht und sagt, pass auf, ihr müsst das auch zulassen. Und wenn die Chinesen jetzt auch WhatsApp machen wollen, dann sollen die WhatsApp machen dürfen.
Und das wäre ein echter Power-Move gewesen.
Und dann würde man wahrscheinlich noch mit denen aushalten, dass die aber ein bisschen mehr zensieren dürfen, dass das bei WhatsApp nicht so zugeht wie hier. Aber das wäre ja so ein Move gewesen, bei dem man sagen würde, ja, das ist zwar nicht irgendwie werteorientiert, aber es ist business-orientiert. Hier bedeutet das ja nur, dass man weniger Geschäfte macht und den eigenen Konsumenten hohe Preise aufzwingt und man auch keine Alternative anzubieten hat. Denn dein Beispiel ist ja genau richtig mit dem Supermarkt. Man geht da rein und sagt, warum kaufen sie eigentlich nicht bei mir? Ja, was soll denn jetzt in Amerika produziert werden? Sollen zum Beispiel Textilien, sollen die jetzt in den USA wieder groß produziert werden? Wäre das sinnvoll?
Das ist das, was die Amerikaner wollen.
Werden wir dahin kommen, dass die Oberklasse in den USA keine deutschen Autos mehr will? Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Also Tesla ist gerade absteigend. Chinesische Autos sind eigentlich bei Amerikanern auch schon beliebt, beziehungsweise interessiert man sich dafür. Also es ist sehr interessant, dass man das gar nicht erkennt. Und ich finde aber auch verblüffend, ich hatte beispielsweise diesen Podcast gehört von Gideon Rachman. Dort war Jörg Wuttke zu Gast, der ja für das China-Geschäft von BASF zuständig ist, aber auch die EU berät. Da fand ich es verblüffend, dass er doch eher China als Systemrival in die ganze Zeit kennzeichnete und immer wieder deutlich machte, dass man ja jetzt nicht das transatlantische Verhältnis aufkündigen dürfe. Und ich dachte mir, ja aber merkt ihr denn jetzt nicht gerade etwas, dass das eigentlich eine gute Möglichkeit wäre, durchaus wieder mit China in einer anderen Art zusammenzuarbeiten. Und wir sehen das ja auch bei Ursula von der Leyen, da ist das ja auch eine Anti-China-Haltung nach wie vor.
Ja, also bei Behrs, da kann ich mir das total erklären. Die haben vor zehn Jahren Mosanto gekauft. Dann ging ihr ganzer Unternehmenswert um 80 Prozent zurück. Sie haben in Amerika diese riesigen Probleme juristisch und sind natürlich alle Mosanto-Fabrikhallen und so weiter auch noch in Amerika. Also, wenn die zehn Jahre nachdem sie Mosanto verkauft hatten und seitdem haben sie faktisch kein Gewinn mehr gemacht, gekauft haben und jetzt noch einen Spalt da rein, dass das ganze Unternehmen zerschlägt in den europäischen und amerikanischen Teil, der gar nicht mehr miteinander in Güter im Produktionsprozess austauschen kann, also dass der festhält an dem transatlantischen, verstehe ich auch, BWL sich total, weil dann wäre BASF Geschichte.
Ich verstehe nur nicht die Revalität. Aber die Revalität zu China ergibt ja keinen Sinn, weil BASF das China-Geschäft verstärkt hat. Es ist ja nicht so, als würde sich BASF da zurückziehen. Ich finde es merkwürdig, dass man so sehr immer noch mit diesen ideologischen Scheuklappen da unterwegs ist, von Seiten der EU. Also man müsste da ja eigentlich viel proaktiver sagen, wir versuchen jetzt da wegzukommen von der Zollpolitik. Die hat man ja tatsächlich mehr von der EU angefangen als aus PK.
Ich sehe das nicht ganz so kritisch, weil die EU im Sinne von unserem Verwaltungs, was wir eben sprachen, eine Hyperverwaltung ist. Nicht mal die Verwaltung selbst durchschaut, was die Verwaltung da macht. Jetzt haben wir ja im Kontrast dazu dieses Wolfram Weimer Buch besprochen, das ja nur Semantik ist. Also da ist ja Approximationshoffnung, dass es irgendein empirisches Korrelar für irgendeine Aussage gibt.
Die Nürnberger Rostbratwürstchen bei McDonald's.
Genau, das ist dann so Aufhänger für irgendein Argument. Also totaler Schrott. In deren Sicht, die EU macht jetzt Sachen, die die EU so macht. Und sie redet aber, wie die EU so redet. Und da sind große Differenzen dazwischen. Und ich halte es ja immer noch für sehr wichtig, dass die Europäer ganz viel Wert darauf legen, immer den Fokus drauf zu haben, wir kündigen hier gar nichts auf. Die Amerikaner kündigen auf. Und nur weil Wolfgang M. Schmitt sagt, ich würde mir gerne mal ein europäisches Signal wünschen, dass wir das auch und so weiter. Ich bin auch total dafür, dass die Franzosen, dass die Deutschen, dass die EU immer sagt, die Amerikaner sind unsere besten Freunde, wir würden gerne mit denen verhandeln, an uns liegt es nicht und so weiter und so fort. Also für mich ist das ein Zeichen, dass sie es geblickt haben, dass sie das Problem verstehen. Und gleichzeitig, und wir hören gleich die Chinesen, sagen, an uns liegt es nicht. Wenn überhaupt, werden wir jetzt einer bitteren Realität entgegentreten und sagen, okay, dann mach mal Kontakt zu China. Aber wir liefern uns jetzt auch nicht China aus, sondern...
Glaubst du, dass es dann doch am Ende die Konzerne machen und die Politik rennt hinterher? Denn was wir jetzt gerade erleben, ist ja, dass es die Automesse in Shanghai gibt.
Megading.
Und dort sind ja die deutschen Autokonzerne und haben Großkooperationen angekündigt oder haben sie schon mit Huawei. Und Huawei ist ja der Konzern, der ist hier der umstrittene Konzern. Alle sagen, oh wei, oh wei. Wenn man da Politiker befragt, von Grünen über SPD bis CDU, werden alle sagen, ja problematisch. Und jetzt erfahren wir gerade, dass die Autoindustrie da neue Kooperation schließt. Das bedeutet also, dass man jetzt eigentlich, was die deutsche Wirtschaft anbelangt, sagt, die Konzerne sollen jetzt mal gucken, was für sie sinnvoll ist. Und wir stellen uns dem dann nicht in den Weg. Also offenbar wäre das so ein, ich weiß es nicht. Jetzt haben wir bald einen neuen Außenminister, Wadepuhl, der kann natürlich auch, der liest sich gerade ein und der wird auch gerade eingelesen. Da werden wir sehen, ob der jetzt auch solche Baerbock-Auftritte hinlegt, bei denen er dann Wert darauf legt, die Chinesen nochmal zu beschimpfen.
Nein, nein, nein. Oder ob man da ein bisschen sinnvoller ist. Also ich bin hier einfach dagegen, das zu platt zu machen. Annalina Baerbock fing an mit diesem De-Risking. Ja. So. Gleichzeitig gab es zu dieser Zeit, als die Ampel regierte, noch nie so enge Verquickungen zu China. Und das Investitionsvolumen war noch nie so groß. Ja, also Semantik und Struktur fallen einfach auseinander. Und ich habe eben schon gesagt, ich kann mir die europäische Semantik erklären. Ich möchte nicht, dass ein Bundeskanzler sagt, ich habe jetzt mal an die Bücher geschaut, es wäre ganz pragmatisch, wenn wir uns jetzt China ausliefern. Sondern nein, das wird natürlich im semantischen Wettbewerb.
Es geht ja nicht darum, zu sagen, sich China auszuliefern. Aber wenn wir jetzt an die Ära Merkel denken, auch mit Wirtschaftsminister Altmaier, dann ging es ja nicht darum, zu sagen, guten Tag liebe Chinesen, nehmt was immer ihr haben wollt. Es war ja ein Businessplan dahinter. Und der hat dann auch Erfolge davon getragen. Und die zeigen sich ja dann in den Volumina, die du da jetzt gerade angesprochen hast. Das ist ja nicht Ergebnis der Ampel-Regierung, sondern das ist ja eigentlich Ergebnis der Merkel-Regierung gewesen. So schnell geht das ja nicht, dass das alles kommt. Das bedeutet aber, dass jetzt die Politik, die Deutschland unter der Ampel gefahren hat, kann dafür sorgen, und hat ja auch zum Teil dazu gesorgt, und Rosa von der Leyen hat das ja auch assistiert, dass plötzlich weniger Kooperationen zwischen der chinesischen und der deutschen Wirtschaft stattfindet. Und deswegen glaube ich, muss man schon erkennen, die Zölle sorgen ja ganz klar dafür. Auf E-Mobilität, auf Photovoltaik, all diese Dinge sorgen ja dafür, auch wenn man überall sagt, das ist der systemische Rivale und Xi ist ein Diktator, dann sorgt das ja dafür, dass die Chinesen auch weniger Lust haben, mit uns zu kooperieren. Und da sieht man ja schon auch dann mitunter in sehr ehrlichen Interviews, zum Beispiel im Handelsband, dass sich Wirtschaftsgrößen darüber aufgeregt haben, dass da einfach jemand, um die heimische Presse ja glücklich zu waren, also Beowock hat ja, sie kann das ja sagen, das bewirkt ja in China höchstens, dass die eine schlechtere Wirtschaftspolitik mit uns machen werden. Aber das sorgt ja nicht dafür, dass jetzt Xi abgesetzt wird oder kritische Journalisten freigelassen werden oder sonst irgendwas. Das ist ja eine reine Aktion, um Melanie Ammann und andere froh zu machen von der deutschen Presse. Und da würde ich sagen, dass das keine gute Strategie war. Es geht ja nicht darum, ausverkaufsam. Ich bin ja jemand, der auch sagt, ich halte das für hoch problematisch, dass wir immer mehr auch solche, sagen wir, chinesischen Überwachungs-Tools mit liebevollen Augen betrachten und sagen, hm, könnte man vielleicht hier auch mal machen. Also da sehe ich ja tatsächlich eine autoritäre Wende, die da stattfindet, die dann auch irgendwann ohne China geht. Aber dass man so sehr auf Konfrontation geht mit einem Handelspartner, ist ja nicht intelligent, würde man ja nicht machen. Und deswegen ist es ja auch intelligent zu sagen, wir gucken mal, wie wir jetzt mit Trumps Zollpolitik umgehen, aber wir verlautbaren in der Öffentlichkeit immer wieder, dass wir uns über die transatlantische Partnerschaft freuen und dass wir die gute Zusammenarbeit schätzen. Und genau so müsste man ja sinnvollerweise auch mit China umgehen. Man verlautbart, dass das so eine tolle Zusammenarbeit ist und dass so zwei alte Kulturen schön zusammenarbeiten. Und dann kann man ja intern nochmal klären, wie geht man eigentlich zum Beispiel mit europäischen Investoren in China um. Und dass die zum Beispiel gegängelt werden und dass dort die chinesische Regierung tatsächlich das alles sehr viel fester gezuhrt hat und nicht im Interesse, dass da auf Augenhöhe operiert wird. Das ist ja völlig klar, aber das wäre ja wieder was, was intern zu klären ist, wo man jetzt nicht als Elefant im Porzellanladen auftreten muss.
Ja, das ist sehr gute Politikberatung, denn ich würde das auch empfehlen, dass man die nächsten fünf Jahre die Chancen nutzt, im Sinne von Richard David Brecht, hier mal einen Schulterschluss hinzuwirken, denn am Ende geht es ja nur um zwei Sachen. Allen soll es gut gehen und niemand soll niemanden erschießen. Und da sind wir aber noch nicht. Und ich bin ja auch immer mehr ein Fan davon zu sagen, warten wir doch mal ab, denn am Ende, irgendwelche Leute werden irgendwas wollen, aber soziologisch aufgeklärt, Sachen passieren. Ob noch irgendwer was will, okay, das können wir dann nur so als Beiwerk in die Fußnote schreiben. Jemand wollte etwas und dann ging ein Plan auf. Es werden halt Sachen passieren. So, die Sachen sind jetzt in Bewegung. Es ist alles wahnsinnig kompliziert. Jetzt gerade sind wir aber nicht im Stadium mit Europa und China machen einen großen Schulterschluss, weil es ist ja gerade für beide Wirtschaftskrieg. Wie die Chinesen darauf reagieren, wir hören es hier im Urton, es ist wirklich eine Sensation.
China wird die notwendigen Maßnahmen ergreifen, um seine legitimen Rechte und Interessen entschlossen zu wahren.
Wenn die USA die Interessen beider Länder und der internationalen Gemeinschaft ignorieren und auf einen Zoll-
und Handelskrieg bestehen, wird China diesen bis zum Ende kämpfen.
So, jetzt behauptet Trump immer die ganze Zeit, ich rede mit der ganzen Welt, ich habe schon 200 Verträge und dann sagen die, aber es gibt doch nur 195 Länder, also mit welchem haben sie denn 100% und so. Also wir sind ja gerade im, keiner redet mit niemandem offiziell, damit jetzt nicht im Sinne von, naja, in Amerika wird jetzt beobachtet, dass Europa verloren geht. Nee, das Signal senden wir jetzt gerade nicht. Und wir Europäer sind auch mehr so diese, ja, komm doch zum Staatsbesuch, bei uns passiert immer was, der Papst stirbt, die Orgel wird eröffnet oder was auch immer so. Die Chinesen sind halt anders drauf. Aber jeder fällt jetzt erstmal zurück in seine kulturelle Sehgewohnheit und kommuniziert halt so vor sich hin. Also man darf jetzt nicht zu viele Ansprüche haben an irgendwas, weil alle warten jetzt erstmal, dass was passiert. Und das Tolle ist ja, alle können ja warten. Trump ist ja der Enige, der sagt 90 Tage, dann sind 90 Tage um, dann muss er irgendwas machen. Die Chinesen will nichts machen. Es ist halt ein bisschen blöd, dass die ganzen Container da zu rumstehen und so. Aber das größte Problem, wie gesagt, dass die Europäer haben, ist erst mal strukturell zu viel billiger Kram. Und das ist kein ernsthaftes Problem, sondern das kann man auch erst mal dankbar annehmen im Sinne von. So nun gut, diese Staatsanleihe Zinsensache ist nun und deswegen hier am Ende des ersten Drittels von diesem Ding eine Sache, da kann man noch so viele politische Wünsche haben. Und noch so viele Intentionen und noch so komische Ideologien. Wenn sich diese Zinsen entwickeln, entwickeln sich diese Zinsen und sie haben Effekte. Es ist in dem Falle, auch wenn es Kultur ist, wie ein Naturereignis. Der Regen fällt. Und in der New York Times wurde das ganz gut beschrieben, was das so bedeutet, wenn dieser quasi Leitzins sich verändert. Also in Zeiten der Krise bringt man sein Geld in Sicherheit und man weiß, das einzige Geld, das immer akzeptiert wird, ist der amerikanische Dollar. Fast wie Gold. So, bis hierhin, das kann man ja mal unter, unser Podcast profitiert sehr davon, wenn es viel zu erklären gibt und die Welt besonders scheiße ist. Wir sind also in so einem inkongruenten Verhältnis zur Welt und so ist das halt mit Amerika auch. Wenn immer Krise ist, erst mal wird der Staat Amerika gestärkt.
Selbst wenn Krise in Amerika ist, selbst wenn Krise in Amerika ist, setzt man auf den Dollar.
Wenn dann erst mal Corona ist und so was, das ist eigentlich ein Erfolgsrezept. Und das ist jetzt gerade nicht so.
Die Zinsen steigen also dann, würden steigen. Bedeutet der Alltag für die Amerikaner wird teurer.
Die konkrete Kreditkartenzahlung für Güter, die sowieso schon teurer wurden durch diese Politik, sind höher plötzlich.
Aber auch die Staatsverschuldung wird teurer, weil man plötzlich höhere Zinszahlung hat. Wir erinnern uns, als Corona war, weil diese Idee, wer könnte dann die Impfungen zahlen für die armen Länder? Dann hat der Adam Toos gesagt, naja, eigentlich sollte einfach Deutschland die Impfungen alle per Kredit kaufen. Es sind Negativzinsen. Der Staat würde noch daran verdienen, sich zu verschulden. Und genau diese Situation herrscht natürlich dann nicht mehr. Jetzt ist ja sowieso schon etwas Inflation da. Und dann werden die Zinsen für die Staatsanleihen plötzlich teurer. Und das bedeutet für alle, dass es teurer wird. Und das ist dann etwas, dem es Trump, der große Inflationsbekämpfer, ausgeliefert hat.
Ja, wir haben ja eben von Wolfram Weimer dieses Die Ordnung. Konservativ sein, um die Ordnung zu erhalten. Hier hätte man sich ja nicht Impfstoff für Afrikaner gekauft, sondern Stabilität im Großen und Ganzen. Und Deutschland war nicht bereit oder Europa da reinzugehen. Zum Glück hat dann Afrika gar nicht diese krassen Verwerfungen durch Corona gehabt, weil die Bevölkerung einfach jünger ist und so. Also da hat man dann so ein bisschen Glück gehabt. So, jetzt ist hier Podcast angesagt. Wir hören jetzt nur Podcasts, die Trump geil finden, richtig geil, die das bisher geil fanden, dass da mal jemand den Kulturkampf in die politische Praxis überführt und so. Zum Beispiel dieser... Was hören wir denn als allererstes? Ich weiß gar nicht, ich hör mal kurz rein.
What do you think is going on here?
Ah ja, das ist dieser All-In-Podcast. Indem einfach so ein paar Sätze jetzt gesagt werden. Bislang war ja so, ja okay, so denkt halt Trump und mal gucken, was er dann macht. Aber diese Sätze haben jetzt andere Prisanz.
What do you think is going on here? Because if, when I went through all the top people on the internet, all our group of friends who are deeply in finance, I can't find anybody deeply in finance who's not in the administration, who thinks this is well executed or a good idea. What's your thought?
Let me start by saying a couple things. To use the Donald Rumsfeld code, I do agree with Ben tremendously, that this was a known known. We mentioned this last episode. Donald Trump has been speaking about tariffs for 40 plus years. So this is not a new thing. I think that he tried this in Trump 1. But to your guy's point, it didn't really go well because he didn't have the team around him that had his back. So it was inevitable that he would have tried it in Trump 2. He said it and he's been able to do it. So if you weren't planning for it, whoever was vested in this outcome, you really needed to be focused on this. It was a no-no. And so there was a little dereliction of duty if you were caught off guard, I think. That's one. The second is, and we've said this all year since January 1 on this pod, we started it even with that Polly market bet that I made, which is the Trump administration does not care about the stock market.
So, ein ungeheuerlicher Satz. Denn Trump wurde von Leuten ins Amt gebracht, die ihm alle eine Million Dollar für seine Amtseinführung gaben, damit er sich um den Stockmarket kümmert.
Und das war ja auch die erste Amtszeit von Trump. Er verwies immer auf die Aktienkurse.
Ich erlasse euch die Steuern hier, alles ging nach oben.
Und das ist ja so interessant, dass diese Trump-Anhänger aus der Kryptoszene und Hausrundhopf und wie sie alle heißen, ja eigentlich gerade Verluste machen. Genau. Und dass sie aber trotzdem nicht wütend sind. Also wenn ich daran denke, wie wütend diese Leute waren, wenn Robert Habeck irgendeine minimale Veränderung machen wollte. Und das hätte der deutschen Wirtschaft vielleicht so einen kleinen Knick gegeben. Dann waren die völlig aus dem Häuschen und haben so getan, als sei die Enteignung jetzt kurz vor der Tür. Und jetzt, wenn es einfach heißt, ja die Börse ist zwar gestiegen, aber ihr seid jetzt einfach wieder auf dem Börsenniveau wie vor einem Jahr und alles ist verpufft und der Bitcoin hat jetzt auch wieder 20.000 Dollar verloren, da haben die Leute irgendwie keinen Grund zu hyperventilieren. Das finde ich erstaunlich.
Genau. Also mal sehen, wann das richtig ausbricht. Hier wird ja eine Ideologie auf Biegen und Brechen durchgepeitscht, auch gegen politische Realität, die einem einfach nicht egal sein kann, anders als wenn man Oppositionsführer ist. So, also da kann man Munition sammeln, aber das heißt noch nicht, dass man die dann in der Regierung abschießen kann, sondern da hat man halt dieselben Probleme. Wir haben in Deutschland die Diskussion mit diesen eine Billion Euro, also wenn man die der Ampel gegeben hätte, wäre das auch eine super Regierung gewesen, ja? Und jetzt ist es halt März. So, wir haben in Amerika eben diese völlig absurde Diskussion. Äh, Obama hat damals mal bei einer Pressekonferenz so einen hellen Anzug getragen. Die Debatte hast du bestimmt noch. Es gab so, Obama tritt im Presseraum auf und hat so einen relativ hellbraunen Anzug an. Und Fox News war aussässig. Tagelange Berichterstattung, wie das denn geht und überhaupt und so, ne? Also ein Anzug heller als seine Haut, so zu sagen. Und Donald Trump ist jetzt nach Rom gefahren und saß halt einfach in einem blauen Anzug auf einer Beerdigung unter lauter schwarzen Anzügen. Also dieses Foto ist so absurd, das zu sehen, wie er da einfach sitzt. Und da gibt es aber keine Kritik. Und in diesem Maße, wie man da einfach drüber hinweggehen kann, kann man halt bei den anderen Themen gerade nicht drüber hinweggehen. Aber während die ganze Welt sich auf den schwarzen Anzug einigt, aus Sitte und Gewohnheit oder eben Transferleistung, weil es nicht anders geht, trägt trotzdem blau. Und dieses Bild, ihn dazu zu sehen, als der komplette Counterpart zur ganzen Welt, zur ganzen Gesellschaft, zur ganzen Geschichte, kann sich bei einer Papstbeerdigung nicht benehmen. So gilt das einfach. Das ist das ikonografische Bild dieser Regierungszeit, wie er da auf der Tribüne ist.
Aber wenn wir nochmal ganz kurz in diese Köpfe hinein klettern, was sind das für Leute, also wir reden ja jetzt über welche, die bei Twitter oder Tweets am Tag veröffentlichen, in denen sie sich zum Beispiel aufregen, wie Alena Baerbock irgendwo gekleidet ist und was weiß ich, mit der Fosur nicht stimmt oder so. Also irgendwelche Details suchen sie den ganzen Tag. Und zugleich wollen sie das nicht ein einziges Mal thematisieren. Sie könnten ja sagen, ich hasse die Baerbock, aber hier hat Trump echt daneben gegriffen, der muss ja eine Chance anzutun.
Ja, aber was würde es bedeuten, wenn sie das machen?
Das wäre ja schon ein Schritt, das könnten die ja sagen. Aber das machen sie ja nicht. Bei denen ist ja nur, sie konzentrieren sich auf den politischen Gegner und der macht auch alles falsch und jeder, der gesagt wird, ist falsch, beziehungsweise wird noch mal so umgeschnitten, bis er falsch wird, während sie ja nicht in der Lage sind, noch die kleinsten Zugeständnisse zu machen und zum Beispiel auch zu erkennen, nicht nur der Anzug war ein Problem, sondern richtig durchdacht war das offenbar mit den Zöllen nicht, sonst rudert man nicht so schnell wieder zurück. Dann kann man ja nicht da sitzen breitbeinig und sagen, ja, es ist ein Dealmaker, es ist echt genial, was der Trump da wieder gemacht hat. Dann kann man ja auch einfach sagen, nee, das war offenbar nicht so gut. Das würde schon mal reichen. Dazu sind diese Leute aber nicht in der Lage. Also diese Gefolgschaft bei gleichzeitiger Bekundung von ich das Individuum bin frei und denke selbst ist ja erstaunlich. Denn das ist ja wirkliches Herdenverhalten da. Das sind ja genau, also Herdenverhalten meint ja, da ist eine Klippe. Ich weiß auch eigentlich, dass da eine Klippe ist. Aber das Herdentier sagt mir immer weiter, immer weiter. Und dann falle ich da runter.
Ich glaube, das Herden-Phenomen ist es nicht so sehr, aber es ist diese Lenin-Logik. Um eine Revolution zu machen, musst du ein echtes Angebot in der Tasche haben. Wenn du habe kritisierst, ist ja der O-Ton immer, März könnte es besser. Also mein Lager könnte es besser. So, wenn du dich gegen dein eigenes Lager wendest, was ist die Subbotschaft? Wer könnte es denn besser? Du gestehst ja nicht nur dein eigenes Scheitern ein, sondern dass du jetzt selbst nicht weiter weißt.
Man wäre allein.
Ja, also auch da wie der White Lotus, in dieser einen Staffel macht der eine Typ lieber einen Massenmord an seiner eigenen Familie als einen Gesichtsverlust seiner Person hinzunehmen. Vor denen. Er bringt sie lieber einfach um. Und das ist einfach schockierend zu sehen. Und das ist aber die Logik, die gilt. Deswegen finden wir das so faszinierend, das mal ausbuchstabiert zu sehen, was das bedeutet. Und diese Leute können sich diesen Gesichtsverlust, lieber reiten sie gemeinsam in den Tod und dann sterben einfach alle. Das Schicksal hat es wieder für alle gleich. Bevor man sich zugesteht, ne, wir ziehen jetzt hier aus und überlassen anderen das Weiße Haus. So, weil diese es eingeständen sind. Dieses eigene Unvermögen. Und dass irgendwer anders vielleicht eine Idee hätte, die besser sein könnte. Geschweige denn, dass diejenigen, die vorher dran waren, es wieder machen. Also irgendwann habe ich doch mal noch als Kanzlerauftritt.
Das ist natürlich eine Reise ohne Wiederkehr, die die angetreten sind.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Und das hören wir jetzt hier Ben Shapiro. Wir kennen ihn, Daily Wire, riesiger Publikumserfolg, ist jetzt hier im Podcast zu Gast und redet mal anfänglich, also schon so ein bisschen, wir hören jetzt irgendwo, müssen sie es ja kritisieren. Also sie suchen hier händeringend Auswege.
So, wieder einmal, es ist schwer für mich zu sehen, wie all das in die, was so ein wirklich gut kategorisiertes Politikentwurf sieht. Und dann, vor allem, in der langen Zeit, Tricks, die wir spielen, mit Bezug auf den Rate der Interessen, das Geld unserer nationalen Schuld, werden nicht genug sein, um unser nationales Geld zu bezahlen, unless wir robuste, ökonomische Wachstum haben. Und also, vieles muss auf die robuste, ökonomische Wachstum auswählen, wesentlich die Niveau der Schuld, So, Zölle, richtig.
Doge, Bürokratieabbau, richtig. Vieles, richtig. Trump hat recht. Leider war kein Wirtschaftswachstum da. Es wird jetzt so ganz feingliedrig gesagt, woran es liegt, dass wir natürlich sagen, wo soll das Wirtschaftswachstum herkommen, wenn alles das, was du für richtig Empfindnis gemacht wird, ist das halt der Zustand der Welt. Aber man könnte schon wieder ein Problem isolieren, einen Schuldigen finden, wie auch immer. Jetzt ist es gerade der Fatsh-Chef. Er hat halt kein Mandat für Wirtschaftswachstum, sondern nur für Arbeitsplätze und Zinseninflation. Man versucht jetzt so die Einflugsgeneisen zu finden. Shapiro noch ein bisschen mehr. Er versucht jetzt so Bilder zu schaffen.
Das ist so schnell, dass du es fast mal übersetzen müsstest.
Also hier droht einfach die Gefahr, die Leute machen sich zu viele Gedanken über, oder jetzt ist gerade dieser riesige Tenor mit irgendwelche Pinguine werden besteuert, wird bezahlt. Das ist natürlich blöd. Kann man so lange aufrechterhalten, also so ausfrasern zu lassen, die ist ja Trump am besten, flooding the zone with shit, bis die Rezession kommt. Also das echte Preisschild im Supermarkt, wo es einfach heißt, nee, sorry. Ab hier muss grundsätzlich neu erklärt werden. Ich kann jetzt nicht mehr akzeptieren, dass Leute, die ich nicht kenne, mit Krankheiten, die ich nicht verstehe, ins Ausland müssen, wo ich noch nie war. So kann man alles hinweg sehen. Aber wenn es ans Eingemachte geht, dann wird es problematisch.
Das funktioniert jetzt alles ja gerade noch halbwegs in den USA, deshalb, weil vorher die beiden Administrationen funktioniert hat. Also man muss es ja so sehen, dass ja also das, was gerade noch funktioniert, deshalb funktioniert, weil es nicht mit Trump zu tun hat.
Ich versuche mal jetzt mit 72 Prozent Geschwindigkeit abzustellen. Mal gucken, wie es klingt.
Wir versuchen jetzt also wieder eine normale Geschwindigkeit bei den Clips herzustellen. Hast du die etwa alle so schnell?
Es ist immer ein Ding, den ich halt nicht entsprechend setze.
Aber die davor waren ja in normaler Geschwindigkeit.
Also ja, gut, das ist dann in einem Exportvorgang, wenn das schief geht.
If you're going to make the case for a long term gain, I need to know what the long term gain is, so I can make the case.
Nee, das klingt komisch. Ich übersetze euch einfach mal, was hier gesagt wird. Und wir hören es uns in dieser entsprechenden Geschwindigkeit an. Ben Shapiro fordert Aufklärung ein im Grunde. Also er hat eben schon das Ehebild bemüht. So eine Ehe geht immer so lange gut, bis die Rezension kommt. Und dann steht aber alles kleinteilig zur Disposition. Dann zieht man über nichts mehr hinweg, dann ist plötzlich alles Konfliktthema. Und hier, wenn ich vom Arzt die Diagnose bekomme und ich gehe ins Krankenhaus und der sagt, die Operation wird kompliziert und sie werden sich danach nicht gut fühlen, aber sie sind dann geheilt für den Rest ihres Lebens, dann geht das. Aber wenn es einfach nur heißt, wir operieren sie jetzt mal. Warum? Wir wissen nicht genau, ob es ihnen danach besser geht. Aber sie müssen jetzt da durch.
Aber wir wollen es mal versuchen.
Genau, wir versuchen es mal. Das ist so diese Schrecken ohne Ende, Ende ohne Schrecken und so.
Da sind wir aber an einem Punkt, bei dem man sich ja folgendes fragen muss. Wir haben einen uralten Präsidenten, der noch ein paar Jahre jetzt regieren wird.
Der hat sein tolles Leben gelebt eigentlich.
Aber er bekommt ja, wenn diese Wette aufgeht für ihn, bekommt er das ja in dem Sinne nicht mehr mit. Also wir haben es ja hier nicht mit jemandem zu tun, der noch dann eine zweite Amtszeit vor sich hat, sondern wir haben es ja mit jemandem zu tun, der in der letzten Phase seines Lebens solche Projekte umsetzt, die nur als Long-Term-Projekte überhaupt zu verstehen sind. Also sie ergeben dann schon wenig Sinn, sagen wir mal. Aber für die kurze Zeit bedeutet das ja nichts. Wenn wir uns an den Trump der ersten Amtszeit erinnern, dann war das ja ein reiner Short-Term-Mann. Der hat ja nur gesagt, ach, seht hier, die Kurse sind hoch. Dies und das selbst noch als Corona kam, als wirklich alle in der Panik waren, hat er ja erst noch mal, bevor er dann auch sah, okay, man muss da eingreifen.
Noch einen Tag, das ist auch immer offen und so.
Da hat er ja auch so Sachen gesagt wie, Benzin ist billig, ist toll für die Konsumenten. Also das war ja nur so eine ganz kurzfristige Sache, überhaupt nicht nur einmal über den Tag hinaus gedacht. Jetzt erleben wir einen anderen Präsidenten. Jetzt erleben wir einen, der eigentlich in fünf Jahresplänen denkt. Das ist ja das chinesische Modell, zu sagen, wir haben folgendes Ziel 2035, 2049, dies und das. Und dann werden wir das große chinesische Reich sein mit dem und dem. Das ist ja eigentlich eine Perspektive, die auch nicht Demokratien gut stehen, beziehungsweise die auch ein Problem ergeben. Also wir wissen es ja gerade bei so Klimazielen oder so, dass wir gerade diese kurzfristige Politik, die gemacht werden muss, wenn man wieder die nächste Landtagswahl gewinnen will, etwas dem widerstrebt, was man eigentlich klimapolitisch umsetzen wollte. Was er ja jetzt hier macht, ist zwar keine Klimapolitik, aber auch eine Sache der Reindustrialisierung der USA, wo man sagen muss, das ist ja ein Projekt, das auf 10, 15 Jahre mindestens angelegt sein soll. Erst dann wird man bewerten können, ob das erfolgreich war. Wie auch das chinesische Aufstiegsmodell eines ist, das in den 70er Jahren mit Ronald Reagan beginnt und dann sich ja erst in den 90er Jahren als wirkliche Erfolgsgeschichte entwickelt. Was er also hier anstrebt, ist etwas, was er selbst nicht mehr erleben wird. Und er muss ja, um das verfolgen zu können oder seine Leute um das verfolgen zu können, JD Vans und wer da so alles im Hintergrund agiert, die müssen das ja ausgelegt haben auf eine Regierung, die im Prinzip die nächsten 15 Jahre nicht mehr abgewählt wird. Weil sonst wird das nicht aufgehen. Alles andere ist ja dann nur Chaos gestiftet, ohne irgendein wirklich utopisches Projekt zu haben.
Wir sind ja in dem Metier, wo die davon ausgehen, dass sie nicht mehr abgewählt werden.
Genau.
Also die sind ja in allen Belangen so hoch.
Was ich jetzt hier anspreche, ist nämlich, dass man eigentlich davon ausgehen muss, dass man doch die Demokratie abschaffen muss, um das überhaupt zu einem Erfolg zu bringen. Denn anders ist es nicht. Mit wechselnden Mehrheitsfeldessen ist eine solche große Idee, ist so ein Long-Termism nicht umsetzbar.
Ja, in dem nächsten Clip. Wir haben häufiger von dieser Idee gehört, die vor allem von Elon Musk zum Beispiel zuletzt bei Joe Rogan erzählt wird. Die Demokraten machen eine Migrationspolitik, die ihnen Wähler verschafft. Weil da kommt nämlich die diverse Welt nach Amerika und es sind ja dann alles Demokratenwähler. Jetzt hören wir mal hier, was die Republikaner brauchen bei Wählern, die sie eigentlich schon in der Tasche hatten, aber deren Boden unter die Füßen sie jetzt wegziehen. Also mal wieder die Soja-Bohnen-Farmer.
As a result, the Trump administration had to issue two support payment checks to farmers that totaled $28 billion in 2018 and 2019. Just because of that China stepping out of the buying market, American farmers represent a large amount of the voting bloc for the Republican Party. And so I think that the second consequence is going to be that there is going to need to be financial support, which means increased government spending, if we intend to keep the tariffs in place, and the global market stops buying American exports. That's the second consequence.
Ja, also ihr wird wieder konkret darüber gesprochen. Und damals gingen ja wirklich 100% der Zolleinnahmen dafür drauf, nur die Soja-Bohnenfarmer da zu unterstützen, dass man sich ja Wählerstimmen erkauft. Wird einfach so gesagt in Podcasts, ne? Schon nicht schlecht. China. Sie reden im All-In-Podcast über China. Hier geht es jetzt auch ans Eingemachte, denn China hat ja Waffen zur Verfügung.
The third consequence, which is the one I am most worried about, which I think about a lot, is China had the State Council meeting a couple days ago and in that State Council meeting they announced a series of measures and a series of steps that they would be willing to take.
Das ist auch eine Million iPhones konkret hergestellt werden. Das ist der viel wichtigere Teil. Ich würde sagen, wenn jetzt Apple einfach sagen würde, wir haben uns das anders überlegt, wir bauen keine iPhones mehr und China würde sagen, ja dann übernehmen wir das einfach und bauen jetzt erstmal nur iPhones 16. Damit wäre die Welt zehn Jahre lang zufrieden. Also keiner erwartet jetzt große Sprünge in der nächsten iPhone-Generation oder so, sondern bei Autos sieht man es ja schon, das Auto war im Grunde aus erfunden und jetzt liegt China noch eine Schippe drauf und sagt, geiles Entertainment hier, da pipa po, kriegst einen Countdown für die nächste Ampel, weißt schon mal, wie du fahren musst und so. All solche Schnickschnack, den es hier nicht gab. Sie entdecken jetzt die eine oder andere Sache, die man bisher ausgeblendet lassen konnte, wenn man einfach nur Wolfram Weimer mäßig so vor sich hin textet.
Weißt du, dass etwa 25 Prozent aller unserer Utilitätsbewerber in Amerika zwischen 2017 und 2022 für die Erhebung beherrscht wurden? Ich wusste es nicht. Also, die meisten der Menschen, 56 Prozent aller Utilitätsbewerber haben jetzt weniger als eine Dezember Erfahrung. Weißt du, was das in dem Fall ist? Im Jahr 2021 hat die average US-Kustomer von einer elektrischen Utilität 7,5 Stunden von Anrufen in der Service-Interruptions-Behörde und es ist einfach wach.
Ich denke, die average Plummer-Ausgabe ist 50-something. Wir können keine Menschen werden, um Plummer zu werden.
NERC sagt, dass 19 Staaten in den USA nun durch normale Peer-Konditionen schlafen, wenn diese Probleme nicht beantwortet werden. Und übrigens, das ist ein menschliches Kapitalproblem. Aber wenn du das um 10, 20, 30 Mal multiplizieren kannst, gibt es einen anderen Tweet, ich weiß nicht, Nick, ob du es finden könntest, der über eine Organisation gesprochen hat, die Leute versucht hat, nukleare Submarine zu bauen. Seht ihr diese Quote? Wo sie 100.000 Menschen brauchen, um nukleare Submarine in den USA zu bauen, und sie kaum ein paar hundert finden können.
Ja, wir müssen besser aus dem Ding kommen.
Es fehlen Leute.
So, das ganze Land müsste sich auf so eine demografische Wende einstellen.
Ja.
Diesen Dienstleitungssektor überhaupt erst mal schaffen, gestalten, Ausbildungswege machen, Anreizstrukturen, Gehälter regeln und dann die Leute da reinbringen. Stattdessen soll jetzt alle in Fabrikheilen gehen und sich ihre Turnschuhe selber herstellen. Das ist ja auch sprunz doof, ja.
Ja und um das dann umzusetzen, müsste man ja in Jahrzehnten denken. Da reicht ja auch kein 5-Jahresplan.
Ja und das ist eine Herausforderung, die ist schon da, unabhängig davon, dass man nochmal die Welt in Turbulenzen bringt. Ja. Also es macht, und ich würde sagen, so schlecht geht es stets noch gar nicht um die Demografie, nur wenn man den Leuten jetzt so viel Perspektive nimmt, dass sich wirklich erstmal alle auf sich selbst konzentrieren, also in den nächsten 20 Jahren die Geburtenrate entsprechend sinkt, dann ist das halt ein echtes Problem.
In den USA gibt es ja keine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit.
Genau, ist ja gar nicht das Problem gewesen.
Ja, wenn man jetzt noch mehr Migranten aus dem Land jagt oder weniger reinlässt, dann verschafft man das ja noch. Und wenn man dann noch von denen, die ja ohnehin alle erarbeitet sind, verlangt, dass sie jetzt plötzlich Tätigkeiten verrichten, die sie vorher gar nicht verrichten mussten, weil man es im Ausland einkaufte, sind wir ja in einer Situation, wo man sagen muss, ja, dann müssen die sich jetzt als Bevölkerung verdoppeln, damit das geht.
Und das sind die Trump-Podcasts, die so reden. Das sind hier Shapiro, David Sex, die ganzen Leute. Also dieser All-In-Podcast, der ist ja ganz instruktiv. Ich will mir nicht interessant sagen, aber instruktiv.
Jetzt auf wieder normaler Geschwindigkeit.
Ich weiß immer nicht so genau. Wir hören jetzt wieder ein Shapiro-Clip. Vielleicht redet er einfach schneller. Also der redet wahnsinnig schnell. Nur ich kann es jetzt auch nicht genau hören, dass er vielleicht, mal gucken, Shapiro.
The thing that I would say, that I really think that maybe no other politician would say, and I can say it, because I'm not a politician, your future is in America.
Das ist echt komisch.
Das ist doppelte Geschwindigkeit, aber eben im Podcast davor, die Folge davor von All In, das war tatsächlich wieder normale Geschwindigkeit.
Your future is in your hands.
Ah ja, das ist wichtig. Also versucht mal hinzuhören. Das Individuum und der Staat, was ist, wenn der Staat ausfällt? Könnte man dann den Gesichtsverlust in Kauf nehmen und sagen, okay, wir übergeben dem Staat jemand anderem, der es für dich besser macht? Oder sagen wir einfach, nö, dann ist kein Staat mehr. Es ist deine Verantwortung, dich um dich zu kümmern. Ja, also wenn der Staat ausfällt, wir geben dir gerne eine neue Chance, damit du es nochmal versuchst, aber bitte warte nicht auf die Hilfe des Staates.
Und auch der Fall, der ein bisschen früher von China gemacht wurde, dass China sagt, dass es Dinge kann. Eine der Dinge, die mich auf der Wiese steigern, ist, wenn Politiker sagen, ich habe X-Jobs gemacht, oder wir haben X-Jobs gemacht, dann hast du keine Arbeit gemacht. Die Regierung hat keine Arbeit gemacht. Die Regierung kann Geld von Leuten nehmen und dann anderen geben.
Also der Staat hält dir das Volksblut rein und verteidigt dich nach außen, aber den Rest musst du schon selber machen.
Ja.
Und der Staat schafft keine Jobs?
Nein. Da soll Trump nicht mit Kennziffern oder auch ein anderer Präsident kommen. Die Jobs haben wir uns selber gemacht.
Irgendwoher, die Infrastruktur, gut schweigen wir von.
Also die radikalisieren sich jetzt in diesen Hüberindividualismus rein, in der einfach der Staat komplett ausgeblendet ist.
Das ist ja auch die einzige Chance dann. Also man kann ja einfach sagen, wenn du nichts vom Staat zu erwarten hast, dann brauchst du dich ja auch nicht mehr zu kritisieren.
Was ich auch gut fand, ist Philipp Westermeier war im Allesgesagt Podcast. Du hörst ja diesen OMR Kram auch gerne, instruktiv.
Instruktiv, ja.
Und er wurde da auch gefragt, ist das jetzt nicht, du bist doch Wirtschaftspodcaster und so, voll turbulent und Westermeier versucht nur die ganze Zeit so, nee, ich bin voll gelassen, es kommt doch immer mal zu Anpassungen und sowas. Und ich habe mir dann so gedacht, ja, so verkauft man Business, also so Konferenzen heute, dass man einfach sagt, du bist im Chaos, Therapie ist nicht für dich, sondern dann komm noch zu uns, wir erklären dir den Sinn der Sache und dass das alles normal ist. Also so Hyper-Normalisierung ist jetzt plötzlich auch so ganz in, während ich immer sagen würde, nee, das ist einfach das Zeitalter der katastrophalen Dummheit. Ist ja noch lange nicht, dass deswegen, nur weil die Intelligenz, die Beisteuert gemindert ist, die sozialen Sachen jetzt anders oder irgendwie so, also ist ja total interessant, was so passiert, wenn Menschenintelligenz ausfällt, die Welt bleibt ja nicht stehen. So und bei Horst und Hopf hören wir das auch mal. Ja, es passieren halt so Sachen, es ist keine Aufregung.
Ich glaube, Trump hat mit seinen Zöllen etwas beschleunigt, was so unvermeidbar gewesen wäre.
Das, was gerade passiert ist unvermeidbar.
Ja, klar.
Wir müssen sie aber ein bisschen entschuldigen, die denken ja nur in Aktienwerten. Ja, denen ist ja der Rest egal. Denen sind ja nur die Effekte auf den Märkten so entscheidend.
Wo unvermeidbar gewesen wäre und ich glaube, er möchte es beschleunigen, weil er nicht ein Slow Bleed und eine langsame Rezession über seine Präsidentschaft hinweg haben wollen möchte, sondern weil er einfach mit seiner Präsidentschaft eher gegen Ende hin als die Person eingehen möchte, bei denen die Märkte hochgegangen sind und weil er weiß, dass unabhängig davon, was er jetzt gemacht hätte, wenn er jetzt nicht das quasi beschleunigt hätte, durch seine Strafzahlen noch mehr Panik gesorgt hätte, dass so passiert wäre. Aber also, ich habe jetzt viel geredet.
Ja, viel geredet und viel Dummes gesagt, denn es ist ja so bemerkenswert, dass man es schafft, da noch eine Strategie rauszulesen und das ist, also neues Kalkül habe ich so noch nicht gehört. Trump sah die Rezession kommen, fürchtete sich davor, dass ich lange hinziehen könnte. Deswegen sagt er, ich beschleunige die Rezession, so als sei die Rezession auch etwas, was, wenn man sich ein bisschen mehr anstrengt, dass es richtig schlecht wird, als sei das dann schneller vorbei. Das ist ja auch verrückt, ja. Das könnte man abkürzen dadurch, damit er dann strahlend am Ende seiner Abendszeit, als derjenige dasteht, der wieder die Börse nach oben gebracht hat und der Gewinner ist. Das ist ja eine Logik, wo man ja sagen muss, die ideologische Verblendung ist offenbar grenzenlos, dass man jetzt auch noch da bereit ist, eine größere Strategie zu erkennen. Wo man ja auch sagen muss, ja, Trump soll ja also nach normalen Gesichtspunkten gar nicht mehr wiedergewählt werden. Von daher, wie der aus der Abendszeit kommt, wäre ja für ihn wahlstrategisch überhaupt keine Frage mehr. Sie endet dann ohnehin für ihn. Und zu glauben, dass man Rezessionen verkürzen kann, indem man sagt, naja, dann so einmal mit Hauruck, und dann ist aber gut, ist ja völliger Unsinn. Als sei das so eine Idee von Gesundschrumpfen, die da stattfindet. Nein, es wird jetzt gerade die Wirtschaft massiv demontiert. Und dann kann man sich fragen, wie man sie irgendwann wieder zusammenbauen kann.
Braucht aber auch wieder Programm und Idee und ist kein Selbstläufer.
Und da ist überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit dahinten, das genauso zu machen.
Selbst wenn man jetzt sagt, Trump hat irgendwo ja vorausgeahnt, dass etwas nicht mehr funktioniert. Ja, das ist ja diese Idee von diesem Maralago-Akkord, wo halt nach 30 Jahren mal wieder eine neue, ich würde jetzt sagen, so wie George W. Bush schon vor zehn Jahren oder so sagte, ja immer kommt so einer und sagt Isolationismus. Das ist so regelmäßig das Programm Amerikas. Und Trump hatte immer diese Idee im Kopf, Amerika ist stark, wenn es isoliert ist, weil es dann sich auf seine eigenen Stärken konzentrieren kann. Kennt man ja immer, man entlässt Leute, weil man wirtschaftlich schrumpfen muss, weil es da Markt nicht mehr hergeht. Dann sagt man, wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auf unsere Stärke. So. Und da hängt aber hier diese politische Idee dahinter, dass dieses Gefüge aus, wir stellen das Militär für die Welt bereit und die Reservewährung für alle Zahlungsverkehre, die ablaufen. Und wir dulden nicht länger, dass wir auf Kosten dessen entindustrialisiert werden. Also hängen wir ein Preisschild dran. Entweder kriegen wir mehr Geld oder wir holen die Industrie zu uns. So. Und Trump hatte ja die Idee, das muss man so machen, weil das bisherige Gefüge funktioniert nicht mehr. Damit hat er aber nicht beschleunigt, was als bisheriges Gefüge nicht mehr gilt, sondern er hat ein ganz neues an diese Stelle haurokmäßig platziert. Das passt nun gar nicht. Diese Hoss und Hopf-Axeliterismus-Idee, ja?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so eine accelerationistische Idee davon, dass man etwas ganz schnell macht und dann wird es schon...
Nach dem Abgrund ist besser...
.von selbst gehen wieder. Dann wird es schon wieder gut werden. Was mir überhaupt noch aufgefallen ist...
Das ist echt so eine erlösende Idee, was das? So eine Lösung steckt da drin.
Was mir überhaupt noch aufgefallen ist bei Hoss und Hopf ist, dass dieser Erfolg des Podcasts nur funktioniert, wenn man ein Publikum hat, das faul ist. Also ein Publikum, das nicht sagt, ich vertiefe mich selbst mal in tiefere Artikel, vielleicht auch mal ein wissenschaftliches Paper, in die größeren politischen und wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge, sondern ich brauche ein Publikum, das faul darauf wartet, dass eine Folge kommt, und dann bekomme ich noch mal so eine irrsinnige Logik vorgeführt, da ich aber davor nichts gelesen habe, danach nichts lesen werde, und höchstens das Buch von Hoss und Hopf, das zum Teil aus leeren Seiten besteht, in meinem Bücherschrank habe.
Damit du dich selbst verwirklichen kannst.
Genau, werde ich niemals irritiert werden durch irgendetwas, und wenn ich in dieser Faulheit lange verharre, bin ich der ideale Hörer für Hoss und Hopf. Also jeder Hörer, der sich weiterbilden würde, der tatsächlich sagt, ich lese jetzt einfach mal ein Buch von Josef Sieglitz oder Krugman oder irgendeinem Ökonom, würde ja sofort nach 50 Seiten aufhören, Hoss und Hopf zu hören, weil man merkt, ach, das ist doch alles ein bisschen anders und auch komplizierter. Aber das ist ein Publikum, das niemals zu diesem Schritt gehen wird. Und deswegen ist das gar kein Problem.
Naja, ich meine, was willst du dich auch vertiefen, wenn die eigentliche Fragestellung ist, wenn ich heute eine Adidas Aktie für 5 Euro kaufe, ist sie dann morgen auch 5,30 Euro wert?
Ja.
Ist ja quasi der Horizont, an dem alles hängt.
Ja, dann kann man natürlich aber auch Pferdewetten machen. Das ist genauso. Also wäre sinnvoller.
Wir können jetzt mal Pferdewetten quasi.
Kehran, ich würde aber dich da mal eine andere Frage stellen. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, sehr, sehr viele Leute, das ist für mich für sie die drängendste Frage aktuell.
So, die drängendste Frage aktuell.
Ja, gerade. Und schreibt es gerne mal in die Kommentare rein.
Und schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare. So, jetzt wollen wir wissen, was ist die drängendste Frage, zu der wir alle kommentieren sollen?
Wie ihr das seht. Wie fühlt ihr euch jetzt aktuell? Habt ihr Angst, Unsicherheit und geht ihr ganz ehrlich damit um? Das kann ja jeder frei sagen. Ich würde sagen, der Kean und ich, wir sind da schon Veteranen in diesem Spiel drin. Ich sehe das als Riesenschance aktuell. Ich habe heute, ich habe Nvidia nachgekauft, ich habe Nike nachgekauft.
Er ergibt sich jetzt in diesem, was ich nachgekauft habe. Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich auch so Riesenangst. Was soll man jetzt bloß tun? Und er meint einfach nur, was kauft man jetzt?
Nike ist für mich gerade als Sportartikelhersteller Nummer eins, Weltmarktführer dominant, minus 70 Prozent jetzt runtergegangen. Das ist für mich, wo ich sage, alles klar, Schnäppchen. Meta ist für mich sehr interessant. Wie siehst du das generell? Bist du jetzt super defensiv?
Das ist auch toll, nur Geheimtipps. Meta, Adidas, Nvidia. Ich frage mich auch immer bei diesen Leuten, gut, diese drei Börsenwerte, die kann man ja so jeden Tag im Kopf mit sich herumführen. Aber habt ihr denn mal sonst noch irgendetwas anzubieten? Also es wäre ja mal interessant, mal irgendein anderes Unternehmen aus dieser großen, weiten Welt zu hören. Da würde ich mich ja sogar noch hinreißen lassen, mich dafür auch zu interessieren. Aber dass ihr mir jetzt noch mal sagt, ja, ein Video könnte man noch mal rein oder Meta. Ja, dann kann ich euch jeden Tag einen Podcast aufnehmen, dem ich sage, ja, vielleicht ein guter Zeitpunkt nochmal bei Meta einzusteigen. Also das ist doch totaler Irrsinn.
Ja, für Apple. Oder Alphabet.
Erstmal oder sagst du dir, ich schaue mir das Ganze genauer an und ich werde vielleicht sogar stärker investiert?
Philipp, ich habe ja schon wirklich lange auf diesen Moment gewartet. Letztes Jahr im Oktober habe ich noch sehr viel Hate dafür bekommen, dass ich gesagt habe, dass ich Q1 die Rezession erwarte. Gut, jetzt ist es Q2, aber sieben Tage um sieben Tage verschoben. Nichtsdestotrotz, ich habe so lange auf diesen Moment gewartet. Ich habe jetzt angefangen, wirklich größere Mengen wieder in Bitcoin vor allem zu stecken.
Der Liberation-Day ist wie Ostern und Weihnachten am selben Tag. Endlich billige Aktien. Ich habe es ja schon lange erwartet und auch schon vorausgesagt.
Ja, irgendwann gehen Kurse immer runter. Das kann ich jetzt auch hier schon mal voraussagen. Und irgendwann gehen sie auch wieder hoch.
Genial.
Und ja, es ist eine alte Börsenweisheit, dass wenn die Kurse unten sind, man günstig einsteigen kann. Bedeutet aber auch, dass man darauf wetten muss, dass sie wieder nach oben gehen. Und wenn sie immer weiter nach oben gehen würden, müssten sie gar nicht mal fallen. Also das sind ja alles so Idiotien, die hier als große Weisheiten präsentiert werden. Vor allem muss man sich ja auch hier wieder das Publikum klarmachen. Hier hören Leute zu bei Haus und Hopf. Die haben vielleicht 3000 Euro, die sie im Aktienportfolio haben und die haben sie aufgeteilt auf Einzelaktien. Was man eh nicht machen sollte, aber gut. Das heißt, bei denen ändert sich ja so gut wie nichts. Die haben entweder 2600 Euro oder 3400 Euro. Für die ändert sich da nichts maßgeblich. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, wenn jemand mit so einem Mini-Portfolio mit Einzelaktien rumspielt, dann verschwendet man ja Geld. Wenn man sich ja nur selbst einen Mindestlohn von 12,41 Euro berechnen würde und mal überlegt, wie viel Zeit man aufwendet, um zu überlegen, sollte ich jetzt mal zwei Adidas-Aktien kaufen oder eine Meta-Aktie abstoßen. Wenn man in der Zeit irgendwo Kellnern ginge, würde man mehr Geld verdienen und das könnte man ja dann wegen mir in der ETF anlegen, als sich diesem Podcast anzuhören und danach auch vor seinem Portfolio mit 2.000, 3.000 Euro drin zu grübeln, ob man nochmal irgendwo eine Aktie zukauft. Also das ist eine solche Blödheit, dass man es ja kaum aushält und ich wundere mich auch, dass da bei diesen Hörern von Horst und Hof sich so gar keine Schwarmintelligenz breit macht, weil man ja irgendwo doch mal was aufschnappt, was die eigenen Informationen zumindest irritieren könnte. Aber offenbar ist das nicht der Fall.
Ja, wir machen mal noch so einen kleinen bunten Weg durch die Podcasts. Zum einen Deutschlandfunk Der Tag, da wird dieses größte Problem Europas jetzt mal beschrieben, könnte, wenn man es klug managt, wirklich Ostern und Weihnachten an einem Tag sein?
Wir hören hier in Brüssel, dass man Zusagen bekommen hat auf europäischer Seite, dass es eben nicht zu einem für die Europäer fatalen Effekt kommen würde, dass durch die Tatsache, dass möglicherweise der amerikanische Markt für chinesische Produkte so gut wie geschlossen wird, da steht ja die Deadline von 18 Uhr heute im Raum, diese Überkapazitäten einen anderen Weg finden werden. Und Brüssel ist besorgt, dass das Europa trifft in einer Situation, wo zusätzliche Exporte Chinas in die EU alles andere als gebraucht werden.
Was für eine Formulierung, ne?
Telefonat, gut, dass du es direkt angesprochen hast, Klaus, zwischen Ursula von der Leyen, der EU-Kommissionspräsidentin und dem chinesischen Außenminister.
Also vor Texel ist vor zehn Jahren mal ein Containerschiff irgendwie so verunglückt, da sind so drei Container ins Wasser gefallen, wurden angeschwemmt. Was machen die Leute? Rennen zum Strand, sägen das auf, bereichern sich an dem, was da angelegert wurde. So, das größte Problem Europas ist gerade, dass in den Häfen Europas zu viele Containerschiffe geparkt werden, mit zu viel Kram, den wir die ganze Zeit wollen, brauchen und eigentlich von der Mega-Werbeindustrie uns eingeredet wurde. Das braucht ihr auch wirklich und so. Das ist gerade das größte Problem, das wir haben.
Überkapazität.
Da würde ich nicht so ganz mitgehen, dass wir hier irgendwie beschossen werden oder dass der Zoll Krieg ist. Denen erleidet Amerika. Für China ist es nicht nur in Sachen Produkte und so weiter jetzt wirklich eine tolle Situation. Die haben ja wirklich sehr viele Dimensionen, in denen man es jetzt betrachten kann. Win-Markt, China, Aufstiegschancen und so weiter. Und auch diese neue Rolle. Du hast es ja eben angesprochen. Was passiert in Zukunft? Sagen wir mal die nächsten drei Jahre. Wie ist das Verhältnis? EU, China?
Also im Grunde fühlt sich die chinesische Führung gerade sehr bestätigt. Denn wir dürfen eins nicht vergessen. Das, was die Chinesen in den letzten Jahren wirklich vielen Jahren versucht haben, ist, die USA und die Europäer auseinander zu treiben, auseinander zu dividieren. Im Sinne von, das immer wieder gesagt wurde, ihr Europäer seid einfach nur ein Anhängsel an den Amerikanern, macht doch eure eigenständige, chinafreundliche Wirtschaftspolitik. Und das haben die Chinesen jahrelang versucht, mit nicht so wirklich großem Erfolg. Und jetzt kommen die Amerikaner und sorgen dafür, dass genau das passiert, dass die Europäer und die Chinesen fast schon an einem gemeinsamen Strang ziehen. Klaus hat dieses schöne Stichwort genannt, fast schon freundschaftlicher Ton. Besser könnte es für die Chinesen gerade in dieser Hinsicht nicht laufen. Also das große ganze, das große strategische Ziel, für das sie so lange gekämpft haben, mussten sie jetzt gar nicht so viel tun, stillhalten.
Das ist nicht, also eigentlich gar nichts tun.
Unbedingt alles super elegant gelaufen oder läuft gerade nicht so super elegant, weil es natürlich große wirtschaftliche Verwerfungen und Schäden gibt. Aber das große Ganze, da würde ich so weit gehen und sagen, das passt gerade den Chinesen.
Ja, das meine ich eben, Barbara, mit Schnittmenge. Da gibt es einen Gedankengang, der ist sehr ähnlich und der äußert sich eigentlich in den Worten von Robert Habeck gestern, als sich die Handelsminister der Europäischen Union getroffen haben, als er sagte, wir haben Zeit. Wundert einen ja in dieser dramatischen Lage, wo jemand sagt, wir haben Zeit.
Robert Habeck sagt, wir haben Zeit. Also er ist keine Überstürzung mit, ich will schon mal beobachten, was vielleicht und so weiter ist, sondern erst mal klopft Countdown 90 Tage Trump. Na und danach, eigentlich wünscht man sich jetzt, Robert Habeck als Wirtschaftsminister. Na ja, man kann nicht alles haben. Die FAZ, auch ein interessanter Einblick, die hat ein Wirtschaftskorrespondent in Shanghai, der kurz Stimmung, das war jetzt die Stimmung aus Europa, jetzt hören wir mal Stimmung in China.
Wir sehen natürlich die Reaktion online. Und da gibt es schon eine ziemliche Zuspitzung. Das Schlagwort, was man überall sieht, das Kämpfen bis zum Ende, natürlich immer auch mit einer irgendwie gewissen humoristischen Verarbeitung, da macht man sich drüber lustig, dass auf einmal jetzt Amerikaner meistens als übergewichtig dargestellt, wieder anfangen sollen, Turnschuhe zu nähen oder was auch immer. Aber da gibt es schon irgendwie eine patriotische, nationalistische Zuspitzung. Die Sprecherin des Außenministeriums, also eine der wichtigsten Diplomaten Chinas, zitiert auf X Mao aus Zeiten des Querkrieges. Das ist aus tatsächlichen Kriegszeiten, nicht aus Handelskriegszeiten. Das ist so rein von der Kommunikation, was man hier sieht.
Das finde ich eigentlich am interessantesten. Wir haben uns in China immer gefragt, wie funktioniert so eine Diktatur?
Eine Milliarde Menschen, wie hält man die überhaupt so im Zaume? Wie kriegt man da eine soziale Ordnung stabilisiert? Und was auch immer. Und wir hatten verschiedene Angebote. Das Internet wird zensiert. Da findet innerlich einiges nicht statt. Dann gibt es eine Corona-App, die dir einfach Behaltensbefehle gibt. Dann gibt es dieses Credit-Score-System, das dich einfach belohnt dafür, bei Grünen über die Straße zu gehen und nicht bei Rot. Lauter solche Sachen. Für die Chinesen ist das ja super relevant, dass sich gerade alle hinter einer patriotischen Idee vereinigen.
Konsum ist jetzt plötzlich ein patriotischer Akt.
Aber auch dieses gegen Amerika, sich über die nochmal lustig machen. Das sind ja so Schulterschlüsse, die jetzt stattfinden. Da muss man ja fast sagen, das ist der kommunistischen Partei noch wichtiger als die ein oder andere ökonomische Frage.
Ja, das ist dann die Soft-Power-Dimension, die man da hat.
Genau, dieser ganze Soft-Power-Apparat, der in Amerika so krass vernachlässigt wird, im Ausland sowieso, mit USAID und so, aber auch im Inland. Also dass Trump sich gar nicht darum schert.
Und die haben ja Chris Rock und Hal Kogan.
Ja, aber ich sehe ja Daily Show, den ganzen Kram, und das könnte ja nicht desparater sein.
Sie haben da keine Ego-Monie, gut, dann hat man vielleicht, wen kann man noch von den Kerren spannen? Katy Perry oder so, aber das war es ja auch.
Genau, also es ist wirklich ein ganz dünnes Angebot, dafür, dass Amerika, Hollywood, die Musikindustrie, eigentlich weiß, wie es geht, die ganze Welt und sich selbst in den Bann zu schlagen. Also das finde ich schon ganz erstaunlich, weil wir dann nicht so genau wissen, was das so bedeutet. Also wir können uns Amerika gar nicht als kulturellen Hegemon vorstellen, dass die Filme wirklich alle dann aus China oder Bollywood oder irgendwas kommen.
Also meinst du, wir können uns noch China nicht als kulturellen Hegemon vorstellen?
Das auch nicht, aber wir können uns Amerika nicht als Nicht-Hegemon vorstellen.
Ach so, ja.
Wir brauchen einfach diesen Überbau, da muss man gerne hinfahren können. Sein Kind da ein Jahr lang bei irgendwelchen Rednicks, das würde ja gerade keiner machen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es gerade große Au-pair-Planung gibt für Leute, die ihr Abitur fertig haben oder so. Also nennen sich, da geht schon ganz schön viel verloren und wird in China gleichzeitig so aufgebaut. Und wir sind immer nur, also eigentlich zu affektiv drangebunden, um das mal nüchtern zu betrachten, was das so insgesamt bedeutet. Superinteressant ist ja auch, wie viel Insiderhandel da drin steckt. Also diese Größenbewegung, die wir da gesehen haben, sind ja wirklich...
Also wir wissen ja, was in Chatgruppen alles so publiziert wird.
Auch, genau.
Obwohl Journalisten anwesend sind. Wir können uns also denken, was da noch mal intern bei Trump und den Seinen stattfindet. Wenn da mal plötzlich ein Moratorium angekündigt oder was anderes aufgekündigt wird, da werden schon Leute informiert vorher.
Genau. Ich hab mir auch mal ein Gemini-Deep Research gemacht zu diesem, einfach nur, was ist dieser Insiderhandel? Und diese Klarheit und diese Eindeutigkeit in der DKI einfach, 9.38 Uhr, Twitter, Trump, great time to buy. 13 Uhr wird das Ding zurückgenommen. Man weiß genau, wer Bescheid wusste und wer nicht. Der Handelsminister sitzt noch in einer Anhörung und wird so überrascht. Aber es gibt so diesen Spike in den Orders, 20 Minuten vorher und der ganze Kram. Wenn man denkt, das muss man gar nicht ermitteln. Hier muss man einfach nur die ganze Riegel ins Gefängnis packen und sagen, sorry, aber ihr könnt ja nicht einfach 100 Millionen so hebeln, dass ihr eine Billion Euro gewinnt innerhalb von 35 Minuten. Das ist einfach absurd. Aber in dem Podcast, also hier Adam Curry, John C. DeWalk, ich habe ihn ja mal sehr geliebt vor zehn Jahren, den No Agenda Podcast mittlerweile so abgedreht. Wir hören kurz, wie sie sich über Elizabeth Warren lustig machen. Die größten Verschwörungstheoretiker, die wirklich aus jeder Möcke Elefanten gemacht haben, fragen sich jetzt, wo ist denn hier die Korruption? Das kann man für das Publikum, das man sich erarbeitet hat, Das kann man nicht lange so recht verdingen. Also das clasht dann auch irgendwann.
Ja, das frag ich mich auch. Also wir haben ja häufig gesehen bei den rechten Medienmachern und Podcastern, dass die ja eine gewisse Cleverness an den Tag gelegt haben. Und sie hatten es natürlich leicht. Man wird ja immer irgendetwas finden, was Kamala Harris so gesagt hat, worüber man sich wieder drei Stunden lustig machen kann. Und mitunter waren Angriffspunkte ja auch berechtigt. Aber was wir ja jetzt erleben, ist, dass alle die, die immer in Opposition zu der Regierung standen, plötzlich in Kooperationen sich verstehen. Und das natürlich etwas ist, was dem Publikum doch zuwider werden könnte. Denn diese Anhängerschaft macht vielleicht mal für einen Moment Spaß, wenn die Börse auch tatsächlich nach oben stellt. Wie das ja im November war, als Trump dann gewählt wurde, ging alles nach oben und plötzlich sah man sich tatsächlich auf der Siegerseite und spürte es sogar in seinem kleinen Aktienportfolio. Jetzt ist das nicht mehr gegeben. Und zugleich sind die dabei, immer mehr Lügen aufzutischen, die so offensichtlich sind und die ja auch direkt abzugleichen sind, zum Beispiel mit dem eigenen Portfolio, dass ich mich frage, ob daraus nochmal was anderes erwächst.
Ich glaube, der Backlash wird enorm. Das kann man sich heute nicht vorstellen. Aber die konnte sich auch nicht vorstellen, was Trump wirklich macht.
Ja, ich meine auch wirklich, dass eine neue kulturelle Hegemonie insofern entstehen kann, als jetzt man gewissen Galionsfiguren nicht mehr länger traut, weil man jetzt sagt, Moment mal, aber es geht doch jetzt wirklich gerade schlechter. Was redet ihr denn da? Und wenn ihr da noch nicht mal Korruption erkennen wollt, dann ist doch was nicht ganz richtig.
Jorong schwingt schon um. Plötzlich wird Bernie Sanders abgefeiert für die Argumentation vor großem Publikum, dass es mit der Oli Kashi gar nicht geht. Plötzlich heißt es, also da jemand nach El Salvador ins Gefängnis zu stecken, ist ein Eingriff in die persönliche Freiheit. Das geht nicht. So langsam zieht es ein. Hier noch ein Clip aus dem No Agenda Podcast. Es geht ums Chaos, das allgemeine Chaos. So, also Chaos ist angeblich hier nur die Agenda der Opposition, um irgendwie Trump ans Bein zu pissen. Dann ist aber so, das Chaos ist ja da. Das ist jetzt auch medienhistorisch interessant, der nächste Clip, denn es gab jetzt drei Momente, in denen im größten Podcast der Welt, nämlich The Daily von der New York Times geweint wurde, Tränen flossen. Das erste Mal war als Michael Barbaro mit zum Kohlearbeiter damals darüber sprach, warum er jetzt Trump gewählt hat. Und er erzählte halt so von der Kameradschaft, dass es bedeutet, die ganze Nachbarschaft geht flöten und so weiter und so fort. Das zweite ist ein Gespräch über die Texte von Taylor Swift. Ja. Nicht unbedeutend.
Da hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch geweint, aber aus anderen Gründen.
Genau. Jetzt hören wir den dritten Fall. Und mir geht es jetzt gar nicht so sehr darum, dass die da irgendwie emotional ergriffen ist, sondern einfach nochmal inhaltlich. Wir müssen jetzt inhaltlich nachvollziehen, wovon diese Frau spricht, während gleichzeitig Ben Shapiro und so weiter von individueller Freiheit reden.
However, this is not short-term.
Sie ist so ein Small-Business-Owner. Sie hätte irgendeine Idee für so ein Letzchen, wo das Essen noch mit aufgefangen wird bei Kindern. Das war so ihr eines Ding, das sie dann in China hat produzieren lassen, in Amerika verkauft, lief wohl ganz gut.
This is immediate death to thousands of small businesses.
Wir wissen das nicht. Wir reden mit dir am Freitag.
Oh mein Gott, bist du okay?
Ich schaue mir das Bild an und sehe, dass du nicht okay bist.
Ich bin nicht okay. Ich habe mich für meine Freunde und mich für mich selbst für Angst. Sie verstehen nicht, dass das eine gewisse Todesdurchsicht für uns ist. Es ist eine gewisse Todesdurchsicht für so viele meiner Freunde und mich. Nicht in der litoralen Sicht. Ich sage das nicht in der litoralen Sicht, weil der erste Gedanke, der mir kam, als er die 104%-Tarif annoncierte, war, dass ich zumindest Lebensverschleiß habe, damit meine Familie noch ein Zuhause hat. Ich habe mich sofort selbst getroffen. Ich kann nicht einmal im Moment das, was du gerade sagst, Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, was du gerade sagst. Ja, nein, es ist ein guter Ort.
Du sagst, dass die dunkelsten möglichen Gedanken kurz durch deinen Kopf gehen, wenn du dir vorstellt, was es bedeutet, all das zu verlieren.
Ja, weil mir nichts mehr wichtig ist als meine Familie und meine Kinder Und sie haben einen Ort, wo zu leben zu können.
Eine kleine Unternehmerin, die mit Michael Bobauer von der New York Times öffentlich über ihren Tod aus Verzweiflung als Zukunftsszenario, um auf die Politik zu reagieren, redet.
Um eine Lebensversicherungssumme zu bekommen.
Ja, das ist doch irre. Also das sind auch Verwerfungen auf so verschiedenen Ebenen, die werden sich politisch und gesellschaftlich niederschlagen. Hier läuft nicht nur 90 Tage Trump, also Trump ist in der Handlungshoheit und der Countdown läuft von ihm gesteuert, sondern hier laufen auch so andere Countdowns gegen ihn. Das ist nicht lange durchzuhalten. Aber es ist nicht alles schlecht. Deutsche Nachrichten.
Trotz Konjunkturkrise, die Gehälter von DAX-Konzernvorständen sind im vergangenen Jahr gestiegen um insgesamt gut 10 Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr. Laut Handelsblatt betrug ein Vorstandsgehalt im Schnitt rund 6,3 Millionen Euro im Jahr.
Ja, das wollen wir gar nicht so genau wissen, denn wir wissen von Wolfram Weimer, das ist auch eine Privatsache. Da muss man nicht über Managergehälter jetzt noch mal so transparent reden.
Nein, muss man auch nicht.
Das wollen wir gar nicht.
Zum Abschluss, heute reden wir noch kurz über den Krieg. Offen bleibt der Sozialstaat. Das sind super interessante Clips, die gucken wir entweder vor dem Salon oder mal gucken im Mai. Gewaltenteilung, also es sind noch einige interessante Sachen, aber wir machen mal hier Israel. Das, was da in Gaza gerade stattfindet, also ich habe gestern eine Story aus Gaza geteilt, wo einfach klar wird, also das alles zerstört. Also es war in einem Maße zerstört, dass ich bei Instagram ungefähr 15 Nachrichten kriegte mit ist das echt, ist das die Unreal Engine, sieht Gaza wirklich so aus? Und ich dachte mir so, ja klar sieht Gaza so aus, Gaza sieht auch schon seit einem halben Jahr so aus, also das wird jetzt nicht super aktuell gewesen sein, bis mich dann eine Person und du noch darauf hinwies, dass der Typ, dessen Story ich geteilt hatte, auch antisemitischen, also klar antisemitisches Zeug so.
Paustet, ja.
Genau. Und das war schon, also passiert ja immer mal, weil jeder verbrennt sich die Finger mit Israel, deswegen findet man das eigentlich nur auf Accounts, die auch irgendwann mal antisemitisch klar gepostet haben.
Sagen wir es so, es ist ganz interessant, mir ist es jetzt bei Twitter mehrmals aufgefallen, bei Instagram bin ich ja da gar nicht so politisch unterwegs oft. Nun, habe ich gesehen bei Twitter, dass dort Accounts sind, die tatsächlich Videos teilen oder Fotos teilen von realem Leid in Gaza. So dann eben so eine totale Zerbomberung, wir sehen Bilder, da ist kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen und das ist jetzt nicht im übertragenen Sinne gemeint, sondern es ist wirklich so. Und wenn man dann diesen Kanal aufruft, dann sieht man aber zum Teil, nicht bei allen, aber man sieht es mehrfach jetzt oder ich würde sagen vermehrt, dass da Accounts sind, die zugleich antisemitische Propaganda posten, Memes posten. Also beispielsweise Videos, in denen irgendwelche Comic-Figuren auftreten und immer wenn irgendjemand Böses da ist, dann wird ein Tuch hochgehoben und darunter steckt ein Jude und der ist dann auch so gezeichnet wie im Stürmer. Und man ist so verblüfft darüber, dass das als Quelle plötzlich ja nicht mehr dann haltbar ist. Also ich kann das Video dann nicht teilen von so jemand, der so einen Account hat. Zugleich aber ist es sehr schwer, es gibt auch solche Kanäle, aber es ist sehr schwer, an seriöse Berichterstattung zu kommen, beziehungsweise wo nur diese seriösen Bilder kommen und nicht irgendein antisemitisches Zeug verbreitet wird. Was aber dann bedeutet, dass sehr viele seriöse Medienhäuser sich scheuen, diese dramatische Lage in Gaza abzubilden. Und dass Leute dadurch so ein Video finden und dann in andere Kanäle reinkommen, wo sie eigentlich gar nicht sein sollten, weil sie die Videos woanders nicht bekommen, die Bilder nicht bekommen. Und dass da in einem so erheblichen Maße, dass noch immer verschwiegen wird, was da eigentlich passiert, dass also dieser mörderische Krieg noch immer nicht so benannt wird und dass man immer noch so tut, als sei das alles noch zu rechtfertigen, aufgrund des siebten Oktober. Ist für mich nicht verständlich. Und ich glaube auch, dass der Antisemitismus auf diese Weise einen Zuwachs erlebt, wenn plötzlich nur noch antisemitische Kanäle oder viele antisemitische Kanäle plötzlich die Realität von Gase aber auch abbilden. Dann verwischt da wirklich alles. Das heißt, es müsste jetzt gerade, um antisemitische Denkweisen zu verhindern, um sie zu bekämpfen, müsste jetzt jedes seriöse Medienhaus real das abbilden, was da auch der Fall ist und sich dann nicht die ganze Zeit wegducken und nochmal die Staatssouveränität und was weiß ich alles. Wie heißt das?
Selbstverteidigung, Staatsräson.
Staatsräson und all das, Herr Weihofen, das braucht man da nicht, sondern man kann auch da klar beurteilen, was da gerade passiert. Und dass das nicht der Fall ist, finde ich wirklich dramatisch.
Ja, ist ein interessantes Paradox, aus dem man nur mit aktiven Handeln rauskommt. Ansonsten ist jedes Verschweigen, das aber auf ein reales Interesse stößt, Vorschub leisten für Antisemitismus, weil so ist nun mal die Medienrealität. Wenn man den Kanälen folgt, wenn man sich für etwas interessiert, besteht man immer in der Gefahr, dass man die anderen Sachen, die man dann auch noch so sieht, auch interessant findet. Und im Gegenpol, also in den Tagesthemen, wird über Gaza so gesprochen.
Israel hat seinen Militäreinsatz im Gaza-Streifen ausgeweitet und in der Nacht zu heute ein Krankenhaus in Gaza-Stadt mit Raketen angegriffen. Ziel war der Armee zufolge eine Kommandozentrale der Terrormediz Hamas. Diese habe von dort Anschläge auf Israel geplant. Zuvor sei eine Warnung ergangen, um unbeteiligte Personen zu schützen. Verletzt wurde beim Angriff offenbar niemand. Es wurde aber neu dringend benötigtes medizinisches Gerät zerstört.
Also das Ausmaß, in dem die israelische Regierung Befehle gibt und sagt, das ist Hamas, sind, weiß nicht genau, aber nicht ganz unvergleichbar zu Putin gibt ein Befehl an seine Militärs zu sagen, da sind Nazis.
Ja, natürlich.
So, und Jens Riva würde niemals so über den Ukraine-Krieg sprechen. Putin hat seinen Einsatz ausgeweitet. Ein Krankenhaus wurde getroffen.
Aber man hat vorher auch Bescheid gesagt.
Man hat vorher Bescheid gesagt.
Vor allen Dingen auch immer wird so getan.
Und die Regierung sagt, da sind lauter Nazis.
Als würden immer alle Angriffe Bescheid gesagt werden und als hätten die Palästinenser auch jederzeit die Möglichkeit, irgendwo dann sicheren Unterschlupf zu finden. Das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Also für Bescheid sagen, also anrufen braucht man Netz und Strom.
Ja.
Sonst klappt das alles nicht. Naja, dennoch gab es erstaunliche Nachrichten. Und das meine ich jetzt im Tenor, wie Bericht erstattet wurde. Im heutigen Journal, im April.
Absichtliche Tötung von Rettungskräften. Also im Grunde nichts anderes als die Hinrichtung von humanitären Helfern. Das ist der Vorwurf, den der palästinensische Rote Halbmond, eine Schwesterorganisation des Roten Kreuzes, heute gegen die israelische Armee erhebt, nach deren Angriff im Süden des Gazastreifens, bei dem Ende März 15 Sanitäter und Zivilschützer getötet wurden. Die israelischen Soldaten hatten die Leichen und die Rettungswagen danach im Sand verscharrt.
Also an solchen Fällen hier merkt man, es gibt irgendwie keinen richtigen Korridor mehr für Berichts-, Verdachtsberichterstattung. Sondern es muss wirklich super eindeutig sein, dann ist man entsprechend kritisch. Aber solange der Verdacht im Raum steht, soll es nicht sein. Will man es nicht berichten. Also dann wird es aussortiert. Und dann mal hier diesen Fall, wo es einfach super klar war, was passiert ist.
Israels Armee weist die Vorwürfe zurück, behauptet unter den Getöteten sein Mitglieder der Hamas, ohne dafür Belege zu nennen.
So, ohne dafür Befehle zu nennen, kommt natürlich die Ansage, das waren alles Hamas-Kämpfer und das heißt nein, es waren halt medizinisches Notfallpersonal. Hier eine Berichterstattung von vor Ort, ein israelischer Soldat erklärt mal, wie die Rationalität vor Ort aussieht und ich denke mir so, nee, das ist alles Anlass für sehr viel Berichterstattung, weil sehr viele Fragen aufwirfen.
Er erkennt die Einheit gut, Hanok Dauber, Oberstleutnant der Reserve, hat selbst in Gaza gekämpft. Ihm besorgt er zunehmend der Einfluss rechtsextremer Minister auf die Soldaten. Leider sehen wir in den letzten zwei Jahren den Einzug der Politik bei der Armee. Die Soldaten bekommen von allen möglichen Meinungsführern oder Politikern einen Blick auf die Dinge, die nicht unbedingt mit den Werten der israelischen Armee vereinbar sind.
Er kritisiert einen zu hohen Einfluss der Politik auf die Armee.
Ich dachte immer, die Politik schickt die Armee los.
Wie kann man denn das so sagen?
So eine eigenständige Bewegung nochmal innerhalb eines Staates, oder was, die ihr eigenes Hüpfchen kochen. Also ist ja klar, dass die Politik das anleitet und dass Netanyahu mit seinen Leuten nichts Gutes im Schilde führt und überhaupt nicht daran interessiert ist, dass Frieden in Gaza passiert, sondern da ja in einem Maße Unrecht begeht, wo man ja nicht zu schweigen darf. Also auch, dass man sich jetzt irgendwie nachrichtlich damit abgefunden hat und es kaum noch vermeldet wird, nur noch so in Videotexten oder so kann man es vielleicht mal lesen. Na, gibt es noch Videotext, aber so kurze Meldungen noch irgendwo nur geschrieben, aber nicht mehr in den Tagesthemen wirklich vorkommt oder was. Einfach, dass dort jetzt Kinder mit Unterernährung auf die Welt kommen. Also man hat da eine Hungerkatastrophe, die medizinische Versorgung ist katastrophal, dass das jetzt einfach Tode und Missbildungen, alles Mögliche produziert. Da kann man ja nicht sagen, naja genau, das ist ja wegen des 7. Oktober. Das ist ja Unsinn. Das ist ja eine Logik, die man überhaupt nicht herholen kann. Und das ist eben auch interessant, wie das so auseinandergeht. Also ich meine, es gibt ja auch, und das ist eher so im amerikanischen oder im britischen Kontext zu sehen, so linke Aktivisten, die sich eigentlich so mit Ungleichheit oder so beschäftigt haben, wie jetzt jemand wie Owen Jones, und die jetzt seit dem siebten Oktober nur noch Gaza als Thema machen. Und das find ich auch ein bisschen eigenartig, wo ich denke, naja, welchen Kampf für dir denn jetzt da eigentlich gerade? Also das sind diese berühmten Doppelstandards. Aber dass man nicht in der Lage ist, bei den liberal-konservativen Medien, wirklich auch über die Situation in Gaza so zu berichten, wie sie ist, und auch mal tatsächlich Druck aufzuüben, auf die Bundesregierung, diesen Kram nicht weiter zu unterstützen mit Waffentieferungen und so, dass das alles nicht stattfindet, finde ich wirklich absurd. Und da sieht man diese enormen Doppelstandards. Wir können ja noch uns ein Doppelstandard ansehen.
Also drei Clips.
Ja.
Denn wir könnten jetzt einfach uns selbst die Übersetzungsleistung abbringen, zu sagen, ab jetzt ziehen wir immer Lehren aus der Ukraine-Berichterstattung auch für Gaza zum Beispiel. Weil einfach der Krieg als Dämon, wie von Alexander Kluge beschrieben, wenn der Kriegsfiebel ein Ding für sich ist, mit dem dann beide Kriegsparteien hantieren müssen, denn Frieden ist fern. Und wie fern Frieden sein kann, hat man im Deutschlandfunk Hintergrund gehört, am 5. April, ist wirklich sehr eindrücklich. Also es ist ohne Bilder, es ist Radio, wir bekommen also nichts gezeigt, sondern wir hören einfach nur, wie Protagonisten im Krieg, ausgeliefert dem Krieg, darüber reden, was sie da tun und erleben. Und ein ukrainischer Soldat erklärt mal, wie sehr ihn der Krieg eigentlich entkoppelt von Staat und Politik, während wir doch dachten, der Krieg ist doch dieses ganz gewaltsame, radikale Ausleben von einer politischen Idee, eines Befehls oder was auch immer.
Die Weiterführung der Politik mit militärischen Mitteln.
Genau, so und dann hat Alexander Kluge gesagt, nee, nee, der Krieg selbst hat so ein generatives Moment, gegen das man sich erstmal, eigentlich müssten beide Kriegsparteien gegen den Krieg sich wenden und so und nicht gegeneinander kämpfen. So und das wird hier ganz eindrücklich erzählt.
Das ist Alltag. Sie greifen an, wir töten sie. Sie greifen wieder an, wir töten sie. Manche rennen, versuchen zu fliehen, manche geben direkt auf. Man kann sie auch in den Suizid treiben, sie mit der Drohne zur Erschöpfung jagen, damit sie sich in die Luft schreien. Wir unterhalten uns hier so gut wie können.
Ivan klingt beiläufig, macht zynische Witze. Auch über seine Prothese. Er habe immer eine zweite dabei, falls er sein anderes Bein auch noch verliere, scherzt der 30-Jährige. 2022 tritt auch Ivan auf eine Mine und verliert seinen Fuß. Trotzdem kehrt er zurück in die Armee. Schon 2014 meldet er sich freiwillig für den Krieg. Heute interessiere ihn das zivile Leben nicht mehr, sagt er. Und Politik und Diplomatie erst recht nicht.
Für mich ändert sich nichts. Ich sitze ja mit meinem Gewehr in der Scheiße und so wird es auch bleiben. Ich beschäftige mich nicht mit den politischen Spielen.
Für mich zählen mein Frontabschnitt, meine Leute, meine Arbeit.
Kann man fast schon so aufschreiben und man hat so eine Poetik davon?
Du hast ja vielleicht den Film Warfare schon gesehen von Alex Garland, der jetzt gerade in den Kinos ist. Der zeigt einen Irakkriegseinsatz und da wurde mitunter Kritik laut, warum man denn jetzt diesen Angriffskrieg der USA plötzlich für Hältentum glorifiziert. Das ist aber gar nicht Absicht des Films und geschieht auch nicht, denn was da eigentlich gezeigt wird, ist eine konkrete Mission, nicht mal einen Tag lang ist diese. Und dort gibt es einen Häuserkampf. Man weiß nicht, warum. Die Soldaten dort wissen es auch nicht. Es gibt zwei Verwundete plötzlich, um die man sich die meiste Zeit kümmern muss. Also wir sehen dann auch so, die Kameradschaft ist ja nicht eine, die aus so einer Freundschaft entsteht, sondern es ist einfach die absolute Notwendigkeit dann. Und es gibt für diese Soldaten nur noch, gehe ich einen Schritt nach dort, könnte ich dort erschossen werden? Oder gehe ich einen Schritt nach dort, werde ich da erschossen? Wann kommt eigentlich dieser Hilfstrupp? Wer hat noch ein Gewehr draußen auf der Straße liegen lassen? Das muss zurückgeholt werden. Es geht also überhaupt gar nicht um Politik. Es ist eine völlige Dekontextualisierung, die der Film vornimmt, weil die Leute, die im Krieg kämpfen, genau diese Dekontextualisierung auch vornehmen. Und das ist ja das, was wir hier in dieser Aussage wiederfinden. Und was damit einhergeht, ist natürlich auch eine totale Verrohung, wie wir das jetzt gerade da hören. Und wir könnten jetzt ein Interview von einem russischen Soldaten abspielen, und er würde ähnlich darüber sprechen. Und diese Verrohung, die können sich ja auch diejenigen, die jetzt gerade für Kriegstüchtigkeit bei Twitter und sonstwo plädieren, in dem Sinne gar nicht vorstellen. Und seien wir mal ehrlich, wir reden ja da auch vorwiegend von Leuten, die jetzt diese Kriegstüchtigkeit einführen, die viel zu alt wären, um überhaupt in den Krieg zu gehen. Und die, ich gestatte mir die Anmerkungen auch oft Körper haben, wo ich sagen würde, also allerhöchstens noch an der Gulaschkanone ist da was zu gewinnen.
Ja, so, jetzt können sich sehr viele Leute im Frieden plötzlich einen Krieg vorstellen und wir fragen uns, seid ihr euch sicher? Jetzt fragen die ihn im Krieg, ob er sich eigentlich Frieden vorstellen kann.
Im Schützengraben hat man viel Zeit zum Reden, manchmal zu viel.
Manchmal kommen dir von der Form zurück und einer sagt, ich will mit dir reden und du denkst dir, in 40 Tagen hast du dafür nicht genug Zeit gehabt, mir reicht's, lass mich ein bisschen entspannen.
Nach dem Krieg wolle er eine Arbeit finden, in der er nur von wenigen Menschen umgeben sei, sagt Vasil. Vielen ukrainischen Soldaten geht es ähnlich, Menschen, Massen überfordern die Männer. Unter Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten fühlen sie sich zunehmend unwohl.
Ja, der Krieg geht ja viel länger, als der Krieg dauert. Das muss man sich auch mal klar machen.
Das dauert ja immer alles ewig in den Köpfen, in den Gewohnheiten, in dem, also mehrere Generationen war ja alles thematisiert. Ein Clip noch aus so einem Lazarett, denn so wie man so einen Film einfach unterstellen kann, der bringt ja dann Heldentum rein, weil halt einzelne kleine Handlungen sehr mutig gelingen, aber halt im Großen und Ganzen man sich fragt, warum war das jetzt überhaupt notwendig? Hier wird jetzt auch so gezeigt, dass einige in der großen Katastrophe noch Konstruktivität und Ordnung finden, die sie dann aber auch brauchen. Für Menschen, die sich sehr gerne psychologische Rätsel stellen, wird es jetzt sehr fragwürdig. Also hier kann man sehr lange drüber rätseln.
Während Olay versucht, die starke Blutung am Arm zu stoppen, sediert Anästhesist Oleksandre den Patienten. Er wurde von einer Drohne angegriffen. Granatsplitter haben sich durch Beine, Arm und Kopf gebohrt. Oleksandre atmet sichtlich erleichtert auf, als es ihm gelingt, den Soldaten zu stabilisieren.
Das ist wirklich schwer zu erklären. Genau für solche Momente bin ich Anästhesist geworden. Es gibt mir Kraft, jedes Mal, wenn wir Schwerverletzte haben und es gelingt, sie gut zu behandeln. Wir haben hier oft Patienten mit starken Verletzungen, die fast nicht mehr zu retten sind. Das ist sehr schwer zu ertragen. Aber wir halten nur wegen solcher Fälle durch, wo wir viel ausrichten können. Das fühlt sich einfach nur gut an.
Ja, wenn man aus so einem Einsatz, wo man nur hinter davon, nur als Arzt und so zu tun hatte, und dann kommt man zurück und dann heißt es plötzlich, so in allgemeinen Gesprächen, und wie läuft es bei dir? Ja, ich habe jetzt so eine neue Stelle. Als was denn? Marketing, was machst du da? E-Mails schreiben. Wow, das ist ja wahnsinnig sinnlos. So, und dann erkennt man plötzlich den Wert des geruhsamen Lebens nicht mehr, weil es nicht die ganze Zeit existenziell ist. Ja, und das ist, glaube ich, eine Art von Einflugschneise in Depression, aus der es wirklich schwer ist, wieder rauszukommen. Weil da sind dann fünf Leute irgendwie gestorben, und man fragt sich so, warum, und man möchte denen noch so einen Sinn mitgeben und hört dann, damit irgendwer Marketing-E-Mails schreiben kann. Ja, also das ist, einmal im Krieg ist Krieg. Da wird es wirklich kompliziert.
Wir hören uns noch kurz etwas an, nämlich man rückt ja nah an Aserbaidschan. Wir haben es ja damals schon mitbekommen, mit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine, als man da einen Deal machte für Energiezufuhr aus Aserbaidschan. Wir kommen dazu, hören aber jetzt erst einmal die Außenbeauftragte der EU, Kaya Callas, wie sie sich zu China äußert.
Genau, das finde ich super interessant, dass wir Callas Clips hören, denn wir wissen alle nicht, wer das ist. Halten uns aber für politisch sehr aufgeklärt.
Na, das ist die EU-Außenbeauftragte.
Genau, ich denke, so sehr viele Hörer hören den Namen gerade zum allerersten Mal. Ah ja, ich habe letztens eine Berichterstattung gesehen zum Thema, wie denken die Russen über den Krieg? Was sehen die so im Fernsehen und so weiter und so fort? Für die Russen gibt es gerade nur zwei Personen in der westlichen Welt, Donald Trump und die Kaya Callas. Und das fand ich sehr überraschend, denn wenn ich über den Ukraine-Krieg informiert werde, höre ich immer nur, was Baerbock sagt.
Strackzimmermann.
Genau, Strackzimmermann. Das spielt alles keine Rolle. Also da läuft einfach die ganze Zeit so ein Bildmaterial mit Kaya Callas. Und wir kennen die überhaupt gar nicht. Also Putin befindet sich im Krieg mit Amerika, Donald Trump und Europa, Kaya Callas. Also mal sehen, wie wir sie jetzt kennenlernen. Okay, das ist ja schon mal sehr gut, denn ich hab auch so ein Clip darliegen, können wir jetzt nicht spielen, aber wie Zelensky sagt, wir haben hier zwei Chinesen. Sie haben die Chinesen festgenommen und ich dachte so, okay, das wird jetzt eine große Nummer. Nordkoreaner okay, aber Chinesen, das geht nicht. Während es noch nicht mal heißt, die schicken überhaupt Material oder so. Dass Kaya Callas jetzt hier gleich all in geht und die Finger in die Wunde legt. Aber es ist der Finger in der Wunde.
Naja, also es ist...
Aber das stimmt, dass Chinesen da mitkämpfen.
Ja, okay, das wäre was anderes. Aber wenn jetzt, aber sie sagt ja der Enabler, also sie sagt ja das quasi nur, weil China wirtschaftliche Verbindung zu Russland hat, dieser Krieg finanzierbar ist. Dann würde ich sagen, naja, also so richtig werden ja unsere Sanktionen auch nicht ernst genommen. Und das liegt ja jetzt nicht nur daran. Und außerdem hat Indien auch seinen Beitrag geleistet, dass die russische Wirtschaft nicht kaputt gegangen ist. Also ich finde es interessant, dass man so eine Provokation wieder hier setzt gegen China.
Wir haben ja dann das Öl gekauft.
Ja genau, aber es wird jetzt bunter. Sie hat Aserbaidschan gesucht und jetzt äußert sie sich zu Aserbaidschan. Wir wissen, die haben einen völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg gegen die Armenier in Bergkarabach geführt.
Man muss noch dazu sagen, brutal habe ich jetzt gelernt. Ich halte Bröker und so würde das niemals ohne brutalen Angriffskriegen sein.
Aber nicht in Bezug auf Bergkarabach, sondern nur in Bezug auf die Yogäne. Jedenfalls, also ähnliche Verhältnisse nur im kleineren Umfang. Also das ist so quasi wie so ein kleines Russland, sagen wir mal. Und es ist jetzt so, dass Aserbaidschan ja eine sehr merkwürdige Rolle hat. Der Mitarbeiter von Sonneborn, Dustin Hofmann, schrieb bei Twitter folgendes zu diesem Besuch in Baku von Kaya Kallas. Dies zeige erneut, dass die Kommissionsspitze Werte vollkommen egal sind. Angriffskriege, ethnische Säuberung, Unterdrückung der Zivilgesellschaft, schwerste Kriegsverbrechen und politische Gefangene spielen überhaupt keine Rolle, wenn die Taten von einer genehmen Seite begangen werden. Dieser Auftritt ist auch ein Schlag ins Gesicht für das Europaparlament, das sich in dieser Angelegenheit in aller Deutlichkeit positioniert hat. Der EU-Kommission ist die Stimme von 450 Millionen EU-Bürgern egal und sie biedet sich lieber brutalen Diktatoren an. Überraschend ist das alles nicht, denn mit der Bestätigung von von der Leyen hat eine Mehrzahl der Abgeordneten des Europaparlament sehenden Auges ihren moralbefreiten Kurs bestätigt. Denn bereits in der vergangenen Legislaturperiode hat sie in dieser Sache konsequent das Gegenteil von dem gemacht, was das Parlament von ihr verlangt hat. Es liegt ein kollektives, institutionelles Totalversagen vor, dass Aserbaidschan dazu ermuntern wird, weiter auf militärische Gewalt zu setzen und die eigene Bevölkerung brutal zu unterdrücken. Im Gegenzug bekommen wir, und dann war ich ganz stutzig, mehr russisches Gas aus Aserbaidschan. Dann habe ich nachgeschaut, was bedeutet denn das? Hab dann per Plexity dazu befragt. Also, Aserbaidschan profitiert davon, sich den westlichen Sanktionen gegen Russland nicht angeschlossen zu haben und nutzt seine Rolle als Energieleferant, während Russland auf neue Handelsparker und Transportwege angewiesen ist, die dann über Aserbaidschan führen. Das heißt, wir haben hier eigentlich so einen Punkt, der dafür sorgt, dass nicht nur China enabler ist, sondern Europa über Aserbaidschan enabler wird für Russlands Politik.
Wir haben ja auch nie die griechischen Reedereien irgendwie mit unter diesen Schirm genommen, sondern die durften ja weiter das Öl hin und her fahren und überhaupt. Es gibt immer diese blinden Flecken da überall.
Aserbaidschan sagt auch, wir sind strategischer Partner von Russland? Wir hören jetzt mal, wie Kallas dieses Treffen zusammenfasst in Baku.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr mich heute hier in Baku zu Hause habt. Es ist gut, hier zu sein. Aserbaidschan ist ein wichtiger Partner der Region. Es ist ein erfreutem Energiepartner für die Europäische Union. Und zusammen haben wir einen großen Prozess in den Bedingungen gemacht. Du hast die Europäische Union geholfen, um ihre Energie zu vermitteln und unsere eigene Energieversorgung zu stärken, wenn die Welt unvergessliche Herausforderungen vorbeiführt.
Klingt alles erstmal so, als würde man sich gut verstehen. Und das so scheint es auch zu sein.
Das war noch Zeit mit der SD.
Es liegt ja nicht lange her, dass wir eine Ampel hatten, die sagte, du großes Schulterschluss, grün und gelb, nicht mehr auf diese alten konventionellen Verbrennungsenergiequellen zurückzugreifen, bedeutet Friedensenergie, Friedenstechnologien und so zu schaffen. Also diese grüne Wende, bei der wir uns immer fragten, sollte sie uns was wert sein und so weiter und so fort. Hier kann man auch schlechtes Gewissen abbauen.
We are also grateful for Azerbaijan's humanitarian support for Ukraine and for your leadership in hosting the COP29 climate summit last year. Multilateral efforts like these show that when countries work together, we can make a real impact on global stages.
Immer noch keine Kritik, wir hören weiter.
At the same time, our relationship is a two-way street. We have a long tradition of partnership. The EU is Azerbaijan's largest trading partner and also biggest investor. The EU has also been a major supporting of the mining efforts in Azerbaijan, helping to clear the legacy of conflict and also help to save lives.
Wir reden ja hier über eine Diktatur, wollte ich antworten.
Die Situation hat ein großes Potenzial für weiteres Wachstum, wie wir heute schon besprochen haben, und wie ich auch mit Präsident Aliyah vorhin besprochen habe. Wir haben die Wege besprochen, um weiteres Handeln zu erhöhen Ich bin die Weitereinbarung, die ich in der Region kenne, die europäischen Union, die Südküste und die Zentralasie.
Und weiter?
Ich bin auch glücklich, dass wir uns auf die Neuen Zwanziger auf ein neues Kooperationalbett mit der Europäischen Union und der Aserbaidschanin begleiten. Das ist eine Beziehung, die aufgrund von mutualen Respekt, Including respect for our member states and on fundamental principles, including the respect for rule of law and human rights.
Human rights and rule of law. Massiv angegriffen, völlig ignoriert, wenn man so möchte, in Bergkarabach. Aber hier tut man so, als hätte man so einen Wertekostüm, das man sich jetzt übergestülpt hat.
Hier sieht man doch mal, was Trumps großer Fehler ist. Man darf einfach den Präsidenten, Präsidenten El-Savadors, nicht ins Oval Office zu einer Fernsehshow einladen und zack, kann man da auch die Gefängnisse voll machen. Das ist halt einfach, sie steht da irgendwo und redet halt. Das interessiert ja niemand.
Ja, außer uns jetzt hier.
Herr Minister, wir hatten auch einen guten Veränder mit der Normalisierung der Beziehungen mit Armenien.
Also man müsste sich jetzt mal vorstellen, lieber Putin, wir sind jetzt auch d'accord, dass wir, dass sie und die Ukrainer das Verhältnis mal normalisieren. Man weiß ja dann, was damit gemeint wäre....
Danke, dass du mich heute in Baku zu Hause hast.
Alles bestens. Ich habe dann mal mir ein Interview angehört, das auch erst zwei Wochen alt ist, vom türkischen Sender TRT. Dort war der Außenminister Yehoun Bayramov zu Gast und der spricht erstmal über sein Verhältnis zur Türkei, also Aserbaidschan und Türkei.
Na Türkei, Aserbaidschan ist nahe Salai, Aserbaidschan, Türkei ist nahe Salai. Offensichtlich hat Präsident Aliyev und Erdogan viel geredet, viel gesprochen. Du und dein türkischer Gegner, Hakan Fidan, auch im Dialog. Was ist auf deiner Agenda top, Wenn du mit deinem türkischen Hintergrund redest.
Es gibt eine sehr unikale Beziehung zwischen diesen zwei Brüderländern. Und wenn wir über die Agenda reden, dann hast du es absolut richtig, dass gestern hier auf den Seiten der Fantalien Diplomatie Forum Präsident Alef, Präsident Erdogan, sie hatten ihre einzelnen Gespräche und Diskussionen.
Warum sollte es da diesens geben? Mit der Biden-Administration verstand man sich aber in Aserbaidschan nicht so gut. Wir hören folgendes.
Die nächsten vier Jahre der Demokratieadministration sind für uns eine schlechte Chance, weil nichts Positives in Bezug auf die USA-Azerbaidschan-Kommission passiert ist. Und noch mehr, weil wir eine sehr pro-Armenische Position sahen. Nicht mit dem Fakt, dass wir, du weißt, wir haben von 30 Jahren Militärverwaltung, von der Zerstörung unserer Territoren getroffen. Wir waren die Täter dieser, du weißt, Unmöglichkeit und Verbrechen der internationalen Gesetzesordnung. Nachdem wir unsere Territorenverwaltung und die Souveränität zurückgegeben haben, wurden wir von einigen westlichen Kapitalen getroffen. Und sogar die Demokraten, die Biden-Administration, sagen wir mal, haben sie gerettet. Oder in anderen Wörtern, sie haben die Wäsche nicht verlangt, zu diesem sogenannten 907-Ammendung zum Freien Unterstützung-Akt, was in anderen Wörtern ein Kind von Sanktion zu Azerbaycan, das absolut unerhörlich war.
Ja, es gibt dieses Amendment, das er da anspricht, also das eigentlich bedeutet, dass ja, dass das nicht eine Zusammenarbeit dann stattfinden darf mit einem Angreiferstaat bzw. eben wo die Lage unklar ist. Das wird aber eigentlich immer ausgesetzt, sodass man dann doch eigentlich mit Aserbaidschan normal kooperieren kann. Und man hat aber das während der beiden Amtszeit nicht weiter mehr ausgesetzt, also gegen Ende der beiden Amtszeit. Und das wird jetzt von ihm quasi wie eine Sanktion wahrgenommen. Also hat sich da die US-Regierung unter beiden quasi ja eher mit der Seite der Armenia solidarisiert und das sieht er kritisch. Jetzt aber mit Trump wird es alles besser.
Also wir sind sehr hoffnungsvoll mit der neuen Administration. Also die ersten Kontakte sind sehr positiv und wir hoffen, dass es neutral benötigt wird und wir werden dieses positive Momentum haben. Bevor du das gesagt hast, hast du die Nachrichten von Präsident Trump über die Situation im Mittleren Osten gesprochen. Und Präsident Trump hat die besonderen Beziehungen mit Präsident Erdogan gesprochen.
Na ja, man hört jetzt so ein bisschen raus, dass er Trump schon ganz gut findet, weil Biden hat die Grenze zugemacht. Aber erwünscht sich eigentlich auch Stabilität.
Was hier noch interessant ist, ist ja, dass Israel erwähnt wird. Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, wie steht eigentlich Aserbaidschan zu Israel? Nun, es ist folgendermaßen, das ist ja ein muslimisch geprägtes Land. 80 Prozent der Bewohner sind shiitisch und auch Aliyev, der Präsident, ist Muslim. Man ist aber das muslimische Land, das eigentlich die engsten Verbindungen zu Israel hat. Also Aserbaidschan hat 2023 als erstes shiitisch-muslimisches Land eine Botschaft in Israel eröffnet. Man bezieht Erdöl aus Aserbaidschan in Israel und Israel...
Aber das ist immer russisches Erdöl, das da nur geprägst wird.
Ich denke, das ist dann auch aus Aserbaidschan direkt. Und Israel liefert Waffensysteme, darunter auch Drohnen, an Aserbaidschan. Und dafür war Bergkarabach natürlich dann der Ort, an dem man das eingesetzt hat. Also so ist die Verbindung da. Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit einem prächtigen Staat zu tun und einem tollen Kooperationspartner für die EU. Fragt man sich zum Schluss noch, und wie ist das jetzt mit Moskau? Auch darauf wird er angesprochen.
Wie ist die Beziehung zwischen Baku und Moskau?
Unsere Beziehungen mit Russland sind normal, gute Beziehungen. Gleichzeitig gibt es auch Bereiche, wo wir Verabschiede haben, aber wir sagen das auch offenbar. Unsere gute Beziehungen mit Russland bedeutet nicht, dass es irgendwie unsere Politik gegen die Waffe in der Ukraine beeinflusst. Weil die Aserbaidsche, die Außenpolitik, sind aufgrund der Normen und Prinzipien der internationalen Gesetzgebung.
Ja, also das Verhältnis ist gut, aber ein bisschen ambivalent. Und man wird sehen, dass man sich mit allen irgendwie gut auskommt. Das ist doch interessant, dass wir eigentlich jetzt so mehrere Länder erleben. Indien wäre ja da ähnlich zu nennen. Also bei Duran dann erheblich kleiner. Die versuchen also in dieser multipolaren Welt, so Plattformen zu bilden, auf denen eigentlich alles geht. Das ist ja fast so ein Schweizer Modell, dass man sagt, hier ist alles denkbar. Also wir kooperieren, obwohl wir muslimisch sind, sehr stark mit der Türkei und Israel zusammen, während Israel und Türkei ja eher wieder ihre Schwierigkeiten haben. Mit Moskau verstehen wir uns auch gut, aber humanitär wollen wir auch den Ukrainern Hilfe anbieten. Trump ist wunderbar, aber auch die EU. Das heißt, das sind so neue Konstellationen, die wir, glaube ich, sehen, wo wir auch gar nicht mehr weiterkommen mit einer ideologischen Zuordnung, weshalb es ja auch so lustig ist, dass man immer so versucht, den Westen jetzt so zu erweitern. Also Aserbaidschan auch mit zum Westen zählt. Die sind ja auch beim ESC nicht ohne Grund dabei. Und dass man aber sagen muss, nee, das ist gar nicht mehr quasi westliche Hemisphäre in dem Sinne, sondern das sind jetzt so neue globale Player, die mal mit dem einen mal mit dem anderen gut können und die vor allem aber eines nicht wollen, Einmischung in ihre eigenen Unterdrückungssysteme, die sie da gebaut haben. Und das ist ja quasi dann mit so einem Auftritt von Kaya Kalles nochmal abgesegnet. Was ihr hier auch immer macht, interessiert uns nicht, aber wir haben eine ganz tolle Energiepartner-Schaf, die wir jetzt nochmal auf den Weg gebracht haben. Und diese neue geopolitische Konstellation mit solchen Akteuren wird uns glaube ich jetzt noch viel häufiger begegnen. Und Aserbaidschan ist da nur ein Beispiel.
Also dieser Plattformgedanke ist ja nicht verkehrt. Und ich denke für Indianen oder so, die können ja froh sein, wenn sie selber für sich mal so eine Plattform sind, unter der sie alle ihre Regionen und Sprachen mal unter ein Regime kriegen. Aber das ist halt sehr personenabhängig. Wir müssen halt Leute immer so zusammen in der Sauna sitzen können. Ansonsten funktioniert das nicht. Und dadurch kann man es so schlecht auf Dauer stellen. Und man kann die Leistungsfähigkeit überhaupt nicht abschätzen davon. Jedes Mal, wenn dann irgendwo irgendetwas passiert und man braucht aber weiterhin den guten Deal mit Aserbaidschan, muss man erst mal so die Fühler ausstrecken und dann jemanden zum Sondieren schicken.
Ja, die produzieren ja auch hin und wieder dann die EU, wenn es da um Neu-Kaledonien oder sowas geht.
Man kann sich auf nichts verlassen.
Ja, ja, es ist völlig Irr. Jetzt abschließend wollen wir uns noch etwas ganz Kleines ansehen. Und zwar Ed Maillet, das ist ein Erfolgscoach, ein Mann, der natürlich reich geworden ist. Und du kannst dir denken, wie er reich wird mit viel Sport machen, mit tollen Investments und Motivation und all dem. Und dann habe ich einen Clip von ihm gehört, da sagt er folgendes. Und wir alle sagen ja immer, wir haben zu wenig Zeit, wir kriegen mehr Zeit. Er hat ja glaube ich den Vorschlag schlechthin.
Also ich mische Zeit, ich habe kompressiert und kondensiert Zeit, ich habe es geblendet. Mein Tag ist 6 Uhr bis Mittwoch und ich bin nicht verrückt, du bist verrückt, weil du denkst, es dauert 24 Stunden, wie ein Typ in einer Kave 300 Jahre vorhin. Mein zweiter Tag beginnt am Mittwoch und geht bis 6 Uhr. Das ist Tag zwei. Und dann ist der nächste Tag 6 Uhr bis Mittwoch. Was ich jetzt tue, ist, dass ich den manipulierten Zeitraum verändert habe. Ich habe jetzt 21 Tage pro Woche. Stacke das über einen Monat, ich werde deinen Hals kicken. Stacke das über ein Jahr, du bist tot. Stacke es über fünf Jahre, mein ganzes Leben ist anders, als es sonst gewesen wäre.
Die künstliche Zeit hat er überwunden. Ich würde sagen, er hat einfach eine Doppelschicht eingeführt. Und die gibt es auch schon. Das verkauft er jetzt als den großen Zeitgeber.
Das ist ein bisschen wie, es ist mir doch egal in der Realität, ich habe jetzt fünf Tage gearbeitet, ich habe jetzt Feierabend, Dienstag 18 Uhr. Ja, ja. Das ist so...
Husteln, husteln, husteln. Und du siehst ja auch, wie er aussieht, das ist wieder so ein typisches Gesicht, dass wir aus, der könnte dir auch so ein Fast and Furious mitspielen, würde nicht auffallen.
Ich meine, jeder kann seinen Tag einfach so einteilen. Nur das einzige, was man dann gewonnen hat, ist, dass man nicht mehr sagt, treffen wir uns Dienstag Vormittag, 10 Uhr, sondern, lass mich kurz rechnen, am Tag 27, äh, zur Hälfte.
Ja, ich frage mich halt auch, zählt man auch vielleicht an die Jahre an? Das sagt man nicht mehr, ich bin 36, sondern ich bin 72 oder so.
Und die Jahre, ja, klar.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein interessantes Konzept, wer das verfolgt.
Ich finde, das ist was fürs KI-Zeitalter.
Ja.
Meine Idee, mit Judith Musser und Stefan Kühl besprochen, wir lassen alles, wie es ist. Oma Erna redet, wie Oma Erna redet. Das Finanzamt redet, wie das Finanzamt redet. Und dazwischen läuft einfach von 20 Atomkraftwerken so eine KI-Übersetzung, die die ganze Zeit alles passgenau macht. Hier auch. Mir ist doch scheißegal, ob er gerade Tag fünf oder sieben ist. Nur wenn er mir einen Kalendereintrag schickt oder eine E-Mail, in der seine Zeitrechnung steht, muss halt irgendwo ein Atomkraftwerk eine KI betreiben, die das dann auf Montag 12 Uhr übersetzt.
Er tut ja auch so, als hätte man dann wirklich mehr Zeit. Man hat ja nicht mehr Zeit.
Das ist alles so dumm.
Die ist ja nicht menschengemacht. Die Zeit, die wir haben, die ist einfach da.
Der ganze Kontext von dem Gespräch ist mir total egal. Das ist für sich alleine so dumm, was er gerade gesagt hat.
Natürlich. Das ist das Dümste. Es gibt aber auch eine gewisse Hoffnung. Und zwar glaube ich, dass wir jetzt in den nächsten Monaten, Jahren doch einen gewissen Shift, so hoffe ich zumindest, erleben werden. Nämlich, wir haben jetzt gerade schon gehört, die Trump-Anhänger kommen so langsam ins Schlingern, wenn sie noch immer rechtfertigen müssen, was er da macht. Und vielleicht ist doch nicht alles eine Frage des Mindsets. Und vielleicht ist das doch nicht so das neue Idealbild-Mann und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass das jetzt nicht kommen wird von den etablierten Demokraten oder so. Also ich brauche jetzt nicht Kamala Harris oder so, die mir nochmal erzählen, was jetzt so dran ist.
Ich war noch auch nicht auf den Demokraten, egal für was.
Das würde ja nur nerven. Ich spiele jetzt so einen Fitness-Coach. Von dem würde man jetzt auch zutrauen, dass der sich so äußert, wie der davor gehörte. Wir hören jetzt mal so rein in irgendeinem Clip, den der veröffentlicht.
Hier ist, wie man in dem Gym in drei Schritten losgeht. Einer, du wirst ein Programm wählen, irgendein Programm, und du wirst es für mehr als acht Wochen runnen. Nummer zwei, jede Session wirst du rein und du wirst dein Bestes versuchen. Es muss nicht perfekt sein, aber du musst immer hart versuchen, jedes Mal, wenn du rein kommst. Drei, du wirst das für ein paar Jahre tun. Das ist keine sexuelle Antwort. Das ist nicht die Antwort, die du wahrscheinlich hören möchtest, aber das ist die Realität. Oh, du musst aufstehen und hart versuchen, für Jahre und Jahre? Ja, leider ist das der Name des Spiels.
Man könnte sich jetzt vorstellen, dass dieser Typ auch irgendein Video aufnimmt und noch was von Kryptowährungen erzählt und vielleicht auch noch sagt, ja, du musst mal deine Zeit sinnvoller einteilen, mach doch eine Doppelschicht draus, was auch immer. Und außerdem ist doch Joe Rogan unser großer Held. Der hat dann Video aufgenommen, das hören wir jetzt zum Abschluss komplett, zwei Minuten 14, er nimmt Platz, sitzt im Wald auf einem Stuhl und fängt mal an zu reden. Und er ist nur für Fitness-Content bekannt.
Du bist kein Krieger, du bist kein Protektor, du bist nicht zu Hause zu verteidigen. Du bist ein Mann, der ein paar Mal die Weite auflöst, und vielleicht für einen Rund geht. Was die Online-Reihe gemacht hat, ist, dich zu überzeugen, dass du ein Alphamal bist, der Respekt und eine virgine Frau hat. Das ist Bullshit. Schmutzbäcke wie Andrew Tate werden dich glauben, dass Frauen und Immigranten alle deine Probleme verbreiten, dass es diese Schlampe auf den Straßen sind, die die Geheimdienste verbreiten, und dass Immigranten die Wirtschaft verbreiten. Das Erwinden von Faschismus und Lüftung von Weichen ist kein neues Konzept, aber diese Version ist es. Diese Version ist so viel mehr pervasive, weil es von Individuen gemacht wird, nicht von den Staaten. Sie nehmen eine Aktivität wie Fitness, super normal, super sozial akzeptabel, und dann beginnt sie, rechte Ideologien durch sie zu zeigen. Was das tut, ist, dass es nicht nur die Ideologien normalisiert, sondern auch Fitness radikalisiert. Das erlaubt dem Mann, der von diesen Scheißen enttäuscht wurde, sich zu fühlen, als ob seine Ideen normal sind. Seine Ideen sind völlig sauer. Und der Mann, der sie ihm gibt, ist eine witzige, vertraute Source, weil er sein Wissen in einem Raum erprobt hat. Diese Warrior-Typen haben auch korrekte, ängstliche Sichtungen über den Welt. Der Welt krummelt sich um sie herum. Sie müssen sich irgendwo an den Finger pointen und sie müssen sich fühlen, als ob sie etwas tun können. Was sieht so etwas aus für sie aus? Es sieht aus, als würden sie sich aufhören, zu lernen, wie zu schießen, um ein Warrantor zu werden, damit sie ihre Familie verteidigen können. Aber sie verteidigen ihre Familie von dem falschen Gegnern. Der Gegner ist nicht über den Eil. Der Gegner ist hoch. Der Gegner sind Menschen, die im Weltleben leben, die wir nicht fathomieren können. Der Gegner sind Menschen. Ich weiß nicht, was die Lösung ist, aber ich weiß, dass es die Verantwortung ist, jeder andere masculine Mann zu sprechen und diese Arschlöcher zu checken.
Ich vermute, dass wir sowas häufiger jetzt erleben werden. Dass genau solche Typen sagen, ich will mit der ganzen Scheiße nichts zu tun haben. Ich kann viel Gewicht drücken im Fitnessstudio, aber ich finde Andrew Tate trotzdem scheiße. Und das ist ja auch das, was man in seinem Umfeld erfährt. Also da sind ja nicht die Leute, die Sport machen, alle Andrew Tate-Fans. Aber dass das jetzt so ausgesprochen wird und da stattfindet, glaube ich, ist etwas, was erst der Anfang sein könnte. So hoffen wir.
Ich erwarte eh den allergrößten Backlash aller Zeiten. Ich kann mir das gar nicht anders vorstellen, dass wir da angekommen sind, zu sagen, Merkel, Merz und Trump fand ich eine gute Idee. Also, dass wir in Sachen Intelligenz und politische Leistungsfähigkeit weit unter Zufallsprinzipien sind, kann ja nur damit zu tun haben, dass irgendwer irgendwelche Strippen zieht und das genauso will. Also, irgendwer kann, muss es wollen. So. Es ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen verschwörungstheoretisch gedacht, im Sinne von jemand hat die da ins Amt gehievt und so. Aber eine Partei so aufzubauen, dass man sie prägt und dann gewisse Leute dort Schlupflöcher finden, um sich da hochspülen zu lassen.
Philipp Amthor, Jens Wahn, die Frau, die Freundin von Karl Theodor zu Guttenberg. Könnte man noch mal was zu Wirecard an dieser Stelle googeln. Und wir könnten weitermachen. Das bedeutet, dass wir eben sehr mächtige Kapitalinteressen haben, die ihre particulären Wünsche gerne durchsetzen wollen. Und ihnen das auch relativ gut gelingt.
Genau. Es gab so Ortsvereins-Treffen, CDU, keine Ahnung, man kommt da so hin als junger Typ. Sehr viele alte Leute und dann heißt es, also dann gibt es so Leute, von denen hört man oft, aber die sind selten da. Und wenn sie dann da sind, ist einfach klar, der Nimbus des Superreichen kickt hier jetzt richtig rein. Das ist der Typ, dem die halbe Stadt gehört. Wenn der da so was sagt, ist einfach gesetzt. So, dann wird darüber so ein delegierten System aufgesponnen. Wer fährt ihn jetzt zum Parteitag? Wer und so, ne? Also, die CDU als richtig schöner, wie nennt man es nicht Akquise, sondern Recruitment-Apparat. So, der Kanzlerwahlverein. Bisher war das ja so, dass die Grundlage dafür ist, die Leute, die sich davon beeindrucken lassen, dass der Super-Reich jetzt mit einer super Meinung kommt und Recht hat. Die mussten ganz schön viel RTL-Zwei-Frauentausch gucken und Bild lesen und der ganzen Namen. Und das, was wir jetzt feststellen, ist ja, ne, die Leute wollen sich schon schockieren lassen, aber es ist dann Adolescence, White Lotus, weißt du, dann guckt man Nachrichten und sieht Elon Musk.
Aber für ein gebildetes Publikum.
Nee, die ganze Serie, ja.
The White Lotus ist nichts, was jetzt die Masse sich ansieht.
Dass Donald Trump als Businessman galt, weil der Businessman an sich schon so eine Idee erschrebenswert war, die wird gerade so von den Protagonisten selbst eingerissen. Man hört ja nur noch eine Geschichte nach dem anderen von Scheiß Williardärern die ganze Zeit.
Der Mann aus der Wirtschaft mit all den anderen Männern und Frauen aus der Wirtschaft.
Das wird auch so scheitern. Das ist doch, welche particularen Interessen auf welchen Linien dort da gerade durchgepeitscht werden, ist doch so offensichtlich, dass man sich echt fragt, wie stellt ihr euch das denn vor? Glaubt ihr, wir sind wirklich alle doof?
Wir sind gespannt.
Sich einfach so einen Michael Bröker im Dunstkreis zu halten oder einen Gordon Rapinski, die man einfach immer so mit kleinen Freundschaftsdiensten. Klar, gebe ich dir 30 Sekunden Interview, damit du dann wieder sagen kannst, und heute haben wir Söder im Programm und so. Das läuft sich doch alles tot. Ich sehe da große, also ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt, wie es in drei Jahren aussehen.
Wir weisen zum Schluss nochmal darauf hin, erstens, dass ich am 3.5. in Zürich und am 5.5. in Stuttgart bin, gemeinsam mit Jean-Philippe und Ole. Und wir weisen natürlich darauf hin, dass wir uns sehr freuen, wenn ihr diesen Podcast teilt, ihn gut bewertet, ihn weiter empfehlt, auch vielleicht in der familiären WhatsApp-Gruppe, die sich auch fragt, was ist eigentlich Konservatismus. Wir können es jetzt erklären mit Wolfram Weimer. Und wir möchten darauf hinweisen, dass es den Sanon gibt, die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Wir wollen uns bedanken bei denen, die das tun und freuen uns auf neue Abonnenten. Wir sprechen im Salon immer über wichtige Bücher. Diesmal sogar über zwei Bücher. Einmal über die Welt nach dem Kapital von Investor Albert Wenger bei Pippa erschienen. Und wir sprechen über Abundance, How we build a better future von Esra Klein und Derrick Thompson. Wir fragen uns also, wie muss denn jetzt die Wirtschaft neu aufgestellt sein? Was ist zu tun, um tatsächlich ein gutes Leben, ein Leben mit Wohlstand zu führen, das auch sinnvoll geplant ist und sich nur Chaos anrichtet? Ich glaube, dass beide Bücher auch ganz gut dazu dienen werden, dann in den nächsten 100 Tagen zu beurteilen, was die Koalition, die Neue, so alles vorhat oder fast hätte ich gesagt, anrichtet. Wer das also hören will, kann das Ganze einfach tun über Patreon, wenn man da ohnehin schon angemeldet ist.
Nur dann, ja.
Apple empfiehlt sich für die, die nicht umziehen wollen, die jetzt sagen, ach, ist mir alles zu mühsam, nochmal irgendwo einen Account zu machen, dann kann man auch da einmal klicken und dann hat man es drin. Oder Steady, wie ist der Weg da?
Bei uns auf neu20er.de, in dem goldenen Button folgend, oder in jeder Podcastbeschreibung im Text, ist der Link ja auch immer drin. Dann braucht man dann nur seine E-Mail-Adresse, seinen Namen und einen Zahlungsweg. Zum Glück erledigt das Steady alles.
Ja, es ist sehr unkompliziert und man kann den Podcast dann auch überall hören, wo man ihn hören möchte, so wie man ihn immer hört. Man ist nicht dazu verpflichtet, dann auf der Steady-Seite immer den Podcast aufzurufen und nochmal der Hinweis, man kann diesen Podcast auch verschenken an andere. Ja.
Und was lesen wir so im Salon? Das erste Mal habe ich dran gedacht, vorher mir die Texte schon mal zurechtzuleben.
Ich muss es mir noch offen halten, tatsächlich.
Okay, dann gehe ich kurz durch. Meine Kandidaten zwischen Christdemokratie und Rechtspopulismus. Andreas Pütmann in den Blättern. Ein Text, den ich noch nicht gelesen habe, aber er ist schon zweimal aufgekommen in Gesprächen von Frank Stauß zum Beispiel. Außerdem, super interessant, ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, Maga-natalism, also dieser Natalismus durch Maga. Ich habe es ja im Buch schon ein bisschen angedeutet, dass da was kommt, es gibt jetzt hier Programme. Ist doomed to fail, also die New York Times schreibt darüber, wie Trump sich als the fertilizer president, also ich nehme jetzt mal fertilizer als Dünger, aber er möchte sich keine Arzt der Fertilitätspräsident sehen. Walter Borjans, die SPD versucht ja gerade, vorhin kam die Nachricht, während wir hier gerade im Gespräch waren, dass Klingbeier jetzt Vizekanzler wird, wer hätte es gedacht? Und sie wissen ja nicht, wohin mit Saskia Esken. Es wird ja noch interessant im Mai, wenn dann die Liste da da steht. Walter Borjans ist hier in einem sehr langen Text im Freitag mit zur Überschrift, zum fünften Mal verzichten wir auf die Vermögenssteuer. Also in diese Richtung, so wird es gehen.
Prima.
Außerdem Israels AI Experiments in Gaza, aufgeschrieben von der New York Times.
Ja, sehr gut. Über all das und mehr, es gibt dann auch wieder von mir einen Musiktipp, sprechen wir im Salon. Wir freuen uns über neue Abonnenten und wünschen jetzt erstmal einen guten Monat.
So ist es, bis dahin.